[Music]
devops has changed the way we code
devops is a culture that promotes
collaboration between development and
operation teams to enable continuous
development deployment and monitoring hi
guys welcome to this complete devops
tutorial by simply learn in the next few
hours we'll be teaching you everything
you need to know about devops matthew
anaga and anand are industry experts
each with over five years of experience
in the domain of devops will guide you
on your learning journey first off we'll
be going through a short animated
introduction to devops followed by a
detailed tutorial into the concepts of
devops following this we'll teach you
about some popular devops tools then
we'll teach you how you can install git
some of its important concepts and some
popular git commands next we'll teach
you how you can install selenium on
windows and mac about some of its
important concepts about selenium
webdriver and 30 important selenium
related interview questions
following this we'll tell you how you
can install jenkins docker ansible and
puppet in the process we'll also teach
you about jenkins pipeline and docker
compose we'll teach you how chef puppet
and ansible are different from one
another and we'll also tell you how you
can become a devops engineer
finally we'll cover 80 hand-picked
interview questions that you might
encounter in a devops interview before
we begin make sure you subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon to
never miss an update from simplyla
with that other way let's have a look at
our animated introduction
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust well what if we
broke this wall tim and miana work
together in a common space tim develops
each block of functionality of the robot
which is then immediately checked by mia
both are now working simultaneously
instead of waiting on the other to
finish their task as and when a feature
is ready for use they are put together
to build the final product they develop
a common mindset and share ideas to
further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective tim would be the developer
while mia the operations their union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these tim first puts down a
plan in terms of software this could
mean deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes and
their different versions this is called
version control
next this code is fetched and made
executable this is the build stage tools
such as gradle and maven will sort this
out now before deployment the product is
tested to catch any bugs the most
popular tool automating testing is
selenium
once the products are tested mia must
deploy it the deployed product is then
continuously configured to the desired
state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that automate
these stages
now
every product is continuously monitored
in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops lifecycle the integration stage
tools such as jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment this is called
continuous integration
let's now have a look at an organization
that has adopted the devops approach
which of the below sequence of steps
would they follow to develop a software
leave your answers in the comment
section
keep an eye out for the right answer on
the comment section or our youtube
community
giants such as amazon netflix target xc
and walmart have all adopted devops and
seen a considerable increase in delivery
and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost it two hundred thousand
dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse
i hope you guys found that interesting
now we have matthew to help us
understand the basic concepts of devops
and the commonly used tools in the
domain hello everyone this is matthew
and today we're going to introduce you
to what devops is
we're going to cover a few key elements
we're going to take you through how
devops came into being what devops is
you'll also look at the stages and the
tools that are used to implement devops
and dev up practices within your
organization i'll take a look at and
introduce what etsy is doing with devops
and how it transformed how they were
able to be successful and finally we'll
tie everything up by going through the
benefits of what devops is so let's jump
into the first stage here of how devops
came into being to do this i'm going to
tell a little bit of a story and we're
going to use this story to help explain
how different types of delivery models
are used to implement different ways of
pushing software and services into the
world and there are three main types
waterfall agile and then we'll get into
devops so here we have max and max is
actually studying at school and the
story that we're gonna tell here is how
max learned different ways of being able
to delight her customer now the first
way that max learned how to delight her
customer so what max is looking to do is
to complete her assignment at the end of
the year and she's doing this because
her instructor has given her a final
exam and she has to be successful in
that final exam so what is her exam so
she has to be able to produce 200
dresses that meet and delight her
customer now the first approach max is
going to take is she's going to take the
waterfall model and the waterfall model
approach is one where we have different
groups of people separated from each
other so we have max who is a designer
who's going to design the outfit and
then max is then going to give that
outfit to a tailor and then the tailor
is then going to create 200 dresses at
the end of which it's going to be handed
over to the teacher but here's the
problem with the waterfall model is that
you have a cascading delivery approach
where one group hands off to a next
group that hands off to a next group but
finally when the item is given to the
group that actually wants the product in
this case the teacher what we find out
is that because we haven't worked with
the teacher all of the work that we've
been doing has been wrong this is one of
the reasons why that you see such
significant failure rates within it is
that we are delivering solutions and
taking so much time but we're not
getting impact from the people who are
providing us the guidance so this is
waterfall model so let's kind of like
look at some of these elements so how
water forms came into being is that we
have key elements such as requirements
that are given by a group in this case
the teacher but it could be a business
team that you're working with we have
the designer who could be the developers
and the engineers creating work and then
we have people who are then scaling the
work that we're doing at high levels
this is seen as the implementation team
but this could also be your software
factory team that's working offshore and
then finally you want to get back and
get verification from the people who
provided you the requirements in the
first place that you've delivered what
they needed and after all this we go
into a maintenance phase so you know as
there are changes that um happen we have
to do maintenance so let's look at the
next stage here which is agile and the
difference between agile and waterfall
is that you can kind of almost see that
instead of taking three months to do a
delivery with agile we're taking two
weeks to do delivery there are what's
called sprints in agile which are
bi-weekly uh cadence of delivering now
some companies have sprints that are
only one week long some have four weeks
long typically you have two weeks so in
this instance the designer creates a
dress hands it to the tailor and then
instead of the tailor then creating 200
dresses he just creates one and hands it
to the teacher for review well you know
what the teacher then can give immediate
feedback and then we go through the
process again for another two weeks and
we get to the end of that two weeks and
you know what in this instance we've now
created the dress that the teacher wants
from the requirements that have been
handed out what's awesome about this
instead of taking three months to create
an additional 199 dresses we've only
created one dress that was not correct
and then the rest of the dresses are now
created correctly and we can start
accelerating our delivery cycles but
there's a problem we're missing out a
critical element in this model and that
person is the customer and the customer
experience is what's driving devops
because the teacher or the person with
the requirements may believe that they
know what the customer wants but until
the customer actually tries on the
product they're not going to have that
real world feedback and so in this
instance we've created a product that
just doesn't fit the customer and
something has to be done about that so
this is where we start looking at ways
in which devops can be optimized to the
customer so here is the approach that we
have for agile we have the requirements
we have the designer these don't change
we have the development team and who are
creating the product but here is the key
element that does change we have testing
and feedback we have these as continuous
loops that take the information that we
got initially as our requirements
document and we test those with our
customers actually out in the field and
this becomes a continuous loop that is
providing data back into our team and
we're using data and testing to validate
the product moving forward so the goal
for devops is to have disparate teams
working together so you need to break
down those silos you have within your
organizations and have the teams and
connected and when they do they're able
to improve upon each other's skills so
when we get feedback from the customer
that a shirt may fit too loosely we can
then incorporate that and feedback right
back into our delivery loop until we're
able to with just a few stitches adjust
that shirt in real time and you're
seeing this today with a lot of large
websites such as google office 365 and
then later we'll step in and show etsy
where those sites and those applications
those web applications are being updated
in almost real time and this is the
devops approach so the development team
is there for creating the product but
they're they're in alignment with the
operations team who's responsible for
deploying them the product and the two
instead of being disparate teams working
away from each other are closely
connected and the key to this is that
testing element and we'll talk a little
bit more about how these devops teams
using testing and automation are able to
increase and improve the efficiency of
the product that's released so devops is
a software engineering culture and
history is from the world of development
operations instead of them being
separated pulling the two together so
let's talk a little bit about the stages
and tools that are within devops you'll
see at the center of our diagram here
that integration is key for all the work
we do so typically with development you
have planning coding building and then
testing and then within operations you
have deployment operations and
monitoring with devops is how can we
provide the tools that allow these two
worlds to coexist with each other so if
we're looking at planning and coding we
want to be using the tools that allow us
to be able to manage our work that needs
to be done and going through a pipeline
process and code versioning we want to
be able to have the tools that to
automatically collect the code that's
been created and automatically build
those applications and you'll see that
the term automatic is something that is
a consistent with devops testing also
becomes automated so everything that
gets created every time code is checked
into your git repository you want to be
able to test that code and you're doing
the testing so instead of getting to the
end of a project and having a phase such
as regression testing where you're
trying to find all the things that are
not working by having continuous testing
on every single aspect of every piece of
code that you write you're able to
create a library of code that has a
complete and complementary library of
testing so it doesn't matter if you
enter in a new code block your that code
block will be tested against all the
other existing test cases that you have
and then you're looking at the tools and
we have here a couple examples of puppet
and chef which are deployment tools that
when you push out your code instead of
having maybe the different versions of
code delivery you have where your build
environment stage and deployment
environment may be different because
it's difficult to have those aligned
these tools in a devops environment are
ensuring that each of those environments
are completely identical and that when
you push out the code to the production
environment that you're creating
identical environments for the rest of
the development and coding to be created
in and there isn't the issue of well
this runs on my computer but not on your
computer everything is consistent and
then the final stage is monitoring and
this is really critical you want to be
able to monitor the complete performance
of all the work that you're doing really
every single aspect because there are so
many variances on the way in which your
consumers can connect with you from
mobile devices from desktop devices and
now the emerging technologies such as
voice and augmented reality we're seeing
just a huge number of ways in which
consumers can connect with the digital
message that you're sending and then the
heart of devops is integration for all
of these tools and we've provided
example tools through these slides here
but there is a much bigger and deeper
collection of tools that you can also
work with but these are some of the most
popular ones so let's talk a little bit
about the implementation of devops so
the previous slide we talked about
integration particularly with jenkins
being the center of the universe for
everything you're doing and what you'll
see as we go through the next couple of
slides is that it doesn't matter what
you're doing as you move through the
different implementation stages of
devops what you'll find is every steps
through that integration point so what
that means is that instead of having a
clear different gate that you may be
building and deploying your solutions on
what you're actually doing is building
and coding deploying testing and
monitoring simultaneously all the time
and using your integration point as a
way to be able to control how the code
is being delivered so you can be
fetching and building code integration
points are then the way in which you do
that you can be testing your code you
can be doing automatic deployments if
all the right tests are approved and the
the work that's being done within your
deployment tools has been approved then
you automatically deploy you're able to
then monitor and get information back
into your integration point which then
sends back the work that needs to be
done in the planning stages and creating
your backlog and then the next round of
code that has to be created it becomes
this virtuous cycle that feeds itself
so within devops we're looking at a
number of key things we want to automate
and have continuous integration it's not
an event that happens within your
program it is something that is
continuously executed on the same thing
then is for delivery delivery doesn't
become an event what you're doing with
devops is you're continuously delivering
and that delivery is dependent on the
code you write meeting the test you've
written for your integration so
everything that is being tested as soon
as it passes that test you deploy out to
your production environment so how do
you manage the deployment you know
before we have worked in very large
programs that took a significant amount
of communication and effort to deploy
with devops we go in the completely
opposite direction we're looking at
creating
lots and lots of small
implementations i'll give you an example
on any given day office 365 and we all
use office 365 on a daily basis goes
through hundreds of small independent
updates that are built on microservices
the other advantage you have when you
start building elements that are micro
services is that you can connect to
those micro services to build out
additional features and functionality at
a faster rate later a good example of
this is the way in which amazon built
out and scaled up their aws environment
from a few number of services in 2008 to
thousands of services today they're able
to do that because they have implemented
microservices as a way to scale up
rapidly monitoring and logging all
aspects of the application you want to
become obsessive about the performance
of your solution and don't look at the
performance of your solution through a
single lens keep the direction that
you're working on as a way to be able to
delight your customer so that means
building out a website that works and is
optimized for mobile but also ensuring
that that website works for desktop
there's still a lot of people building
out websites just for desktop 80 of your
traffic is going to be mobile traffic
today also bear in mind that the apis
into those applications have to be
monitored and that the people connecting
to your content will be doing it through
multiple different networks some of
those people will be sitting at home at
their desktop and they'll have a high
speed internet connection other people
will be walking down the street and
using their phone and they will have a
slower wireless interconnection another
key point that's different with devops
with traditional environments is that
you want to look at your core
infrastructure as code what that means
is that you want to look at
the environment that you're creating
your solution for so five years ago if
you were building out a solution you
would have physical hardware and you
would install windows onto those servers
or linux onto those servers and you'd
have to build out a series of programs
that would run on those servers the next
evolution was virtualization and that
has continued to evolve until where we
are today is containers and containers
are a way in which you can actually
script out using technologies like
kubernetes to be able to create the
operations infrastructure in just code
and execute it against code the
advantage that you have by doing that is
that you can write in code what the
environment should look like what are
all the pieces of software and what is
the version and then if something
changes where you need to be able to
test that and have your developers in
that same environment you can actually
just give them the code for the
container of what that would look like
and they can immediately have the same
exact environment running so they can be
testing and there is no doubt then that
the code that they are creating will
work exactly the same in the production
environment as it is within their
development environment and then
communication becomes just an incredible
tool when you're working with devops
because you're looking at doing multiple
releases
continuously throughout the day and
pushing those releases to all of your
customers to help continue delighting
your customers and what you can see with
the communication pipeline is you want
to take advantage of tools such as slack
or microsoft teams where you're able to
take all the different tools that we've
been talking about such as jenkins such
as git such as chef and have those tools
talk to your communication tools which
is the tools that your team uses to
share information and broadcast to those
teams when successful updates have been
pushed out and the team as a whole knows
in real time all of the changes that are
happening so let's use an example here
of etsy and where they were able to be
successful so etsy is a very successful
e-commerce site and if you are
into crafting then you probably have
already used etsy you may have even sold
features on sc but the challenge that
etsy had is that um when they were
working in an agile point of view they
were running into problems for when they
were getting ready to release products
into the real world it would take them
up to four hours to update the etsy
website and when you're updating the
website twice a week and you're down for
four hours each time each of those
seconds that you're down you are losing
people to another website and you're
losing revenue and this just really kind
of drove down the number of potential
customers that could be buying from etsy
and so what they realized is that the
updates had to happen both a faster to
meet the constant changes and needs of
the consumer but then the website itself
could not come down and to do this etsy
created a tool called the deployanator
and i just love that name just so the
deploymator is the tool that is used to
continuously deploy code from etsy and
what's great about the deploymator is
that it's open source you can actually
go ahead and download and see the tool
that etsy is actually using the tool
allowed it for the automation of
deployment and what um that led to was
just this continuous release of updates
and etsy today has over 50 updates every
single day i mean think about that etsy
is updating their website every 26
minutes so what are the benefits of
going through devops versus agile and
waterfall and the first and i think
really the biggest benefit is that you
are constantly testing and delivering on
technology in a continuous pattern you
are not waiting for somebody to approve
a release and then having a release
happen you're using the testing and the
analytics to be able to validate that
what you've created will work the second
is that you're breaking everything down
into the smallest tiniest chunk to be
able to validate that chunk will work in
that environment and then you're looking
at automating the whole of this
environment and that automation helps
you reinforce and validate security and
it also allows you to provide a
self-audit track to be able to validate
the uh we're gonna go through what um we
need to be able to do to go to devops
what the arguments are and why you need
to do devops and they will actually go
through all the individual tools you
need to be able to successfully
implement devops within your
organization in addition to that we're
also going to take time and go through
each of those tools so you get a good
understanding of a step-by-step
instructions on how to do basic setup of
each of those tools so let's get started
so what was devops before
so what was the process that we took for
doing delivery before devops well it was
a model called waterfall and waterfall
was a very traditional approach to
actually building out solutions and the
reason why it's called waterfall is that
you bring out all the individual
requirements and individual sections of
a project and they cascade off each
other so if we look at the breakdown we
have requirements design we have
implementation we have verification we
have maintenance you'll have user
acceptance testing and this is all based
on the software development lifecycle
model or sdlc and it's been around for
quite some time and is still used by a
lot of companies today the challenge
you've had with the warfare model is
that it really is a very long drawn out
model for actually building and
delivering solutions so it took a very
long time to actually write code and
then deploy the code and it was very
difficult to actually identify problems
within the code and provide feedback to
the development team on what to fix um
and this really was a very time
consuming we're talking about months
sometimes years for projects to actually
go through a warfare model process so
along came a new method of being able to
do delivery and it's called agile and
the agile approach is a way of being
able to take the actual
work that's done in a waterfall model
and compress it down into small
iterations and what we would do is a
fundamental change is that you would
actually take teams that were disparate
and as part of the individual cascades
within a waterfall project and you
actually bring them together so you have
your requirements team in person design
developer and release management team
all together in one group working on an
iteration the great thing about agile is
that you took a process that was weeks
or months or even years in length as it
was with waterfall and you reduce it
down to two or four week sprints
depending on the cadence for your team
typically you have a two-week sprint and
then the goal is is that at the end of
each sprint or sometimes every other
sprint you would do a software release
and so that customers were getting the
software much faster the problem that we
still ran into though with um agile is
fundamentally similar to what we were
having with waterfall uh you have your
devops person working on code on their
system and you'll be working great on
their computer and then you have the
operations person who's migrating the
code from the developers environment the
test environment to for the production
environment and you would run into
issues where the code simply wasn't
working there's a lot of reasons why
that would happen uh the actual
developer environment would often be
very different or would have different
dependencies in it so the the hardware
the the software there may be additional
uh applications that were installed on
the operating system that simply hadn't
been transferred over to the operations
environment and so what you would have
is a disconnect between the developer
environment and the operations
environment making it difficult um to
actually roll out code so you'd run into
a program where when you rolled out code
you'd have to have a rollback plan in
case the code wouldn't work in
production and so each release became an
event where everybody got very stressed
about the actual event of releasing code
because you didn't know whether it was
going to work so devops really looks to
address and solve a lot of these
problems so the key word that you'll
often hear with devops is continuous
integration and what that means is
essentially that as a developer is
working on their code the code is
constantly being tested against not just
the actual code itself with unit testing
but the environment with which it's
going to be released in and the goal
from a devops model is that the
breakdown of communication that happens
with waterfall and agile where dev
developers and operations teams aren't
working in the same environment is being
removed and you're able to provide a
continuous and contiguous environment
between the developer and the apple
actual operating model so the reality is
when the developer is working on their
code they're actually working in an
environment that is identical to the
production environment and so when the
actual operations person comes to
actually do releases for the code and
you can see some teams are doing as many
as 20 to even up to 50 releases to
production environments every single day
you're able to guarantee that the actual
code itself will work and releases go
from being a stressful event to a
byproduct of good testing and good setup
and structure for how you actually build
out your solutions so what we're seeing
here so the goal is that as a developer
and as an operations person that the
code is working continuously in both
environments you have continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
simply put what we're able to do is
we're able to eliminate the problem of
the operation environment not being in
sync with the development environment
and this is a
improvement on agile this is not to say
that waterfall or agile are wrong as
delivery models what it is is just a
maturity of the ability to deliver
solutions and devops is just another
rung in that maturity curve using tools
that are available to us now that five
ten years ago simply weren't available
so the goal is for you as a team to move
to a devops model where you can
implement continuous releases on your
software as long as you're using the
tools that are available and the good
news is those tools are open source
tools so let's go through some of the
benefits of why you'd want to go and use
devops so you know essentially what's in
it for you so let's over the next few
slides we're going to go through what is
devops we're going to go through the
benefits of devops so in the last few
slides you've actually seen you know
what is devops and the benefits of
devops along with the life cycle but
we're also going to start digging into
the tools that you have that are useful
for devops and we're going to focus in
on seven tools that can provide an
end-to-end infrastructure for delivering
devops solutions but there are
significantly more tools available on
the market but these are seven of the
most popular uh for each of their
categories so devops really is an
essential collaboration between the
development team and the operations team
these are teams that have in past being
somewhat at conflict with each other and
what you have now is an opportunity
where those teams can now work
continuously with each other the
expectation with devops is that it will
continue to mature indeed you're
actually even seeing some groups which
are now called devsecops where they're
integrating security as part of the
delivery between the development team
and the operations team the bottom line
is a devops engineer is highly in demand
the demand for devops engineer is
literally going through the roof with
salaries going up exponentially around
that so let's dig into some of the
benefits of devops it's not just
a new catchphrase it's actually got
significant value and how you can speed
up delivery of your software so the
benefits of devops are really broken up
into a number of key areas first of all
we have continuous delivery of software
which allows you to continuously release
new features with the security and
understanding that the software going
out is of high quality it allows the
teams that are working on the software
delivery within your organization to
more effectively collaborate with each
other so that you're all talking from
the same page and understanding of what
needs to be delivered the deployment
process itself moves from being an event
where there's a lot of stress and
there's a lot of contingency plans to
being a much easier deployment the
efficiency within the actual code that
you're writing the ability to scale up
using the different tools are available
allows you to be able to bring in and
scale up and reduce the teams you have
running the software as needed errors
can be fixed much earlier and more
quickly and can be caught before
anything gets pushed out to the
production environment and fundamentally
what we're looking for is improving the
security of the actual releases so the
actual concept of security is center to
all the work you're doing and then
finally what really allows you to reduce
the number of errors is that there is
much less manual intervention you there
is a greater reliance on scripted
environments that you can actually test
and validate for their security
reliability and uptime efficiency so
let's talk a little bit about the life
cycle of a devops so the very first step
that you'll take is to actually build
out a build and test environment and
this is a continuous building test
environment and this is managed with the
first step of your source code once you
move through that and you're looking at
continuous integration which means that
every time somebody checks in their code
they're validating that the code
actually can run in the production
environment once you've actually then
passed the end continuous integration
and the testing that you have with your
code you're looking at continuous
deployment if the code works and is
available to be released into the
production environment let's go ahead
and release it and once you actually
have release code then you want to be
able to validate that your environment
is working efficiently you may release
code that is a new feature within your
application and customers may then
gravitate immediately to that new
feature if they do you want to be able
to ensure that the code is working and
more importantly that the infrastructure
is there to support and then finally
you're looking at software released as a
continuous event and then you go back to
the beginning you start working on more
code you run it through your build
environment and continuous integration
deployment continuous monitoring and
keep that cycle moving so let's dig into
the tools that you as a devops engineer
would need to learn if we break down the
environment that we have all the way
from source code management to software
release and there are a number of key
tools that you want to be able to use so
for instance source code management and
git is an open source tool that you
would want to use for managing your code
the continuous build and test
environment we managed with mavin and
selenium integration with the
environments that you're working on is
managed through jenkins the actual
deployment to your production
environment will be managed with
products such as ansible and docker and
then the monitoring of your network
would be used with tools like netios the
thing that you have to remember with all
these tools is that they're open source
tools there is no licensing that you
have to purchase uh some of the tools
will have a pro level licensing that you
can choose to select but to get started
all of these are open source tools you
can actually start using for free right
now so let's dig into git so let's look
at the the challenge that git is able to
address so before git and you if you had
a team of developers that were working
on different pieces of code one of the
key problems you have is that there was
no collaboration between the team and
the the challenge you have is that with
version control it was difficult and
often required um having to check in to
a large environment or you had very you
know quasi version control environments
it was time consuming often there were
problems that what would happen if this
the version control server would crash
and there wasn't a backup then you'd
have to kind of essentially go back to
square zero to see whether or not you
actually had to do the work again so
let's look at what git does to actually
solve this so first of all one of the
things that git does is it makes team
collaboration much easier the software
itself is more effectively documented
and more and more effectively maintained
the actual code that actually gets
worked on by each developer in a git
environment is the complete code so it
makes it much easier for backups and for
sharing content amongst each
developer so the way in which git is
able to accomplish this is that it is
essentially a distributed version
control
solution um and what that means is that
when you have multiple developers yes
you do have a git remote hub that you
connect and
are able to upload and download
different branches of the code that
you're working on but essentially as a
developer when you
actually have the code you actually have
all of the code and
you're able to manage it directly from
your local pc or your local development
machine without having to worry too much
about the network or the server actually
going down so some of the key things in
which um git is really good at it is you
know a software management tool is
designed from the ground up to manage
code development it does track the
changes on that code easily and
effectively makes it easy for you as a
developer to track your code the ability
for multiple developers to work together
is much easier in comparison to um other
solutions and and this is really the the
key success point with a git is that it
allows for non-linear code development
so you can actually have people working
on different areas of the code that may
be released at different times because
of what they're working on so if we
actually break down the architecture of
git it really falls into four key areas
of a working directory a local staging
area a local repository and a remote
repository so the process you would go
through is you would add files to the
staging area from your working directory
and this would be usually the get add
command and then from your staging area
when you're ready to actually then
commit those files to a local repository
you use the git commit command and then
from there you would actually then push
your local repository out to the remote
repository for a final commit to the
remote repository um and this allows
then the rest of the team to
pull down your latest final changes so
you can be working on your code locally
and you can be using your
local staging area local repository and
when you're ready to commit your work
you can commit it and as soon as it's
committed the rest of the team can then
pull down the latest changes that you
have worked on and this allows for a
complete and holistic checkout check-in
process and then sometimes you want to
be able to go through and then take the
checked out code that you cram that
you're pulling out and merge it with
your local code and the merge process
always ensures that
you are working on the latest and best
version of the code and everybody on the
team is being consistent with the
communication of the actual code that's
being delivered okay so what we're going
to do is we're going to validate that we
have get running on our computer we're
going to then create a directory add a
file to that directory make some changes
to that file and then use the commit
commands to be able to check in the
files and validate changes that have
been made so first thing we do is we're
going to see if we have git installed
and to do that you just use the command
git version and what your sorry git dash
dash version and that actually then give
you the version number and now we're
going to create a new folder so mk der
green and that will create a new folder
and we'll move our cursor into the green
folder by changing the directory and we
can go back into windows so we can
validate that that directory is actually
there so here we go let's have a look we
should see it there's the green folder
if i double click into that you'll see
there's nothing in the folder right now
so what we have to do is we actually
have to add the folder as part of a git
project and so we're going to use our
get initiate init and then we'll
actually initialize the
folder and make it a git repository and
so let's go ahead and create a file
that'll actually go inside of
that new initialized folder and you'll
see that there's a dot git folder that's
been added so the new text file we're
going to create is going to be called
class and they'll actually be class.txt
the extension is hidden by default in
the uh text file we're just gonna type
in the text uh welcome to simply learn
and save that now let's go ahead and
check the status um of that file in get
so let's do git status and you'll see
that it says yes there's a file there
but it hasn't been committed to the
repository that's why it's in red so
what we have to do now is commit the
file to the repository and it won't be
able to track any changes that we do to
that file so let's go ahead and commit
the file so we do commit add
class.txt and they'll add that to the
repository and there we are it's added
and the final step is we want to do is
commit it let's do git so let's do git
commit dash m put in this will be our
first commit and this is the description
and so it actually shows us committing
the
file it's the only item in the folder so
now we can go over to the file that we
just created and we can make some
changes to it so let's open up the files
so it says welcome to simply learn uh
let's put in some text afterwards that
says this is my demo and we'll save that
close that and now if we go back to git
we can do a comparing contrast between
the original file that we committed and
the new um updates that we've just done
and we can check the difference by using
git diff and what you'll see is the
red text was the original text and the
green text is now the new text that's
been added and so that shows you how you
can actually go and create
a new git repository go through adding
files committing the files into the
repository and being able to see the
different version controls let's move on
to maven so why use maven so so why use
maven well let's look at some of the
things that you would have done in the
past if you actually building out the
tasks so let's break down what you would
have done before using maven if you were
to create a game of football using java
you would actually have to go out and
for your actual game you would have to
collect all the different components
needed within the java environment to
make sure that everything would work
correctly and if you made the slightest
mistake you wouldn't get the right
output that you needed the actual
process of building and applying a
project really would take quite a lot of
time after maven maven allows you to be
able to take templates that are stored
locally and be able to use those to be
able to improve the efficiency of being
able to build out your environment by
removing dependencies within the
application it makes it a lot easier if
you be able to focus on just writing the
code for your game or your solution
rather than having to manage the
environment within which that solution
would be deployed now the focus within
mavin is that it is an automation tool
and it's used for projects that have a
short period of time so as you're
starting on your environment for
building out um solutions mavin is great
to get started with and then if you need
to have a longer term projects then you
can look at other alternative tools on
the market so four key areas that you
want to focus on and why mavin can help
you is that it does allow for efficient
um parallel builds to be run
concurrently it's really easy to use you
can get up and started with mountain
very quickly uh you do have fast access
to new features and new configurations
quickly within your environment and the
build process that will allow you to be
able to visualize your code happens very
quickly the actual architecture of mavin
is that the execution and commands are
managed through what's known as a pom
file the pong file itself is a project
object model and it's an xml file that
actually has the details for the project
and the configuration for the build
environment prompt file itself will then
fetch dependencies from the local
repository and will apply any plugins
that you may have also included within
your mapping environment the goal is
that your software is built much more
controlled
manner so what we're going to do now is
we're going to show you how to go
through and run at your very first
project using maven the first steps you
can have to do is make sure that you
have the latest jdk installed on your
computer so we're going to go ahead and
open up our web browser and get this
installed on your computer so we're
going to type in jdk download into our
chrome web browser
and go to the oracle website which
allows us to download the jdk now
because we're running this on windows
we're going to download the windows
version of the jdk
and once you have that installed
so the next step is to actually then go
ahead and download the maven files so
it's going to take us to the maven
apache.org website where you can
actually go ahead and download the
version of maven that you need for your
operating system we're going to go ahead
and download the zip file instead of
just an executable file and this will
give you more control over how you
install it onto your windows pc after
the file has been downloaded we want to
go ahead and extract the entire file so
you have the unzipped folder running on
your computer
so one of the things that we're gonna
have to do is go through and set a
number of system variables for the jdk
and for the path to your maven files and
to do that you want to go into your
control panel and select the system
security and system settings and then go
into advanced system settings this will
give you access to
the
edit system variable setting that you're
looking for
so we're going to go down to the path
variable and you'll see already that we
have pasted in the link to the jdk
right there underneath the variable
value if you've installed the jdk it's
likely that it's already installed this
path for you correctly
the good news is actually fairly easy to
install the path to maven and to the jdk
because all you have to do is copy the
path for where the folder is located on
your system and just paste it into the
variable value under the edit systems
variable fold and file system
and that should now get us all the files
and you can see that we have our
extracted folder already on our desktop
there
and the system path is now
set to where the maven folder is located
so we also have to go into system
protection and
set the system path to your maven folder
now we have to go ahead and do a user
variable that also part and links to the
path for maven files
so what we're doing right now is we're
just validating that all the files have
been extracted correctly they have which
is good we can now go ahead and link to
this moment folder
all right so now we're going to do is
we're going to move over to command
prompt this is where we're going to do
most of our work from here on out first
command we're going to do is uh mv
so we're going to go ahead and create a
new user variable and
we're going to type in we're going to
call this one m2 dash and then we'll put
in the path to the apache maven folder
you should be able to use m2 dash home
uh for your project if it's not you can
always use the variable name maven dash
home and that will do exactly the same
as
m2 we're going to do both here just so
we have a backup
so we're gonna open up command prompt
and we're gonna see if maven is
installed we do that by writing mvn dash
dash version
and here we are yes so now we're going
to go ahead and create our first maven
project and the first part of creating
the maven project is actually the
directory in which we will store the
files that will be used to create for
our project
so we're just going to go ahead into the
folder and we're going to create a new
directory and we're going to call this
one and we're going to call it simply
learn
and we can just copy the path for that
so i'm going to write this the
correct path for us so we're going to
change directory cd and copy the file
location over all right we are now moved
ourselves over to the simplyland folder
and we'll be able to install the pom
file which is what all the instructions
from mavin are stored in uh into this
area so to do that we're actually going
to use a template that's already been
created by mavin and this is going to be
the mvn archetype template and so you
just do nvm archetype colon generate and
this will go ahead and create all the
files for us
so this can be quite a few files and
they're all being downloaded from the
mavin website
so it can take some time but as you see
we've gone ahead and all the files have
downloaded and we have everything up and
running correctly inside of our
environment on command line and command
prompt so we'll have some values that we
do have to set the first one is group id
and we're going to call this one
com.mav and then the next one is going
to be artifact id and this is going to
be
mav mav dash project hit return and then
version is going to be
1.0 snapshot which is put in the same
value for this
version which would be 1.0 dash snapshot
and the package we're going to call this
one com.mav.demo
and then we'll select yes so wife to
create the environment and it will build
the environment for us
and what we have now is we have this
screen which shows everything is up and
running for us and we have a successful
build and so let's go into the maven
folder and just see that we have our
simply them folder let's open up and see
what's in there so we double click into
that directory
yep and there we are starting to see
some of our files so it's um the same
project names there as mav dash project
and then we have our pom file that's in
there which is fantastic under the
source folder we'll actually see
the uh the demo and we have our app
under the demo app
we have our test file as well
so in the main folder we have a file
that's called the pom file and that
really is the most important file that
you need for your project you'll now go
and you'll be able to set all your
settings inside of that file but that's
it that's what we have done here we've
gone through and we've gone through all
the setup that allows you to
make sure you have the right files
running on your computer the right files
to download from the maven website how
to install all the files the settings
you need to make on your windows
computer and then all the settings that
need to be done in the command line to
be able to run the application and then
from here you can actually start running
maven now let's look at selenium as we
get start looking at testing so before
selenium if you wanted to run testing
and particularly if you want to do
sequential testing it would take up a
lot of time you'd have to run one test
and the second test and then all the
other tests and the actual time elapsed
would be quite significant
with selenium you're actually able to do
parallel testing so instead of looking
at the amount of time it would take to
actually run a test and run the test
sequentially the length of time to
actually run your test is based on the
length of the longest running test of
which in this example uh the longest
running test is two minutes now one of
the things that you'll notice with
selenium is that its focus is on web
applications um and it is an open source
tool and it's really good at regression
and functional testing of web
applications if you're doing a mobile
application or if you're doing an iot
application there are other tools you
can use on the market as well but if you
are new to devops and you're setting up
your first devops environment selenium
is a great place to start and web
applications are mature and allow you to
be able to test out and validate the
concept of continuous testing in your
environment so four key takeaways for
selenium it really is fast and it's fast
execution it's highly accurate so you
can always validate that what you're
doing uh will work correctly and
feedback can be sent straight back to
the developer if their
code doesn't pass the test um it allows
you to script in multiple languages um
again this is a great way for you to
test and the focus is on web
applications but you can test in
multiple languages used for web
applications and most importantly allows
for parallel test execution which speeds
up the whole test process significantly
we're actually to break down the
architecture of selenium and what you'll
find is the actual libraries that you
can use for selenium are run in c-sharp
java python javascript php these are the
common languages used to build out web
applications the actual web drive itself
is an api driver and which is fantastic
because it makes it easier for you to
integrate selenium with applications
through api and you can run the solution
through different web browsers the most
popular being firefox chrome and edge so
to focus the selenium webdriver codes
are being used to build out the client
libraries that make it
to allow you to be able to build
solutions across multiple web
application environments the webdriver
application interface is you to
integrate with the application to make
it easy for testing the webdriver
service provides an immutable stateless
environment that makes it very easy for
you to be able to use protocols such as
json to wire up your test environment
the driver manages communication between
the browsers and the wire protocol
that's used for json within the web
browser itself and then the actual
commands are then run through the web
browser for you to be able to get your
results okay so before we actually get
into the setup of selenium the first
things we want to do is we want to make
sure that we have the right version of
java installed and so i'm just using
command window here and i'm going to
type in java and actually what i can see
now is i do have java installed which is
fantastic otherwise you'd have to go and
download java from oracle's website the
next step is to validate that i have
eclipse installed and i'm just typing
eclipse and there we are i have the
eclipse app installed you can actually
download um eclipse from the eclipse
website the third step i want to check
is to validate that i have a browser
driver installed so i'm using google's
chrome and for my main browser but you
can actually go out and download the
chromium driver and that's the actual
core engine that powers chrome uh
interesting enough being used in the new
microsoft edgeweb browser so you can
actually go and download the latest uh
chromium driver and install that and
then the final stage is to go to the
selenium website and download the jar
files themselves so just uh do a google
search on selenium download and here we
have the
seleniumhq.org website and it takes
straight to the download page and we
want to download the latest version and
we've gone ahead and done that already
so we have everything running and now
the next step is for us to install all
of this great content okay so before we
actually get into the setup of selenium
the first things we want to do is we
want to make sure that we have the right
version of java installed and so i'm
just using command window here and i'm
going to type in java and actually what
i can see now is i do have java
installed which is fantastic otherwise
you'd have to go and download java from
oracle's website the next step is to
validate that i have eclipse installed
and i'm just typing eclipse and there we
are i have the eclipse app installed you
can actually download eclipse
from the eclipse website the third step
i want to check is to validate that i
have a browser driver installed so i'm
using
google's chrome for my main browser but
you can actually go out and download the
chromium driver um and that's the actual
core engine that powers chrome uh
interesting enough being used in the new
microsoft edgeweb browser so you can
actually go and download the latest
chromium driver and install that
and then the final stage is to go to the
selenium website and download the jar
files themselves so just do a google
search on selenium download
and here we have the
seleniumhq.org website and it takes
straight to the download page and we
want to download the latest version
and we've gone ahead and done that
already so we have everything running
and now the next step is for us to
install all of this great content so
we're just going to go ahead and open up
the eclipse environment and it always
takes a moment to launch clips
i'm going to go ahead and create a new
project
and we're going to call our project
i think that should be fine
and this is just a test after all and
we're going to go ahead and create a new
class file by right clicking and select
new
class
and we're going to go in here and give
the class file a name of simply learn
and
see the finish button being selected so
maybe we need to select some other
options here oh you know i think it
could be the package name yeah let me go
ahead and change the package name and
i'm going to change that to
qwe
qw app yep and the fetch button has now
been highlighted i can select that i can
go select that and click finish
and
we now have a test page that's up and
running um but what we have to do is to
validate that selenium is actually part
of the project so to do that we're going
to go to the source to the actual source
xyz file and right click on it and we
want to validate that all the files are
there correctly
and so we're going to see that we have
the libraries are there yep there's
selenium if it's not there you can
select add external files and find the
selenium jar file select open and that
would load that in there and then you
hit apply and close and that would then
apply it to your project and now we can
actually start writing the code part
so we're going to put this uh code in
the public static void section and the
first
command is going to be a system.set
property and we want to make sure that
we're configuring the web driver for
chromium correctly so we're going to do
webdriver
dot chrome driver
and then the argument is actually going
to be the full path full network path to
the chromium driver that you have on
your pc so let's see we have chromium
here we want to copy that path
and so that paste that in and then after
we've pasted in the path we have to make
sure that we also put a link to the
actual file that we want to execute
which in this case is chromedriver.exe
and then we want to make sure that the
driver is pointing to
the new chrome driver
and you'll notice that there's a couple
of red colors on here which means that
we don't have all of the public classes
imported correctly so you can right
click command and say import the web
driver and just select that real quick
and that adds the import correctly at
the top of the page and same for chrome
driver
and that's just a very quick way and
when you're working in eclipse to import
additional
files
so before we actually start our test we
want to make sure that we've actually
cleared out any potential browser
cookies that would be within the
chromebook driver so for that we're
actually going to go ahead and
we're going to write a script that
allows us to remove the
cookies
so we want to do driver.manage and then
delete all cookies
and the next line we're going to do is
to actually have the webpage that we're
going to connect to open up in full
screen mode and
for that to happen we're going to go and
actually use the window property which
which is what i was writing before by
mistake and so this will allow us to go
full screen and now we need to pull in a
web page so we're going to get the get
command and what we're going to do is
we're actually just going to pull in a
web page from amazon which i just happen
to have here so i'm just going to go to
amazon web page and so i'm just going to
copy the url and you know just need to
copy https www.amazon.ian.com
wherever you're located
and so you can see that i've pulled in
the amazon web page and then line 18
actually allows me to go and connect so
here we are we have the amazon web page
that i'm pulling in
and then what i also want to do is i
want to look for a specific id in one of
the elements and so i have the driver
which is called fight and element and
that allows me to look for any element
that would be on the actual page so here
we have the html in the console screen
and i can actually then paste out an id
from the element that i want to use
so the find element is just the id for
each element and most of them have them
because they need it for that javascript
and css
so let's see there's quite a few ids so
and we can select any of those
so what we have here is we have two tab
search text box and then what that
actually does is that finds the id for
the text box used for searching and then
we're going to use the send key command
which allows us to actually pre-fill in
the search box and we're going to use
the test of puma shoes this is a fixed
string but you can actually put a
variable in here if you want to pull the
strings from a database or an xml file
and
then the next
line on line 19 shows how long actually
going to run the actual script for the
search which is only 10 seconds and then
once the 10 seconds has elapsed we'll
actually quit the script which actually
closes the web browser and takes us back
into our screen here
and let's test that make sure it's
working and everything's looking good
the web browser opens which is what we
expect it goes to amazon fantastic um it
now actually goes to the search screen
and should fill in the puma shoes
there we go puma shoes and
waits 10 seconds and it closes and
that's exactly what we were expecting
now you can actually change the unit of
time that you would have for the actual
test so if you wanted to see what's
happening so longer than 10 seconds you
can actually change the actual time or
the actual metric and so in this
instance we got it says seconds and
units of time but you could do minutes
or hours or microseconds
and you can change the keyword as well
so it could be a jigsaws or anything you
wanted to check but if you're actually
building your own application you want
to be able to test your own data against
your own application that's where you
put in that specific data
so let's look at the center the heart of
your devops environment and that center
is with jenkins so before jenkins people
would developers would work on their
code and the code would then be checked
into a source repository you would then
check for any issues and then you would
then send that code over to
the operations team and there would be a
delay for actually delivering software
so the actual um
challenges developers had is that if
they wanted to run any tests they had to
wait until their software was built and
there was a lot of
problems in providing feedback and
particularly had large teams working on
software who actually had the error the
actual delivery of software was often uh
delayed because of these key problems so
after jenkins what we actually have is
the ability to be able to streamline
this whole process the build test and
deploy happens continuously and are able
to then notify developers and the actual
specific developer of any errors that
are detected being able to speed up the
delivery process much more efficiently
the focus of jenkins is that it
automates a continuous development
testing and deployment environment and
it's open source jenkins is easy to
install and configure it's been around
for many years now and it is very mature
there are many plugins that you can use
within jenkins to be able to have the
jenkins product work with your
environment if there isn't a plug-in you
can actually extend fire you can
actually write your own plug-ins if a
plug-in doesn't exist so you can
actually continue and extend and invest
in the jenkins ecosystem
and it can be easily distributed across
multiple machines so let's break out the
architecture of jenkins so jenkins
starts as a remote source code
repository and it then pulls out the
code every time there is a commit from
into the server master the server the
master will then have a slave that will
run on either windows linux or mac os to
be able to distribute this load across
those environments and after it's
actually gone through and run its test
it'll then send out a report the goal of
the report is to communicate back to the
team what has passed and what has failed
the actual check-in process okay so
we're gonna go ahead and show you how to
install jenkins on your local pc uh so
the first thing you want to do is check
that you have java installed so we're
just going to go into our system and see
whether or not we have the java jdk
installed you can do that by going into
system properties second advanced and
environment settings and
there we are we have java jdk installed
and you want to just double check on the
system variables to make sure that you
have the java unscore home installed
correctly as well and we have that
installed and under path also make sure
you have a link to the java jdk as well
so we have everything installed and what
we're going to do is we're going to open
up a command window and just do a double
check right there so open up command
window and we're just going to check
that we have jar and sword so we do java
dash version and we have a version
number that comes back if we didn't have
java and sword we wouldn't get a java
version number come back we'd actually
have an error all right so everything
looks good so the next thing you want to
do is to go to the jenkins website and
download the files so we're going to go
to jenkins.io
and that's the official jenkins website
and if you want to download you just go
to jenkins.io
download or you can just uh type into
your search bar uh download jenkins and
that will give you a link straight to
the download page and one of the things
that you'll see is that there's lots of
different versions for jenkins because
jenkins runs on pretty much most
operating systems
uh including windows linux and mac os um
but we want to select the windows
version so we've already gone ahead and
downloaded a zip file which contains all
of the files that we need for jenkins
and so that's the zip file and we've
expanded it and what we want to do now
is uh double click the installer file
and we'll go ahead and install that so
we've already installed this so um one
of the things that we'll get is a
message to ask if we want to repair
you'd actually get a install message
because it'll be a fresh install for you
and but once you've done that it has all
the files and all the settings correctly
installed onto your windows computer and
we do all of our commands for jenkins
through
a webpage that's run locally on your pc
and so you're going to type in localhost
colon 8080 and when you do that they'll
actually take you to jenkins running
locally on your pc and here we have our
jenkins dashboard and we've already gone
in and created some sample jobs and you
can see those listed on the uh sorry on
the right hand side of the screen so
let's go through some of the things you
would want to set up here so first of
all let's go into the manage jenkins
screen and that will achieve so we'll go
to the manage jenkins tab on the left
hand side to do some standard
configuration settings so we're going to
the configuration systems and if you
want to if you're like remotely
connecting to a remote jenkins
environment you can actually install a
jdk remotely for on that machine if you
want to now we already have the jdk
environment already set up so yeah
that's good here so we don't need to do
that but you'll also see as you go
through the the list of applications
that you have gradle and mavin docker
git and other tools that you would use
in a devops environment there are many
other tools you can install through
plugins as well let's have a look at one
more setting here with the security the
default security is jenkins own user
database uh that probably is not allowed
within your company due to security
restrictions and so you can choose ldap
which allows you to connect with your
active directory configuration again
because there are so many plugins uh for
jenkins uh there are plugins for saml
authentication as well as oauth so let's
go ahead and start a new build new build
job and so we'll select a new item and
we're going to
select
demo one from that to create a new item
and we're going to use just a freestyle
project because i just want to demo how
you can actually create a build select
okay description um gosh what could we
write here um we can put in a slimpy
demo
and we're not going to use source code
for this one we can do that in the next
demo but uh let's what we want to go
down to is the job time and we're going
to so build and we can just do um add
for wind execute windows match command
and so let's just put in a very simple
command and so we're going to type in
echo open quotes hello world and then
we'll put in the timestamp so put in
date first and then time as part of our
output close quotes and we're going to
save that also save and that's our
simple project so what we want to do now
is we want to actually go and select the
build now command to actually run this
project hit build now and take a couple
of minutes for it to run and here we are
this is our project and we're going to
now see the different builds that have
happened and if you look on the build
history you'll see the latest history
shows when the build was executed and if
you click on that you can actually start
getting information such as the console
output where she provide information
that we were asking for so for instance
now we have it's first saw we can see
that the build was successful and we see
the output and includes uh the hello all
and uh date and time so we're gonna go
ahead and create one more project where
we can actually connect to a github and
use the get command tool to be able to
build a real project so we're going to
go ahead and create a new item and we're
going to call this one jenkins it's
freestyle project and our description is
demo using git and so we're actually
going to connect to github and so to do
that we're going to go into source code
management tab and we're going to say
get and so we select that we can
actually now connect to
github and so to do that you go to your
github account and you want to go in and
select the clone or download and you get
the url link from there so copy that and
go back to jenkins and add that in the
repository url so you paste that in and
then for credentials we want to add in
jenkins credentials and so just make
sure you have those selected correctly
and we've clicked add and then we just
pull those from the drop down and let's
not change any of the other settings and
then for the build we're actually going
to be building a java application so
it's a slightly different set of build
commands so we want to type in java c
for compile and then space and the file
name is simply.java and you want to put
java and space simply on a new line save
that it's again this is a really simple
application but it gives you the
understanding of what you need to do
here and so we saved it and let's now go
ahead and see if everything's working
we'll do the build now and see what
happens and here is our first build we
select that we can go to the console
output for details and what we can
actually see if we scroll down is that
the finished at the finished output at
the very end says success which means
everything was built correctly and so
that's how you're able to connect
jenkins with a git repository and the
thing that's great with working with
jenkins is that it connects to so many
different systems and really does become
the central point of your devops toolset
so let's start looking at the operation
side of the devops environment and let's
focus in on docker so before docker the
problem you had as a developer if you're
working on a virtual machine the actual
virtual machine
was a your vm was a very complex piece
of software so first of all vms have not
been around for very long and we're
talking about less than 10 years and the
typical way of having a vm is that it's
very heavy on usage on your
computer you essentially are running
everything of the vm plus the tools to
run the vm on your computer with docker
what you're able to control is the
actual development environment you're
working in you don't have to be
encumbered by all of the additional
extraneous processing that a vm
environment has you're really stripped
down to just the bare minimum that you
need to have to run the environment
using a containerized solution known as
docker so docker is essentially an os
level virtualization software it is a
maturity of the solutions that were
started with virtual environments and
there are other solutions out there doc
has become the de facto container
solution that you can use for building
out and guaranteeing that what you the
developer is building is going to be the
same as what the operations team will
use so docker itself is highly scalable
and efficient and you can have many
docker environments running on a single
piece of hardware the boot up time is
incredibly short you can reuse the data
volumes very very easily it's not
complicated and the actual applications
are completely isolated this is like a
perfect sandbox environment so let's dig
through the architecture of darker so
there are really two parts to docker
there's the docker engine and there's
the docker client the docker engine is
comprised of the docker cli which
connects with the server demon the
docker client will then issue the
commands to the docker demon and then
the docket demon will then interact with
their system to be able to provide the
tasks and tools needed for you to be
able to build out your solution the
actual images that docker uses are
instructions for creating docker
containers and the actual docket
container itself is a lightweight
package that contains all the
dependencies needed to run an
application now once you have created a
container that is of value to your team
you want to be able to store that
container so that other team members can
use it and this is where you would use a
docker registry to be able to host and
distribute multiple docker images so in
this video we're going to go ahead and
see how we can get docker installed and
running so we're going to go ahead and
open up our terminal window and we want
to validate whether or not docker is
installed uh if you haven't installed
docker you can actually go ahead and use
the following command and that is to
enter in sudo apt install docker and
that will go ahead and run the command
to install docker now i already have
docker installed on my system so i'm not
going to do that right now so i'm just
going to delete that out but um what i
am going to do is check to see what
docker images i have installed on my
system and to do that i'm going to type
in
sudo docker images and when i run this
this will actually show how many images
i have and right now i don't have any
images at all so when we go ahead and
install an image there are two ways you
can create an image for your dark
environment one is to get one from
docker hub and the other is to create
your own image and let's go ahead and
get one from docker hub and so the
command line that we'd want to write is
sudo darker pull redis colon and after
the colon we can actually write the name
of the actual file that we're going to
be connecting to from docker so i'm
going to go ahead and go to docker hub
and i've already logged in with my user
id and account so i'm going to go to
docker hub and
hub.docker.com
is the website address and
i'm already logged in with my
simplylearn account and
what you can actually see is different
repositories that i have already created
below i'm going to click the explore
button
and i can see the the redis image and
these are all the different commands
that i can actually use all the
different variations that i can create
so i can i can do 5.0 i can do a 32-bit
version i can do
a 4.0 version or a 3.8 version or if i
select latest that will allow me to just
pull the latest version even if it's
updated so i'm going to go back to my
command line and do latest and what's
going to happen now is that we're
actually going to pull the files live
over the internet and create the docket
image so it's going to take just a few
minutes of course if your internet speed
is faster then this will happen a lot
faster
yeah here we are we have everything
downloaded which is great and so let's
just go and check and see if the image
has been added to docker so we do uh
pseudo docket images and now you can
actually see that we have the latest
reddest um image and it's given the
default image id and there's the size of
the docker image and the tag is latest
so it's the latest version of redis
and i'm just checking to see if there's
any other images running and no there
isn't so let's go ahead and now create a
container
and so the command for that is sudo
docker run
d dash p
zero dot zero dot zero i think it's dot
80 colon 80 space redis colon latest and
let's run that
got an error message okay now you know
that it's a real demo this is really
live so i'm just going to clear the
screen and um let's write that in again
and so sudo docker run dash d dash p and
it's 0.0.0.0
colon 8080 ready to start late they have
color latest and there we are
everything's up and running awesome so
let's just go ahead and check that we
actually have the image running in
docker so pseudo docker piers and there
you can see that we actually have the
latest redis version and it was created
16 seconds ago we have a new container
id for it and there's our port that
we've created
and let's see if we can view all the
running containers and sudo docker ps a
there we are and we created that
container 42 seconds ago one of the
things you'll notice is um the name for
the docker is created automatically by
docker and here we have stupefied angle
bars is the name let's change that name
to something that's more meaningful for
the work that we're doing so that's
actually fairly easy too and it's gonna
be our final task here so we're gonna
type sudo darker and the command is
rename and we want to copy over the old
name and then we put in the old name and
they do a space and then you put in what
you want the new name to be in which
case we're going to make it simply learn
we run that command that's good now
let's validate that everything has been
changed so we're going to do sudo docker
ps dash a on just ps and there we are
everything has been renamed and that
gets you started working with docker now
let's move on to ansible so before
ansible the ability to be able to deploy
software across a network it was pretty
hard and you know you couldn't guarantee
that your web servers were all
consistent and that the database
environments were consistent this was
okay if you had a small environment but
once you actually started getting into
more complex environments it became very
difficult to manage ansible is code that
allows you to be able to consistently
and reliably create and stand up the
environments that you need to be able to
store your code for production so
whether or not you require one server
environment or you need a thousand
server environments using tools like
ansible will allow you to be able to
consistently deploy out environments
that all look the same so essentially
ansible is a configuration management
tool and it allows you to be able to
deploy automatically to a large variety
of environments the actual tool itself
is a push-based configuration tool it is
an agent-less tool so there is no
communication coming back about the
health of the environment and we
actually have tools that we'll cover
later on in the video that cover that
ansible does have a consistency of its
products performance so you know that if
you're using ansible that it's gonna
work it's just a very consistent product
and it uses ssh for very secure
connections so it doesn't matter whether
or not you have one or a thousand
pieces of hardware you're looking to
configure you can actually be rest
assured that there will be no security
infringement because of the use of ssh
now we look into the architecture of
ansible it's a very simple architecture
there is the ansible management node
that has playbooks which contain the
instructions that you would have for
your environment and that playbook is
then pushed out to all the different
nodes that contain the hardware that you
wish to configure the actual module
collection is the configuration code
itself and the playbooks are the the
instructions of that configuration and
then the inventory is the document of
the different groups and hardware within
those groups that you would be pushing
out to so we're going to go ahead and
install ansible onto system here and
we're actually running our environment
in a linux environment right now um so
we have a master environment and an
extended node but we're actually going
to go into our terminal window and we're
going to do everything on the master
node so the first steps we want to do is
actually go ahead and install ansible
and we're going to do that by
installing sudo yum install ansible dash
y
and this goes ahead and downloads all
the files that we need and starts to run
the installation
and let's go ahead and see if it's
installed correctly so we're typing vi
dash etc
ansible slash hosts and there we see we
actually have a default ansible hosts
already up and running which is
fantastic and we want to grab this ip
address which is ansible servers and
then the ip address with the password
and root access and the ip will be
specific to your local client so this is
my client system so if i type in my
config i'll actually see that the ip
address matches up and then you want to
make sure the ip address is correct for
your environment and so this is
essentially a node in the ansible
environment and this is the ip address
and the password for that node so you
can access effect um correctly so we'll
hit colon at the bottom of the screen
and
take ourselves actually into ansible and
we're going to do now is create a
playbook to be able to run a sample
script so we're going to call it vi
sample.yml
and here we have a sample playbook we
have the name we have the host we have
the right user and we have the task and
in the task you actually see that we're
looking to create a virtual web page
with the content of welcome so that we
can actually see that the web page is
loading and all of this is written with
a very basic xml format called yml which
stands for yet another markup language
but it's very flexible and it's very
easy to learn so let's see if we can go
ahead and actually run this playbook so
you can actually see it in action
and so we're going to type in ansible
dash playbook
sample.yml this will run the sample yml
script dash dash syntax dash check
now we type in ansible
playbook sample.yml
[Music]
so i had some issues there so i'm going
to try that again and
let's uh
go in and write the command again so
answer playbook sample.yml
syntax dot dash check and then run the
actual playbook itself and
let's see if it works yes everything's
working and it'll take a moment for
everything to initialize and now what we
want to be able to do is go back to our
web browser and see whether or not we
were able to create that default web
page with the word welcome in it because
that was the command that we created in
our playbook and there we are there's
the word welcome exactly as we planned
and we can go back and we can review the
playbook that we created just to
validate that so let's go back into
screen here and let's uh go in and look
at the
yaml page and there we are we see that
the word welcome is there exactly as we
expected now step into our final area
which is network monitoring using a tool
called nagios so before you had nagios
sometimes you didn't know whether or not
your network was working in fact the
worst case scenario was when your
customers called up and said hey your
website's not working you know the
challenges you had is that you didn't
know um how the usage of the server was
being managed you didn't know whether
you were up to 80 usage utilization on
that server or if you are at 50 it was
difficult to get that information easily
with nagios you're able to set up email
notifications and other notifications
that allow you to stay ahead of issues
that you would have within your
environment so with this example if
you're looking for memory utilization
you can receive a notification telling
you that your memory is almost full on a
particular server and that you should be
setting up a new server in this instance
use ansible to set up another server so
again it's an as with the other tools
we've been covering nagios is an open
source tool and it's specifically for
monitoring systems servers and networks
within your infrastructure very easy to
use it has comprehensive monitoring
tools that you can set and control it is
highly available and it is designed
specifically at problem remediation you
want to set it up so it is the eyes and
ears of your network without you having
to constantly monitor your network so
the way that nigest works is that it's
just constantly checking out your
environment so the negative server is
constantly checking the status of your
systems and then is able to create
visualization tools of that data so you
can actually then make quick responses
or you can even send out alerts such as
an email alert or push notification
alone in this video we're going to take
you through the steps that you need to
follow if you want to set up nagios and
the dashboard nagios provides to be
helped to help monitor your network so
the first thing you want to do is go to
nagios.com and you can either download
the application or you can actually do
what we're going to do here is actually
just log into the actual application
running on the nagios website so for
that you want to go to
nagiosna.demos.net.com
and you can use the administration or
normal user access
ids that nigeria's provides and we've
gone ahead and we've actually pre-filled
in our id with net use admin and
negative admin for the user id name and
password of course you wouldn't do that
in all of your life um so that brings us
into the nagios dashboard and what
you're going to notice is that there are
three distinct areas that you should
want to focus on um you have the fixed
sources which is all your actual
physical hardware that you're monitoring
you have alert summary and abnormal
behavior so let's go check out the fixed
sources and so we have two default fixed
sources here and one in chicago one in
tulsa um and you can go ahead and set up
additional sources but what you'll see
is that this surprised a quick dashboard
of the activity in the last 30 minutes
the amount of usage on the the disk you
can go ahead and um to the behavior tab
and you can modify how you're monitoring
and updating the actual source itself
and then the data from these reports
will be from these sources we'll
actually be then using reports queries
and alerts that you will use so we're
going to go back to the board and here
you have the
and fixed sources so let's look at load
summary when you expand that out and the
alert summary provides just a uh
overview of the alerts that are being
managed the alerts that you see here are
the default alerts that have been
created as part of the test environment
um it's very easy to create alerts and
in this instance you can see that the
chicago source is being used to manage
the alert what you can do is when you're
actually setting up your own sources
you'll see that the alert will then
point specifically to the source that
it's um pulling the data from so in the
powerpoint in the presentation that we
just went through you actually see how
nagios and aji is the center of
collecting all the information but it's
actually pulling the information from
the different networks and environments
you have and then it stores that data
locally to be able to create the
visualizations and the alerts and we
have here just a quick overview of an
alert here inside of the summary which
actually shows green which shows that
the alert is actually good now there are
three different types of colors there's
green yellow and red but as you can see
we have no critical alerts right now and
you'll see the same thing happening at
abnormal behavior as well where it
actually goes ahead and shows you the
different colors that are available the
thing that's great is about as soon as a
warning status is created then it allows
you to trigger an email notification
that gets sent out to you and has
information in the email which you can
then action so the alerts are very
important and the alerts again are
pulling the information from the fixed
sources so the abnormal behavior is just
going to zero in and show any specific
abnormal behavior that would be
happening with your fixed sources and so
in this instance it's around bandwidth
and everything is green so everything's
looking good so we're going to the
source tab and we're going to look at
the bandwidth graph and this is a more
detailed visualization of the bandwidth
that's happening through the chicago
fixed source again you can create your
own fixed sources and you'll be able to
see the actual usage um such as the
bandwidth graph for that fixed source um
on this screen and at the bottom of the
screen we have just kind of the the most
popular information that
most network engineers are looking to
assess on how a network is being used so
we go ahead and we can select reports
and we can actually come in and we can
either create our own custom report or
you can use one of the many saved
reports are already there if you're new
to nagios use the save reports because
you'll be able to get in and get the
great visualization tools that negios
provides very quickly and be able to
then action the information visually
from what you're looking at these
reports are absolutely fantastic and
they're also really good to send to
other team members that would have an
interest in understanding the network
usage and the different areas that
you're managing now if you want to get
really specific on the type of data that
you want in the report you can actually
go in and create a query and the query
can be customized to really however you
want it to to work the points of view
are very specific insights into
different data points that interact and
they're very easy to create and a lot of
them have been created as you can see on
the screen already and as you can see on
the left hand side there is an edit
button that allows you to edit and
modify those points of view very quickly
now we're going to go ahead and create
one right now and we're just going to
put one in and put the limiter for an ip
address we're going to change the dead
lifetime we can either do hours days or
weeks we do 24 hours that's fine so
we'll just go ahead and we'll see what
we have on the screen and as as you can
see there are just a lot already created
select one will edit the ftp and we'll
see what the delay time for that is and
it all looks good so a query will show
all of the saved queries you've created
but you can actually go in and modify a
query very easy um you can go in and
create a query and really essentially
ask it to pull any kind of information
that you would be looking at analyzing
that has been captured by nagios and
there's a dictionary you can use that
nagios has on their website that allows
you to get better access and
understanding the querying
constructs you can put together the
alerts in my opinion are the most
important part because these are the
actual actions that interact with the
data sources and will trigger alerts
that get sent to you so we go back to
the presentation again you can see that
we're analyzing a lot of data but it's
the data that gets sent to you as an
alert that allows you to immediately
understand why you need to be able to go
in and check out your network and this
is why you're really using nagios
because you need to have those alerts
and so what we're going to do here is
we're going through the steps you use to
create an alert we're just going to do a
an alert here that
is going to be on um analyzing bytes of
traffic and the final step is to
actually go ahead and save the alert and
really put in what the alert
notification model method is going to be
and the default is to use an email which
is great but you can use a nagios alert
or as you know smp a simple network um
protocol blood
or just use a a command email is
definitely the easiest one to use and so
getting started i would recommend you
use email so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to create one we're going to
do one on workflow and we're going to
set up the way which we're going to
manage this so the threshold is going to
be 34 bytes with a critical threshold of
50 bytes which is very small i expect an
alert to be triggered because of this
and we're just going to use the default
emails to send out and you'll see by
default that um the
new alert is now impending um and the
reason why we have impending is that
it's just there to re be reviewed by the
system to make sure it meets all the
standards and i don't think there'll be
a problem and i'm just looking at some
of the other different commands we have
here so if we go back and we can get
alerts from other negative networks we
connect to different networks right from
this configuration screen and same thing
with the smp receiver now we can use a
simple network management protocol to
connect to
other receivers and the command tab
allows us to create scripts that can be
triggered from alerts that get created
so you may want to have something that
triggers a rebuild of a network
environment which would allow you to
authenticate through other systems now
of course there are other things you can
set up in the negatives dashboard so you
know things like information on your
profile you know defaults here such as
language and your username you have the
same thing for system administrator
where you can actually go in and set
defaults for the assist admin there's
ldap ad integration for simple and for
example authentication go back to the
main dashboard if we scroll down you'll
actually see that we have an alert has
been approved that's the alert that
we've created before and it's now saying
critical and because more than 50 bytes
of information have been sent over our
test network in the uh fixed sorts of
chicago surprise price 50 bytes is very
easy to do so it's good to see that the
system is working correctly and this is
how our nagios environment works and
from here the next step is for you to be
able to set up and configure nagios to
run with your infrastructure thanks
matthew now we have anjali apexia
matthew anaga and ananth to take us
through the major concepts of kit
selenium jenkins docker chef and puppet
today i'll be showing you the
installation for git on windows so we'll
start by downloading and installing git
on our system we'll then have a look at
the git bash interface we'll type in
some basic git commands next we'll
create a local repository that is we'll
create a repository on a local machine
we'll then connect to a remote
repository and finally we'll push the
file onto github first things first we
need to download and install git so
download git for windows and i'll select
the second link
so
2.19.1 which is the most latest version
of kit that's the one we want for
windows system choose your version so
mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while
so git is finally downloaded now we need
to install this on our system
click here
run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path
just so just click on in quick launch
and on desktop
next
next again next nothing to change here
either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash
so let's just take that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version
and as you can see version 2.19.1
on our windows system which is exactly
what we just downloaded we'll now
explore the help command so let's just
type git help config so config is
another command and as i hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it
so in case you have any doubts regarding
how a command is used what a command is
used for or the various syntax of the
command you can always use the help
command now there's another syntax for
using the help command itself which is
git config dash dash help enter this
does the exact same thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir
test
now test is my new directory i'll move
into this directory so cd test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so git
init is the command for initializing the
directory and as you can see as you can
see the path here this is the local path
where a directory is created so i'll
just show you the directory test and
it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and i'll
just name this demo i'll open this and
just put in some dummy content
so hello simply done
save this file and go back to your bash
interface
let's just check the status now so git
status and as you can see
our file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is
we'll be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we'll be
applying is the commit command and when
you add certain files to the current
directory the comment command is applied
on all the above directories so git
commit minus m and a message that will
appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion
just clear the screen next thing we need
to do is we need to link our git to a
github account so the command for doing
that is git config
global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
github account
so this is my github profile and my
username is simplylearn.github
so guys before you begin this procedure
just make a github account type in my
username here simply learn github and
enter and there you go a git is
successfully linked with github next
thing we do is we'll just open our
github
and we'll create a new repository give a
repository name so i'll name it test
underscore demo and create repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and our
local repository
so git remote origin and then paste
the http link and now that our local
repository and our remote repository are
linked we can push our local file onto
our remote repository so the command for
doing that is git
push origin master as we are on the
master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to github i'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo today we're going to delve into
git and what it actually is and how it
fits within your devops stack so a
little scenario before using get one of
the challenges that a lot of developers
and development teams would have had is
developers would be working on different
types of code whether it was database
code whether it was uh python or whether
it's java or net and they would have a
central server that they'd be pushing
all of their source code in but there
was little or no communication that was
actually going on in between all the
developers you know the challenge you
had with that scenario is that when
people would be checking in code you
could be like you know there'd be
conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and and this is
really kind of the challenge that git
addresses git is a tool that allows all
of the developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective at being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the biggest applications out there are
managed through a get distributed server
environment so let's jump into what
we'll be covering so you have a clear
understanding of the value that you're
going to get out of watching this
presentation so we're going to go
through devops and the tools have
available for devops we'll talk about
what version control means within a
devops environment and cover the two
different types of version control
centralized and distributed and then
we're going to zero in on git which is a
really fantastic distributed version
control system and we're going to go
through understand the features workflow
branches and commands in git we can give
you a demo and then summarize all the
activities at the end of the the
presentation so what is devops well this
is one of my favorite questions i love
the idea of what devops is so devops
really is a culture of being able to
deliver solutions faster where your
development teams and your operation
teams work effectively together the idea
is to be able to continuously build out
solutions and have testing codes that's
built into your solutions so that no
matter where they are in the stage of
the integration and deployment life
cycle they're always being tested and
you can always have code being ready to
be released out the idea is that instead
of having big releases that you'd have
maybe once every two weeks or once a
month that you would actually have a
continuous stream of releases because
you always have code that is being
tested you have your network that's been
tested you have your environment being
tested and you'll be able to provide
feedback directly to the appropriate
person whether they're in devs or
whether they're in ops to be able to be
successful at being able to deliver
solutions faster the bottom line your
dev team things like operations and your
operations team begin to feel like think
like developers it's really a fantastic
way of being able to speed up delivery
and have your team just think and feel
and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in devops environments if we look at
devops it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your upside you have release deployment
operating and monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost in fact most of the tools you're
seeing in front of you right now are
open source tools which means there's no
licensing to you and you can actually
effectively manage them and implement
them within your team right now so let's
have a look at some of the dev tools
that you have for doing code versioning
and so some of the tools that you may
have used in the past include subversion
team foundation service and git these
are all different types of version
control software that you have out there
one of the oldest ones is subversion
it's a centralized version control
system it's one of the tools i used
years ago it really is good at doing
what it's supposed to do which is just a
very simple version controlled solution
it's open source so it's free and
there's no licensing there are
challenges with working with it because
it is a centralized tool rather than a
distributed tool we'll get into that in
a little bit but for a very basic
virtual control system you know it does
what you wanted to do team foundation
service solutions something that many of
you in microsoft world may have been
using for a long time and the thing
that's great about tfs is it's built
right into the microsoft environment
it's the server side the services side
of building out your solutions with
microsoft um just recently in the last
couple of weeks at the beginning of
september 2018. microsoft actually just
re-branded tfs as azure devops and so
you have azure pipelines and there are
five now azure tools that you replace
tfs but these are all tools that are
very similar in concept the old tfs
tools are very similar to the
centralized svn tools whereas the new
tools that are part of azure are
actually much more aligned with git so
what you're seeing is microsoft moving
from the centralized server to a
distributed server with their new azure
devops tools which is fantastic news for
every developer listening to this and
then we have git and git is a
distributed version control system it is
again open source which means that you
can start using it right now without
fear of having to have any costs or any
penalties and the thing that's really
good about it is that it's really you
can use it for almost any kind of
digital project and what it's good at is
being able to create that historical
record and versioning of your source
code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of version control system is
to allow developers to be able to check
in their files into a repository and
here you can actually see how we can
check in three files into a repository
and that repository then becomes a
snapshot or a historical record of the
files that we're working on and you want
to be able to have it so that the
repository is flexible enough so that as
you want to be able to scale and add in
new files or new versions of a file that
you can actually do that easily within
your vcs environment and the goal is to
be able to constantly have each of these
versions available so that anybody wants
to be able to check out the file can
actually have the latest version or see
a history of how that file became what
it is today let's look at centralized
version control systems and then we'll
compare it against distributed version
control systems so a centralized version
control system has a central server
where all the files are stored and
everybody has to check in and check out
from that centralized server and all of
the versions are managed within that
server environment
the problem is is that if that central
server crashes which doesn't happen but
very often but it can happen you end up
losing all of your files and i was
actually on a project where that
actually happened to us and we lost six
months of history of how the application
was created fortunately for us we
actually had a backup but it didn't have
all the historical data so we were able
to at least continue working but we just
lost a lot of files and it took a while
to get back into place so let's now look
at and compare this to a distributed
version control system with a
distributed version control system you
still have a centralized server that
manages the files but the difference is
is that as a developer you check out all
of the files for a project so you can
actually manage the whole project
locally on your develop machine and make
your changes and then you can just check
in and out the changes that you've made
to the centralized server the
opportunity you have here is that the
server itself if it goes down you're not
going to be in a situation where you
lose all the history because everybody
that's working on the actual application
has all of the versions of the code
locally on their machine
now one of the more popular distributed
version control systems that out there
is git i mean it really is probably the
most popular buyer margin compared to a
system out there so you know let's dig
into you know what actually is git so
get is a version control system for
managing files and as a developer you
have a git client on your machine and
you're able to make changes and create
local repositories of a program on your
computer and then you can sync up with a
remote service such as github or get lab
or the new azure labs environment where
you can actually store files remotely
and then allow remote teams to have
access to
those changes in the actual application
you made so you can track your changes
easily you have it's the the tool is
inherently distributed so it makes it
very easy to manage the code for large
teams and you can bring people in very
quickly and you can have people come in
as specialists and spin them up quickly
and have them work on a piece of the
code and then drop them out of the
project if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to any of the the many thousands of open
source projects at github where you can
go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects
and then finally one of the things that
i really like with git is that it's not
a linear development approach it's not
starting from a and going to z it's a
non-linear approach which allows you to
have branches that people are working on
in parallel to your master branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features
so get as you can imagine the first
thing it does is track history that's
probably the most important part of
having a version control system it's a
free open source you can actually go and
use it right now there are no costs of
actually using it it is a non-linear
environment that allows people to be
able to build out new features in
parallel to the master branch so that
you can be constantly having the master
code out there without and adding in new
features without breaking the code and
you can automatically create backups by
because each developer has a version of
the code remotely it's incredibly
scalable some of the biggest projects
out there now are being managed through
git and because of this scale the
collaboration becomes a byproduct of
teams working together and branching
just is so much easier within git so as
you can see this whole thing leads to a
very effective distributed environment
so let's step through some of the the
workflow that we have available for git
so the way that git works is that you as
an operator as a developer you have the
git client on your local development
machine whether it's a linux machine a
mac or a pc and you connect to a remote
server and you pull down the latest
working copy and then you're able to
make all of your changes uh locally and
you can modify the codes you can review
changes and you can commit those code to
your git repository that you have
locally and then you can push those
changes back up to the remote server and
as soon as you push them into the remote
server those changes then become
available to everybody else working on
the project so they can be constantly
keeping everybody updated on all the
work that is happening so you know
typically the way that it would work is
you know you would start off with having
the working file the working directory
that you have locally then you would
stage those files into a staging area
and then you get those files ready to be
committed to your git repository and
these are all actions that you would do
locally and then connect to a remote
server and then later when you go back
into work on your project the first
thing you should always do is check out
that code so you always have the latest
version of the code and everybody is
kept in sync so let's talk about
branching in git so the way that
branches work is that if you imagine
you're working on a project and projects
always have a tendency of getting bigger
than you imagine and what you want to be
able to do is keep that main product
working and keeping it working
effectively but if you want to be able
to add a feature to that product you may
have two or three different groups that
are working on multiple features
simultaneously
and what you want to be able to do is
give them the freedom to work on those
individual features and the way you do
it in git is that you can create
branches off the master and while you're
off the the main branch which is called
the master
and so each person could be working on
their own separate branch and then when
they want to they can then later merge
those branches back into the main master
and all this time the main master still
works and still able to produce the
right code for the customer but at the
same time it allows the developers the
freedom to be able to write in their new
features and so we can look at this in a
little bit more visually with the master
branch and we can put in small features
and large features and we can then merge
them back as we need to so this kind of
covers some of the commands that we have
in git so the first command you'd want
to use is called git init and that's
allow you to go into a folder on your
local pc and or your local mac and
convert that file that folder into a
local git repository and that creates
that repository then you want to be able
to make changes to that repository and
the commands you'd be using in this
instance would be add commit or status
and you want to be able to sync your
repositories with the remote server so
be able to put the code that you have on
your computer on the remote server you
just push you're going to get the code
from the remote server you'd use pull
and then add origin and then if you want
to do parallel development from the
master branch the main branch you would
use branch merge or rebase as ways to be
able to do parallel development and now
we're going to go through and do a demo
on git so we're going to do a demo on
git so you can feel comfortable running
the commands in the interface and you're
able to get get running correctly in
your environment so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to set
up which version of git that you have
and then we're going to see if we can
establish some global configurations
within your git environment and we're
going to do sandeep.dash as the name the
email address is sandeep.simplyline and
then we're going to do a list of the
different configuration settings we have
so to check the version of git that we
have we do get dash dash version in our
terminal or command line window you can
also use powershell that'll actually get
you running in the same environment as
well all of these tools are going to be
command line tools and then the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to assign some global usernames and a
global email address and so that we can
actually access the git account itself
locally on the device and so we're going
to dash and we're going to put in config
dash global user dot name sandeep and
then a git config
global user.email and
sandeep.d at simplylearn.net
and now we're going to check the list of
usernames and email ids in our
configuration environment with dash list
and you'll see that we have everything
in there correctly here is our username
right here and our name and our email id
so if you need any help when you're
actually doing any of your work in get
all you have to do is to get help config
or get config
help and this will allow you to actually
get access to the help screens so let's
just go and type that in git help
config return and this takes us to the
help page that's running locally on your
device and here we have a breakdown of
all the different commands and what
those commands actually do within a git
configuration
and we can go ahead and we can do git
config dash dash help and that will
actually take us to the same page so two
ways of doing the same thing so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to
create a test repository on our local
system and we're going to do that with
make directory called test and then
we're going to move our cursor within
command window terminal window to the
test folder and then we're going to
initialize that folder to become a get
repository so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to make a new directory
and we're going to call it test and
we're going to move the cursor so it's
actually in the test folder we do cd
change directory to test and you can see
now we're actually in the test folder
and now what we have to do is initialize
this folder as a get repository and so
we're going to do this as git init and
it's now a new git instance that we can
actually now use for managing our git
environment so we're going to create a
new file and we're going to call it
info.txt and we're going to put some
content in it and we're actually going
to put it in the folder that we've just
created so you can actually see what
it's like to test out the get
environment with the file that hasn't
been checked into it yet so let's go
ahead and do that so we open up our
folder directory and here you can see we
have the test folder and we're just
going to go ahead and create a default
test file so right click text new
document info.txt open that and we'll
just you can put really whatever you
want in here we're just going to put in
this information right now name equals
sam registration number
uh one two
four seven nine and save that file close
it out now if we actually go ahead and
run a
get status command you'll see that the
info.txt file is in red that's because
that file has not actually been checked
into the project it's a new file that
we've added but it hasn't been committed
yet into the git repository so let's go
ahead and see what it takes to actually
add the file to the git repository that
we just created so we're going to do
that by doing git add info.txt and then
we're going to commit that into the
history of that git repository so we can
do so it now has a version control and
we can start doing forking and other
kind of sim activities when we connect
later to our github git environment so
we do get add
info.txt and remember we're actually
still in the test folder so it's going
to look for that file in that folder and
just add it in and now if we go ahead
and do git status we'll actually be able
to see that the info.txt file is in an
active color first of all we have to
commit it so we go get commit dash m and
then we're going to commit and we add in
some quick text you can write whatever
you want committing the text file it's
now actually committed into the git
repository and it's all running locally
on your pc so we're gonna go make some
changes to the file and we're gonna save
it and we want to be able to see how we
can use git to compare the differences
between the two files so let's go over
and we're going to make some changes to
the info.txt file here we are here's
info.txt which is going to add in a new
line we're going to add in the line
address and we're going to save that
file and now when we go over to git
we're going to be able to review the
difference so we're going to do git div
and here you actually see that we've
added in a new address file so now you
can actually see this is the difference
and the difference between the two
documents now as you can imagine when
you have code this would become more
elaborate where actually it will show
you code that's been pulled out if
you've reduced any of eliminating code
or if you added a new code really useful
so we're going to go ahead and add our
get username to a remote location so we
can actually start testing out the
file that we've created into a remote
repository in this case we're going to
use github and you'll be able to see how
we can actually then save that file into
a get repository that somebody else
could then access and be able to make
edits to so let's just go ahead and make
those changes so get config dash global
user dot username and we do simply learn
and that will associate it with this uh
git repository that we just created
locally so simply on dash github so
simply learn github is the username that
we use on github so we're gonna go over
to github here we are in github and then
correct new repository
and then as you can see with sim so
we're in simply learn dash github and
we're going to call the new proprietary
test we're going to make it public so
anybody can access it and you'll see
that it automatically adds a readme file
and we have our test environment set up
correctly so we'll go ahead and copy the
url link which is github.com simply
learn dash github forward slash test.get
copy that and we'll go back over to our
command line window and so now we're
going to add the username to the github
configuration so what we're doing is
we're connecting the local repository to
the remote repository so we type get
remote add origin and then we'll paste
in the address and this then allows us
to connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file that we have
in the local repository on your pc or
mac to the remote repository in the
github server environment so let's go
ahead and do that so we do get push and
push is the command to push the
documents from the origin which is the
local file to master and master the
remote file okay and there we are
success so what we have now is the file
that we just created in our local get
repository is actually now in the remote
repository as well so anybody can access
it so let's go have a look at that so
we're going to refresh the github page
and hey there we are there's info.txt
has been uploaded and we're ready to go
that's great that's uh that's what you
should be seeing so refreshing your web
page on the remote github folder and it
could be any get service but just happy
to be using github because it's free to
use you'll be able to see that the local
file has been installed and is now part
of the get repository in the remote
server so what we're going to do now is
we're going to create three more files
and we're just going to call them
info.txt info 2 and info 3 and then
we're going to push them out to the
remote server and we're going to merge
everything together into a single
environment so let's go ahead and create
those three files and we're just going
to add those into the folder so let's go
ahead create new text document info one
and then we're gonna create info two and
then info
three look at my typing right here okay
here we go there we are
okay i'm opening info three and i'm just
going to enter some text in here and
what we're going to do is illustrate how
we can do branching and each of these
files i'm going to save and then close
out and now i can go over and so let's
create a new branch and we're going to
call this one first underscore branch
and we go get branch first underscore
branch and this will be a new branch of
the code environment that we're creating
and so hit return and that allows us to
create a new branch and so what we do is
we're going to move to the new branch so
we're going to do git check out first
underscore branch and that allows us to
move into that branch and you'll see
that info.txt is already there which is
good that's what we want to see now what
we need to do is um add in the new
documents so here we have the different
steps we've taken we created a branch we
moved to the new branch and now we're
going to go ahead and add the info 3 txt
to that branch so you can actually see
everything coming together and we're
going to go at get add info 3.txt so
we're just adding a file like we were
previously with our initially
our first initial git folder and that
file has now been added to the first
branch so we're going to go ahead and
commit the file to the first branch and
then we're going to merge the documents
into the master branch so we have
everything together so let's go ahead
and do those steps we're going to do the
commit first and then we're going to
merge everything together all right so
we do get
commit dash m and we just put in we're
just gonna say uh made changes to
first branch and that's just uh
documentation so that we know what we've
done and there we are we've uh committed
the file so we had
that file info three txt
committed and now we're going to go
ahead and merge the files into the main
master and
so we can actually have everything
together as one consistent environment
and we do that by typing in so this
lists out what we have in our master
file so we just do ls and that shows
everything in the folder and we have
info.txt
info 1 txt info 2 txt and info 3 txt are
now all in the first branch so let's go
ahead and we're going to merge okay so
actually before we merge we have to
check out the master branch so we do get
checkout master so it gets us into the
master branch and you'll see that we
have just one file on there info.txt so
we're going to list out the files in the
master branch and so so what you'll see
is info dot text info one text and info
two texts are there but info dot info
three text isn't there because that was
created in a separate bunch so let's go
ahead and merge the first branch into
the master branch so we do git merge and
we do first underscore branch and there
we are we've merged it in and
accidentally looks good so let's go
ahead and list out the files that we
have in the master branch and we do ls
and then you'll see that we have four
files including the info three dot text
so we had it in a separate branch now
all in the master branch in this video
we will look at how to install selenium
on windows system selenium installation
is a three-step process so it has
certain prereqs the first prerequisite
you need to have java in your system so
we will be installing java first and
then we will be working with eclipse id
so we will be installing eclipse and
then we will install selenium for java
we will install the version java 8 and
for eclipse we have a version 4.10 this
was the last stable version which was
released in december last year so i'll
be using that version and selenium we
will download the latest 3.14 version
okay so let's get started with our first
step which is the java installation so
to install java let's go to the browser
and simply just search for java 8
download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211. so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what i've done is
i've just created a directory called
installers and i'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here i have
a folder called java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to i would like to leave it as
default here and we just go and click on
next and then the java installation is
in progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
you we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which had installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what i
will do is i will just copy this path
and then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting and
here in the environment variables find
the path variable okay and then say edit
now what are we doing here in the path
variable is we are going to add the java
bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you're editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt and
just say java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 201906
so especially with eclipse since it's an
open source i prefer to work with the
last stable version and so does most of
the developers do and hence that is the
reason why i have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is
4.10 which was released in last december
so you can always choose to go with the
latest version but then if there are any
issues and if you're like first time
working with the eclipse you're going to
get confused as where these issues are
coming from right so i would still
recommend that you use the last stable
version which is available with your
eclipse so now to get the last table
version what you need to do is go and
click on this download packages and here
if you scroll down this page you can see
here more downloads so there is a list
of all the previous releases of epclipse
which is available and this is what we
need to download so just click on that
4.10 version and then click on the os on
which you want to install eclipse for us
it is windows so i'll just click here on
the 64-bit windows and then click on the
download and you will be downloading the
complete package so once you download
this is what it will look like so let's
go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the eclipse which i got
now what's the next step i need to do
just launch this installer and install
eclipse so i'll just say double click on
this i'll say run
so here you'll see multiple options here
for eclipse installation so depending on
your requirement you can go ahead and
install any of these packages so for us
we just need an eclipse id for java
developer so i'll select this and i'll
say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is ok we can leave it as it
is and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what
opens when you launch the eclipse you
need to specify a workspace directory
now what is this workspace directory so
this is a directory or a folder wherein
all the java files or any programs or
any artifacts which you are going to
create through eclipse will be stored in
this particular folder so this could be
any location on your system so this is
you can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace i'll say my workspace and then
i'll say launch so every time i open the
eclipse right so if this is going to
take as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so i'll
say file new and since i'm going to be
using java with selenium i'll say create
java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the jre which
you want to use so we just installed
this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going to click
on use default gre otherwise you also
have an option to use a project specific
jr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this gives
me an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here it will show up in
this list so and you can just go ahead
and select that now since we have only
one java installed on our machine which
is java 1.8 i will say use default gre
which is 1.8 and i will click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selenium
so let me go to my browser and here i
will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org is
going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for selenium so here go
to the download tab now for you to
install selenium and start working with
selenium there are three things which
are required for you to download one is
a standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium however when you
start working with remote selenium
webdriver you would be requiring this
when you have a grid setup you will be
requiring the standalone server so for
that what you can do is you can just
download the latest version available
here so when you click on that it will
download the file into your download
folder so this is one particular file
which you need to keep next selenium
client and web driver language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java so that means my
client package of java is what i need to
download so whatever programming
language selenium supports we have
respective downloadables available with
it say if you're working with python
then you need to download your client
library for python and since we are
working with java you need to download
this package so simply what you need to
do click on this link and it will
download the java package for you which
are basically the jar files so we have
client libraries now and then there is
another component what we need now with
selenium you are going to be automating
your web browser applications correct
and you also want your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create should be able to run
on any browser selenium works with
multiple browsers like edge safari
chrome firefox and other browsers even
it has a support for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its own driver files now say
for example we want to say work with
firefox driver so that means for us to
start working with firefox browser we
need to download something called as a
gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome browser you need to
install the chrome driver so depending
on what browsers you'll be testing with
go ahead click on each of this link and
download the latest driver files now
since we are going to be working with
firefox in this demo what i need to do
is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq dot or for us to install
selling so let me show you the folder
where i have already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once i download this this is a
zip file after i unzip the file this is
the folder structure i see and let's see
what is there in this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selling it and then we also downloaded
the driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
this library and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jars click on add external jars go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so i
have two jar files here i'll just say
click open again i will click on add
external jar now from the libs folder i
will select all this file so select all
the five jars and click on open so you
should see all the seven jar files here
so once you have this just say apply and
close now if you look into your project
directory here you will see some a
folder called referenced library and
this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts all right so now let's just test
our installation by writing a small
selenium test script so for that what i
will do is i'll go to the source folder
right click new and i'll say java class
so let's name this as say first selenium
test and i will select this public
static void main and i will click on
finish all right so now let's uh create
a use case say we want to launch a
firefox browser and then we want to
launch the amazon site so this will be
just two simple things which we will be
doing in this test script so for me to
do that what i usually do is i create a
method for any functionality which i
want to create here so now i want to do
a launch browser so i'll create a method
here called launch browser now whenever
you start writing your selenium scripts
the first line what you need to do is
you need to declare an object of web
driver class so here i'll say
web driver driver so now if you hover
over this error what it is showing it
says import web driver from or dot open
qa dot selling in so if you remember
when we installed the selenium we
imported all these jars right so that
means so what whenever we want to use a
web driver we need to import this class
from these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import state done now next
step now for us to launch a firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that i'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value bill now
what is the key i'm going to mention
here i'm going to be mentioning the
gecko driver and the path for the gecko
driver okay because since i'm working
with the firefox so in double quotes
i'll say
webdriver.geco.driver this is my key and
the value is going to be sorry the fully
qualified path for your driver files and
you know where we have kept our driver
files let's go to that driver files in d
colon i have selenium tutorial in
installers i have driver folder okay so
i'm just going to copy the complete path
from here ctrl c and
i paste it here control v along with
this i need to provide the file name for
the geckodriver which is
geckodriver.exe and let's complete this
step next so once i've set the property
i need to provide a command for
launching my firefox driver and how do i
do that i simply use this driver object
which i have created driver equal to
new firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for web driver
we also need to import the package for
firefox driver so just hover over the
mouse over that and select import
firefox with these two statements we
will be able to launch the firefox
browser and as i said in our use case
what is the next thing we want to do we
want to launch say amazon dot in website
for that there is a command in selenium
which says
driver.get and you pass the url here so
for me to write the url what i usually
do is i go to my browser i open the
website which i want to work with in our
case it's amazon.in and i just simply
copy this fully formed url go to my
eclipse and just paste it here now this
ensures that i don't make any mistakes
in typing out the url let's complete the
statement and we are done and now in the
main function i'll just create an object
of this and we will call this method so
i'll copy this class for selenium test
say obj equal to new for selenium test
and now i'll say obj dot this is a
function launch processor so let's save
this and execute this ctrl c right click
run as
java application okay so the mozilla
firefox has been launched now it should
launch your amazon dot bingo so there
goes our first test script which runs
successfully in this session we will be
looking at how to install selenium on
your mac machines
selenium installation on mac is a three
step installation
one we need to install java which is a
prereq and then we need an id to work
with so we will be installing eclipse
and then we will install selenium and
these are the versions of the installers
which we are going to use so we will be
using java 8. eclipse version 4.10 which
was released in 2018 december and then
selenium version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the java installation
so for us to install java let us go to
our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for
java 8 download
okay so we would select the oracle site
for downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since i
already have one i have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on mac this
is the package which i am going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package and i
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i have created a folder called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what i have
downloaded it and kept it here so we
will go step by step so that you
understand what each of these packages
are so as you see here i have the jdk 8
which i've already downloaded so let's
go ahead and install jtk so how do we
install jdk so you have the dmg file
here you just go ahead and double click
on that
okay and then i will double click on
this package
and then we will say continue and
install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay i've given my password and i'll say
install the software
probably it'll just take a couple of
minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed so i let me close this
window let me close this window tool and
then now i'll go to my terminal window
so let's open my terminal and here
let's say java minus version
bingo so there we have java 1.8
installed on our system now there are a
couple of other things which you need to
do apart from installation of your jdk
you also need to set some system
variables right so in mac how do you set
the system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your bash
profile so let's see how we do that all
right so what i will do is i'll use an
editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file for your bash cell
this is mainly used to export variables
in your shell
like in windows we are going to do the
system variable setting from the
advanced setting right so similarly we
are going to do that here so i will say
vi dot
bash underscore
profile so this is the file
where
i will be adding java home path
now i have other parts here already
written because i am working with other
multiple software on this machine and
now i'll go to the end of this file and
i'll say
export
java home equal
now what is the path we need to give for
java home we need to give the path where
the java has been installed on your
system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then i have a folder called library
here so here
there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines so if you have a single java or
multiple java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is java
virtual machines and java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your jre and bin folder so
that means i need to give my java home
path until here
till this home directory so simply what
i'm going to do is i'll just go here say
get info because i want to just copy the
path and what you can do is you copy
this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here i'm going to paste this path
plus i want it till the home directory
so i'm just going to type out h o me
home that is it so you have now set your
java home environment variable so simply
you do
save the file escape colon wq and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile uh to be
activated you just exit out of this
terminal
okay close this terminal window and i
will go ahead and open another terminal
so let me close this
info text so here let me again give java
minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences
okay here you will see this java control
panel okay this is another way of
finding out that your java has been
installed successfully on the machine so
you can just open this java control
panel and if there is any settings which
you want to do here you can do it
through your control panel also
all right
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what i will do i'll go to my
browser
okay and
now i'll open another tab here
and i'll say
eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you are working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
i would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what you are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions i just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that
on this page if you scroll down you will
see something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions so since today i'll be
working with 4.10 version i will go
ahead and click on this
this 4.10 was released last year this is
2018 december okay and now when you look
at this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what i would be using is eclipse id
for java developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then i'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me i've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this eclipse java 2018 12
r
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using to
install eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk i am going to double click
on this and install the eclipse let's
see how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now
i'll just move this folder into
applications
done
so my eclipse is ready now so simply
let's go ahead and launch what i'll do
i'll just simply search for that on my
system eclipse there you go and i'll
just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it okay
it is launching it so did you see how
simple the eclipse installation is it's
just downloading the package and just
installing it on your mac machine all
right when you start the eclipse for the
first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you're going to keep all your folders
all your
java code or whatever you're going to do
in eclipse all under that particular
directory um so right now it gives me a
default directory rather what i will do
is since i have created a separate
folder for our demos i will go ahead and
select that folder which is my simply
demo
and then in this i will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files i'm going to
create whatever code i'm going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i'll go ahead and
say launch so it will take a minute to
load your workbench yeah there it goes
so when you launch your eclipse
right so let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the welcome
screen
just go ahead and close the welcome
screen and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today
and i just need this main screen here
now what is the first step you're going
to do once you have the eclipse i would
go ahead and create a project first
so i'll simply say open file new java
project let's give a nice name to this
since this is a first project which is
going to be created so i'll say selling
name
first project
now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while i create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution jre which
you already have on the system that's
why it is already chosen java one dot it
in case you have multiple javas
installed in in that case what you can
do is you can always go here select this
and select the java of your choice so
say if you have got the latest java
which is java 12 installed on your
system it will give you an option here
along with java software 8 it will give
you java 12 here so you can go ahead and
select that for this particular project
that option is also available now since
we have only one jtk installed here i
will go ahead and create this project
so i just click on finish and it's going
to create a project from so there are
few default things which it grades
created one is definitely the gre system
libraries right this is what we told
eclipse when we created project that my
java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our java programs to work
in our eclipse id and then it creates a
src which is your source directory
wherein we will be creating all our java
code or selenium test scripts okay good
so far so this is a simple way of
installing your eclipse and getting your
eclipse ready to work with your it all
right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq
dot org
so this is going to be a bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what i do is
i go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with selenium
one is the selenium standalone server
so when you are going to be working with
remote selenium webdriver is when you
would require this however i would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what i just need
to do is i need to click on this and
it's going to download this server for
me
so i have already downloaded it and i'll
show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay we need a client so what is the
client which you are going to work in we
are going to working with java client
with the selenium and for that i need to
go ahead and download this if you're
working on say c sharp or ruby or python
then you have the respective packages
which you can go and download now since
we are going to be working with java
here i would go ahead and click on this
and this is going to download the java
client for me now as i said since i've
already downloaded it so let's go ahead
and look at what are those downloadables
what we have so let's close out this
window now if you see here
uh one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded and then when
you download the client libraries what
it does it it creates a zip file it
downloads a zip file and it unzips it
and what is contained in that particular
folder so if you look here selenium java
3. in this folder you have multiple jar
files
with which is what we'll be working with
selenium
so here you have two jar files here and
then under the folder libs you have
other jar files
now these are the files which we will
need and now let's see how do we utilize
this file in our eclipse so for that
let's go back to our eclipse okay so
let me maximize this window so in
eclipse first thing what you need to do
is click on your project
okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
now here in this configured build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium site so that is present in our
selenium java 3. so what i'll do i'll
simply select
these two first
okay
then again you click on the external jar
files what we have is ellipse so select
all the jar files in the list say open
you have all the java files what we need
identified here go ahead and click on
apply and close
once you do that how do you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly go to the reference libraries
here you should be able to see all the
selenium jars which we have downloaded
to be listed out here and so it lists
here so that means we have successfully
imported selling to test our
installation let's go ahead and write a
small test script so for that i'll go to
my source folder
right click new and will create a java
class so let's name it
selenium
first test
and i will also use a public static void
main here and i'll click on
finish
let's remove all this comments here
which we do not need so before when we
write our first line of code first what
we need to do is create an object of
webdriver so i will say webdriver
driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to import this particular web
driver class from a package and that
package is org dot open q a dot selling
okay so now you can see this import
statement
now let's go ahead and write our
test case now for this test case what we
will do is uh we will simply launch a
browser say firefox browser and we will
also launch a website
now i'll create a method for that i'll
say public void
launch browser
so if you have looked at our previous
videos on selenium webdriver basics i
have explained there that every browser
which you want to work with in selenium
comes with its own driver and this
driver is what we need to download from
the website of selenium and i'll show
you how to do that so if we go to that
seleniumhq.org
under the downloads tab if you go down
you will see something called as
third-party drivers bindings and plugins
so all the browsers supported by
selenium are listed here and their
corresponding driver files are available
so now since we are going to be working
with firefox in this demo i will go
ahead and click on this latest release
of mozilla gecko driver so gecko driver
is the one which will be using for
launching our firefox
so just click on this and this will take
you to the latest version of the gecko
driver available so just scroll down and
depending on the os which you're working
with in our case it is a macros so just
click on this file and download this
file
similarly
say if you are working with the chrome
driver what you need to do is go to this
chrome driver
go to the latest
click on that
and select the release which you want to
work with and just download it
now i've already downloaded this file
and i'll just show you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory i have another
directory created called as drivers
and what i do is usually i keep all my
driver files under this folder
okay so i have a chrome driver and gecko
driver already downloaded and kept here
now let's go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to launch our
browser so there are two steps which we
need to do for launching any browser
which you want to work with right first
is you need to set a system property so
for that what i do is
system
dot set property
and this accepts a key and value pair
now key for this is geckodriver is what
i need to provide here and now that is
in the codes because it's a string
argument i say webdriver
dot
gecko
dot driver
and the value is
nothing but the path to your gecko
driver which you have just downloaded
okay let's go to my finder so that's
here so what i do is i simply right
click on this file get info
and i copy this complete path
go to my eclipse
paste this path here
and then the file name which is
geckodriver
so this sets a path to my gecko driver
now next step is actually launching the
web browser and how do i do that i say
driver
equal to new
firefox driver
now we need to do the same thing again
we need to import this class so i say
import firefox driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
firefox browser
and then let's go ahead and also launch
a website say amazon.com so for that i
have a command called
driver.get
which accepts a url
now this url needs to be fully formed
url so for that what i do first is i go
to my any browser i launched the amazon
dot in website
okay and then i copy this complete url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.com so let's
quickly create a class here
object here of this class
so selenium first test
obj equal to new
study name first test
done and then i need to call the method
which is
launch browser
okay so now i save this file i do a
right click on this and i say run as
java application now
this should
launch our browser
okay which it just did and then it
should take us to amazon.com bingo there
goes our first script so we have
successfully executed our first script
so that means your selenium is up and
running successful if you're going to
embark on a journey of automation i
promise you this is the right place to
start so let me take you on the first
lap of this journey this is a video
tutorial what is selenium from simply
learn what is in it for you before you
start understanding any automation tool
it's good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how an automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components and we
will be looking into each of them as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages and
limitations of selenium and how do we
work around it selenium jobs and salary
very important isn't it you are here to
learn selenium you definitely want to
know what's the market demand on the
skill what what you will be once you are
skilled on this automation tool so what
we will do we'll just discuss some stats
on the job market related to test
automation and selenium in particular
all right so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges what is
manual testing manual testing mainly
involves physical execution of test
cases against various application and to
do what to detect bugs and errors so as
a definition if you can say it is one of
the primitive methods of testing a
software execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of any automation
tools and can practically test any
application this could be as simple a
definition can be let's do one thing
let's take an example right before we
start understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example say we
have a simple use case as a user i want
to log into my web application using
username and password a very common use
case isn't it and this is a common use
case for any kind of web application
under test now let's say for example i
have a web application here say i have
this
community.simplylearn.com for me to
actually enter into this application
what i need to do is first log into this
application so this is a simple login
page which accepts a user id or an email
id a password and you click on the login
now as a tester you would write multiple
test cases to test this use case for
example you will have multiple data test
cases like valid credentials invalid
credentials null value and so on you
will also test multiple links on this
page probably the forget password link
the sign up now so whatever links are
made available you're going to test that
then you will say it as this check box
so you will check the remember me
functionality and when you log in back
again you want to validate if all your
previous data are filled up you will
also check for error messages on an
invalid login you will do accessibility
testing you will also do a performance
on this page like say for example
response time after you click on login
button and so on so while you are doing
a manual testing literally you can do
any kind of test you want so this is
what you do in the first place and then
you start executing these test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
again and again until all your bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now this is a very simple use case
now let's look at a little complex use
case now say you have an account
creation form like this so i have this
online pan application form right this
is still a simpler form i would say now
look at the amount of data you need to
fill here each and every field you need
to test and you need to test this with
hundreds of transactions because you're
going to have those kind of data sets
with you and then you're going to repeat
them again and again until you are
satisfied that your application is
working as per it is designed so now if
you go back to our presentation now this
brings us to the first demerit of the
manual testing and what it is this is
very time consuming process and hence
it's going to get very boring for any
manual tester also it is more error
prone the risk of error is pretty high
why because it is done manually and
human mistakes are bound to happen
requires presence of tester all the time
since it's manual execution tester's
presence is required all the time one
needs to keep doing manual steps over
and over again and hence he needs to be
sitting in front of his pc manual
creation of logs and repositories
creating manual reports grouping them
formatting them so that they are like a
good looking reports sending those
reports manually to all the stakeholders
say collecting logs from the various
machines after you execute the test
cases consolidating all those results
and logs right creating repositories
maintaining them wow this is a huge long
list of mundane tasks one needs to do
and this you need to do a do again and
again until your testing is completed
right so this is going to be a manual
process and it's going to be very
tedious and as i said it was also error
pro limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited for example say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
what you do you will pick up choose your
test cases and then execute that way you
are kind of limiting the scope of
testing also say working with large
amount of data which is manually pretty
impractical what about performance
testing so you want to say collect
certain metrics on various performance
measures as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test hence performing this
manually is definitely not feasible and
to top it all the say you're working in
an agile model where your code is being
churned out by developers say every week
testers are building their tests and
they are executing them as and when the
bills are made available to them for
testing now this happens iteratively and
hence you will need to run all the test
cases which you have created multiple
times during your development process
and doing this manually is going to
become definitely very tedious and
boring and is this really effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automate it so this tells us why we
want to automate one one is for the
faster execution two to be less error
prone and the most importantly to help
you run your test cases frequently as
many times as you want so there were
many tools available in the market today
for automation so one such tool is
selenium advent of selenium much before
selenium there were various tools in the
market like rft qtp just to name a few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
a gentleman called jason huggins way
back in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
manual testing his application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner he
also made this open source which later
was renamed as selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool to test web application so
what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kind of browsers like ie chrome
firefox safari edge opera and even the
headless browser selenium is an open
source and it's platform independent the
biggest reason why people are preferring
this tool is because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which i
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
tools selenium is also a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components in it
which we will be seeing in detail in
some time and all these tools together
they help us test the web application
you can run selenium scripts on any
platform it is platform independent as
and why it is platform independent
because it is developed in javascript
it's very common for manual testers not
to have in-depth programming knowledge
so the selenium has a record and replay
back capability and this tool is called
as selenium ide which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
then you just have to replay that script
so mainly this is used for demo purposes
because selenium itself is such a
powerful tool and it offers so rich
functionality you would want to be in a
position to take the advantage of all
its future however if you have testers
who do not have enough of programming
knowledge to start with there is still
this id which is a record replay tool
which you can use to create your test
scripts it also provides support for
different programming languages like
java python c-sharp ruby and so on so
you can literally write your test
scripts in any language you like or
which you know of so one need not again
know a complete in-depth or an advanced
knowledge of any of these languages
selenium supports different operating
systems and browsers it supports windows
max linux and say if you want to run
your test on ubuntu machines yes that is
also possible it's on any platform of
your choice selenium you can run the
test cases selenium suite of tools so
now let's go little more deeper into the
selenium so as i said it is a suite of
tools and these are the major components
of the selenium selenium ide selenium
remote control which is in short called
as rc selenium web driver and selenium
grid from selenium 3.0 version onwards
you will not find the remote control
anymore because it has been deprecated
but you still have your id webdriver and
grid components now let's take a deeper
look into each of these components and
understand how they function in the
suite of tools selenium integrated
development environment which is called
as selenium ide so it is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it's an integrated development
environment it has a record and playback
functionality and it's very very simple
and easy to use too however it is mainly
used as a prototyping and not used for
creating the actual automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitations since it's just a record
and replay tool so this ide is available
as a firefox plugin and a chrome
extension so either you can use firefox
or the chrome browser to record your
test scripts the commands created in the
scripts where you are going to record
are these commands are called selenius
commands and these are the commands
which interact with your browser you can
also write some of these commands
manually while you're recording your
scripts and we'll see how to do that
when we talk about the id in detail and
it is again a platform independent so
you can deploy ide on any platform of
your choice so you can have it on your
windows linux and macros however the
only requirement is you should have
either chrome or firefox browser support
on that particular platform earlier
selenium ide was only a firefox
extension it died with the firefox
version 54 or i55 i guess so id was not
supported from the 55 version onwards
and this was some time during 2017.
however very recently all new brand
selenium ide has been launched by apply
tools and they have made it cross
browser that is it is available both on
chrome and firefox now so you can
install this extension as a chrome
extension or as an add-on on your
firefox browser it's a completely
revamped version which was done by apply
tools they literally rewrote the
complete code and now they have made it
available on the github under the apache
2.0 license and it also comes with many
new features now like reusability of
test cases it has a better debugging
technology now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution it has
introduced an utility called selenium
side runner that allows your test cases
to run on any browser so you can create
your automation using your ide on chrome
or firefox however through the side
runner from your command prompt you can
execute any of your test cases on any
browser of your choice and thus by
achieving your cross browser testing you
can also run parallel testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this again this can be done using the
selenium site runner and having the grid
installation done so let's look at how
ide looks like and what are its
components are and how do we work with
ide let's go to the firefox browser now
and launch the ide and see how the id
looks so let me go to my firefox now on
this browser if you can see here there
is an icon here which says selenium id
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the selenium id plugin so now
i'll just go click on this and then i
already have a project created so this
is the ide window which gets opened for
me i have a pre-recorded script here and
what the script does is i just open
dot in website and i am searching for
the product iphone also i have an
assertion statement here which asserts
for the webpage title and then i'm
closing the browser so let's first
execute the script and see how it works
and then we will get into the details of
what are the different components
available on this id so for me to
execute what i will do is it id has a
very beautiful feature here to control
the speed of the execution so what i'll
do is i'll reduce the speed a little bit
so that you should be able to see the
complete execution step by step now to
execute the script i'll just go here and
say run current test so this opens the
firefox window and the amazon dot in
website it should search for iphone
product now then it is going to do the
title assertion and close the process so
if you look here all the statements look
in green now so that means every step
has been executed successfully and there
are no errors so now let's look at the
components of this id so the first
component which you need to understand
is how do you record the test so there
is a start recording button made
available to you clicking on which you
can launch any website of the
application under test and you can start
recording your steps and once you have
recorded you can use this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test so if
you want to execute multiple tests then
you have an option to do so here which
is run alt test this particular window
what you are seeing here right so this
is the window where you have all your
commands which gets recorded when you
record your script and these are pretty
simple commands and they're very
self-explanatory like say for example
open so it says open and the target is
amazon.com that means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have and then
typing what is the product which you are
searching for and then you have multiple
assert statements made available to you
in this idea so these are all called as
the selenius command and as simple as a
close browser command and now if you
look here in this window this is log
window so every step which gets executed
here there is a log generated showing
you the status of the execution of that
step so if at all there is a failure you
would see a red failed mark against that
particular step and the test case will
not say completed successfully it will
say the failure occurred okay so it is
very simple and a very user friendly
kind of an id so let's go back to our
presentation so we saw the play button
here and we saw how to record it i also
showed you the commands the command
window what we have so these are the
selenium commands and then we saw the
log which indicated the execution of
each of this command now saving the
script so let me go back to the id again
so once you have created your test
scripts you have run it successfully you
need to save your project so for you to
save the project when you click on the
save project every ide project it is
saved with an extension dot sid which is
nothing but selenium id so you just go
ahead and click on save since i've
already saved this project i'm going to
just say cancel so that's the text file
extension it uses to save your project
for more details on how to use ide you
can watch our video on selenium id on
simplylearn.com selenium rc this is
selenium remote control so this was
developed by paul hammon and he
refactored the code and was also
credited with json as a co-creator of
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming language the server itself
is written in java language it supports
multiple programming languages like java
c perl python and php it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it uses a simple http get and post
request for communication this rc server
is also a selenium 1.0 version but it
got deprecated in selenium 2.0 and was
completely removed in 3.0 and it got
replaced by selenium webdriver we will
see why this happened when we talk about
the selenium webdriver this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was javascript program
and he called it as javascript
testrunner and it is also called as
selenium core so every html has this
javascript statements which are executed
by this web browser there is a
javascript engine which helps in
executing this command now this had a
major issue of something called a same
origin policy now what is the same
origin policy same origin policy
prohibits your javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with the scripts
from the domain different from where it
is launched and this was for the
security measure for example every web
page inside google.com domain like say
your search email google drive can be
accessible but nothing outside this
domain like say if you want to access
yahoo or an amazon that was not possible
due to security reasons obviously so the
testers had to install the selenium core
and the web server which contained your
web application which you are basically
testing on the same system and this was
not feasible and effective all the time
now to overcome this to overcome the
same origin policy what paul hammond did
was he created something called as this
remote server which is selenium remote
control server and it acted like a proxy
to trick the browser in believing that
your core which is your selenium core
and your web application under test are
on the same domain this thus by
eliminating your same origin policy and
this was called as your selenium remote
control which was a version one of
selenium now if you look at the simple
architecture of this what are the things
it has so one is your script right first
you need to write your scripts using any
supported language like say php java
python and ruby as i mentioned now
before we start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium one version
is you need to install the rc server now
this rc server is a separate application
so once you install this this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
salinist commands now these are the
salinist commands which you have written
in your scripts it interprets them and
it executes it on your browser and the
results are sent back to your test
scripts and this browser interaction
happens only through this rc server
again as i said using a simple http get
and post request to communicate now upon
receiving these instructions right from
the selenium core the response is sent
back to this rc server from your browser
and back to your test scripts so the
cycle starts from your test scripts the
selenius commands are interpreted by
your rc server those are sent to the
browser and it's a simple javascript
which executed on your browser and the
results after the execution are sent
back to your test scripts through your
rc server this is a simple cycle now
this cycle is repeated for every command
written in your test script until your
complete test case is executed okay so
this is how the rc worked now this rc
had few shortcomings and what are those
one is the architecture of this rc
itself was complicated why because of
this intermediate rc server which we
have between the browser and your test
script and this rc server had to be
installed before running any test
scripts so that means this became an
additional setup and it acts as a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser also the execution of
commands takes a very long time it is
pretty slow why because every command it
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to your rc server to the core and
to the browser execute the script and
then again back in the same line which
makes your overall test execution very
slow and now because of this short falls
web driver was introduced so selenium
web driver selenium web drivers were
introduced by a gentleman called styman
stewart
and it was developed in the year 2006.
it is the first cross-platform testing
framework it is a programming interface
to create and run test cases it makes
provision to act on web elements so
basically there are multiple locating
techniques which selenium webdriver
provides us for finding those elements
and to perform operations on those web
elements webdriver does not require a
core engine like rc and it interacts
natively with the browser application so
there is a direct interaction with your
browser application and it eliminates
the need of having that intermediate rc
server and that makes the architecture
pretty simple this web driver again it
supports multiple languages which we
already talked about and also it has
integration with multiple frameworks so
once you understand how the web driver
works what are its functionalities and
what are it drawbacks you will
appreciate the fact that so how does
selenium webdriver overcomes this even
in web driver we have test scripts we
also have a web browser here and then we
have a web driver however what we do not
have this additional server which rc
required and this makes the architecture
of the web driver simpler the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level now due to this direct
communication the speed of test
execution is much faster than rc now how
does this web driver work so we have
something called as client libraries or
the language bindings so we know now
that selenium supports multiple
languages and you're free to use any
supported language to create your
automation script and where are these
libraries available so if you go to
seleniumhq.org so let me go to the
browser and show you that so in the
selenium hq dot r if you go to the
downloads so here you will see something
called as selenium client and web driver
language binding and depending on the
language which you want to work with or
which you want to create test scripts
with you can download this client
libraries so if you're working with java
download the client library for java so
if you're working with python you have a
corresponding link which you through
which you can download your client
libraries and then selenium provides lot
of apis for us to interact with the
browser and these are called as a rest
apis so then we have the browser drivers
through which we interact with the
browser now what are these browser
drivers so there are drivers specific to
each browser so let me show you that on
our
seleniumhq.org so here if you just
scroll down you have something called as
third-party drivers bindings and plugins
for every supported
browser of selenium you have a
corresponding driver file available now
say for example if you want to work with
firefox mozilla gecko driver is what you
need to download and these driver files
so if you go and click here you will get
an executable driver file for
any of the platforms which you're
working so if you're working on windows
mac os or linux you can just download
the corresponding driver files here so
these drivers see these driver files are
the ones which interact with the actual
browser and how does this happen this
driver establishes the connection with
the real browser without revealing the
internal logic of the browser
functionality now what does that mean
say we want to execute a test script and
how does this test script gets executed
first is it it sends an http request
which is generated and sent to this
browser driver which we just saw for
each of the command in your scripts and
then this driver receives the request
through your http server and this hp
http server does all the execution
directly on the browser and then the
execution status the complete status is
sent back to your test script so let me
show you a simple use case how it works
with the web driver so for that let's go
to my eclipse here so i already have a
test script written here in webdriver
and what this basically does is it
launches amazon.com amazon.in website it
uses the firefox browser and then i'm
also fetching the page title and
printing it on the console and then i'm
closing the browser this is a simple
functionality which i'm doing here so if
you look here so the eclipse is the id
which i'm using i've already installed
selenium here and i've written a simple
java class and this java class we have
multiple methods one is to launch
browser one is to fetch the title of the
page and one is to close the browser now
while launching the browser i said every
browser has its own driver files so
somewhere in this java class i need to
tell selenium as which browser to use
and how is that done that is done by
this first two statements here where i
am doing a system.set property and where
i am indicating that this is my driver
file which is geckodriver to be used and
using this i want the selenium to launch
the firefox browser and after this all
the operations any operations which you
want to perform on your web application
under test you can do it here now let's
go ahead and execute this and see how it
works so simply what i need to do is
i'll just say execute this as a java
program so the firefox browser is
getting launched so you can see amazon
dot in being launched here and since we
are not doing any operations here what i
am simply doing is printing the title of
the page and closing the browser that is
it so if you see here you can see the
page title is online shopping site so
and so and this is what i'm printing
through this method which is fetch page
title a very simple way of writing a
automation script using webdriver so now
you saw how we write a small test script
using the webdriver function now say if
i want to run the script on multiple
browsers and on multiple operating
system and i do not have just one test
case i say say i've got hundreds of test
cases now with this approach what you
can achieve your best is you can
sequentially execute on every browser
available and all your 100 or 200 test
cases whatever you have now this is
going to take quite a long time to
execute and hence to reduce the time
taken for the execution selenium has
something called as grid selenium grid
the main objective of the grid is to
minimize your test execution type this
grid is designed to distribute commands
to different machines simultaneously in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment for example a
web application for which say you have
automated thousands of test cases and
you want to run them as a regression
suite across multiple browsers and os
what you need to do is you need to run
them parallelly and not really
sequentially so grid allows this
parallel execution of test on different
browsers and operating system you also
want an integration with reporting tools
so that you can get a consolidated
report after the tests have been
executed on multiple machines so grid
can be integrated with such many other
tools how does the grid work so grid has
this hub and node concept which helps in
achieving the parallel execution let's
take an example say again your
application supports all browsers and it
also supports different os like the one
which you are seeing here like windows
mac and linux and your requirement is to
run tests on all the supported browsers
and operating system like this one so
what you do here is you configure a
master machine that is this which is
also called as hub by running something
called a selenium standalone server and
this selenium standalone server can be
download downloaded from your selenium
hq website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see selenium standalone
server version 3.1.4.5
and this is what you need to
hub download
like this once you do this you also need
to create nodes specific to your
requirement like a windows 10 like a mac
machine with firefox with the windows 8
with a chrome and mac say with safari
browser and the node configuration is
also done using the same server which is
the selenium standalone server so you
create a node configuration on this node
machines so once you have the setup
created through your master that is your
hub you can control on which nodes you
want to execute which test say for
example here say you want to run some
test on your mac machine with safari
browser so you have a kind of smoke test
which you need to run now through the
master you can control this complete
execution so what master does it it
selects this particular node depending
on the configuration which you have set
on the master machine also you could
have multiple possible combinations like
say i want to just run smoke test on all
my nodes i want to run specific
component tests on say only windows 10
with an edge browser or i can say i want
to just run my complete regression suite
but only on mac machine and so on and
all this is controlled through your
master so what happens on the node once
it gets the command from the master the
node actually runs the specified test on
the browser so you can check out our
detailed video on selenium grid for you
to understand how the grid works and how
do we do this configuration and execute
the test to summarize the selenium
versions selenium version 1 comprised of
an ide rc and grid as we discussed
earlier rc was on its path of
deprecation and webdriver was taking
birth so selenium 2 had an earlier
version of webdriver and also rc existed
from 3.0 onwards rc was completely
removed and web driver took its place
also there's a four dot version around
the corner it has more features and
enhancement so some of the features
which is expected are like w3c webdriver
standardization they have an improved
idea and also i believe there are some
improvements done to the grid advantages
of selenium speed and accuracy since
there is no manual execution your test
can run faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution so you can actually
execute large volume of test cases
within a short frame for example let's
say before your release of product
during your last lap of testing you find
a bug and it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and what you
want to do is you want to run all the
test cases pertaining to that area can
you imagine the amount of time which
will be required if you have to do this
manually but by automation you can
achieve this in a short duration of time
and you can also enable releasing your
product in time and with less or no
human error the second advantage is it's
an open source so it's available free of
cost and anyone can download and start
using it supports a wide spectrum of
programming languages it is not
restricted to any particular programming
language whatever language you are
comfortable with you have an option to
use that and to write your selenium
scripts selenium has support for almost
all browsers and operating system
including a headless browser so this
helps you to create test cases once and
run them across all browsers and
operating system and thus saving your
time from manual execution it also helps
in achieving a broad test coverage it's
a pretty easy to use tool you can check
out all our videos and you can just
master the skill of writing automation
scripts reusability and add-ons of
course like any programming languages it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy limitations so
like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also since selenium is an
open source you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials forums available which you can
refer to this tool is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
application or desktop application
automation however what selenium
provides is a support for integrating
tools like apm tool for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation but then
we again have many other tools which can
be integrated with selenium like auto it
and securely selenium again has a
limited reporting capability it can help
create basic reports but we definitely
need more so it provides supports for
tools like test ng report ng extent
reports which you can integrate and
generate beautiful reports powerful
isn't it of course it does not have a
test management capability a tool need
not have all these capabilities but
again you can integrate with the test
management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language the
developer of the automation script need
to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write effective
automation scripts of course a deep
advanced knowledge is not required a
basic knowledge is more than sufficient
so if you look at all this selenium
still provides a complete solution for
your automation need and that's the
beauty of selenium and that is what
makes it the most popular today most
popular tool today for automation
selenium jobs and salary a very
interesting topic so the market trends
for test automation are continuously
changing and selenium has seen an
exponential growth in a very short time
period this selenium makes it convenient
for clients to receive an roi much
faster and how does that happen by
reducing the number of test cycles
involved in testing their product in
present scenario selenium is a perfect
automation for any of your web web
application testing and automated web
application testing and it is the first
choice of your automation tester as well
as the companies also so as the
softwares are becoming more and more
complex so is the test automation and
selenium is a key skill set for any test
automation engineer to have but of
course it's not the only skill set one
needs to have so if you look at a
typical job description here so gone are
the days when the engineers were hired
as a manual tester every company today
wants to hire engineers who knows how to
do automation and since selenium is the
most popular web application automation
tool companies look specifically for
selenium automation engineers and this
is the typical job description of any
automation engineer to develop test
cases to detect bugs and errors
automation framework designing it's not
just about automating your test cases
one should have the ability to design
the complete framework related to the
project to improve and automate test
practices to participate in
communicating best practices defining
test strategy test manuals for tracking
and fixing your software issues let's
look at the compensation part of it so
compensation varies from company to
company and it also depends on your
experience level so according to the
stacks if you look at the us market it
can vary anywhere from twenty one
thousand dollars to one fifty thousand
dollars average could be of course
somewhere around ninety thousand dollars
and if you look at the indian market
range it ranges anywhere from 2 to 10
lakhs per annum for a startup with an
average of 5 lakhs so the more and more
you're going to get experience the
better is going to be a compensation
package and the market has always been
very lucrative for automation engineers
so since selenium is so powerful web
automation tools there are some of the
top end companies who use selenium in
their various project they want to
provide their customers the best quality
software and help them reduce the time
to market and hence they go in for
selenium so a lot of these companies
have selenium deployments do you want to
know what selenium is all about if yes
this is the video for you simplylon
brings to you a very simple tutorial on
selenium what should you expect from
this video before you start
understanding any automation tool it's
good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a facebook
application and in facebook application
let's let's open the facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
these test cases ready what do you do
you start executing these test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
one by one again until all the bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now if one has to run test cases
with hundreds of transactions or the
data sets and repeat them can you
imagine the amount of effort required in
that now that brings us to the first
demerit of the manual testing manual
testing is a very time consuming process
and it is very boring also it is very
highly error prone why because it is
done annually and human mistakes are
bound to happen since it's a manual
executions tester's presence is required
all the time one is to keep doing manual
steps step by step again all the time he
also has to create manual reports group
them format them so that we get good
looking reports also send these reports
manually to all stakeholders then
collection of logs from various machines
where you have run your tests
consolidating all of them creating
repositories and maintaining them and
again since it's all as a manual process
there is a high chance of creating
manual errors there scope of manual
testing is limited for example let's say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
you will pick and choose your test cases
to execute that way you are limiting the
scope of testing also working with large
amount of data manually is impractical
which could be the need of your
application what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measures as a part
of your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on application
under test and hence manually performing
these kind of tests is not feasible and
to top it all up say if you are working
in an agile model where code is being
churned out by developers testers are
building their test and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
available for testing and this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run this test multiple times during your
development cycle and doing this
manually definitely becomes very tedious
and boring and is this the effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automate it so this tells us why we
automate one for faster execution two to
be less error prone and three the main
reason is to help frequent execution of
our test so there are many tools
available in the market today for
automation one such tool is selenium
birth of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like say rft and qtp just to name a few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004 he was an engineer at
thoughtworks and he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing he realized the inefficiency in
manually testing this web application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner later
he made this open source and this was
renamed as the selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence and
since then selenium has become one of
the most powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kinds of browsers
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari edge opera and even the headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rfd which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as i said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium id which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like java python
c-sharp ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has supports for windows mac
linux even ubuntu as well so you can run
your selenium test on any platform of
your choice
and hence selenium is the most popular
and widely used automation tools for
automating your web applications
selenium set of tools so let's go a
little more deeper into selenium as i
said selenium is not a single tool it is
a suite of tools so let's look at some
of the major components or the tools in
selenium and what they have to offer so
selenium has four major components one
selenium ide it's the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is
integrated development environment
earlier selenium ide was available only
as a firefox plugin and it offered a
simple record and playback functionality
it is a very simple to use tool but it's
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation in the real-time
projects because it has its own
limitations like any other record and
replay tool selenium rc this is nothing
but selenium remote control it is used
to write web application test in
different programming language what it
does it basically interacts with the
browser with the help of something
called as rc server and how it interacts
is its uses a simple http postgate
request for communication this was also
called as selenium 1.0 version but it
got deprecated in selenium 2.0 version
and was completely removed in 3.0 and it
was replaced by webdriver and we will
see in detail as why this happened
selenium webdriver this is the most
important component in the selenium
suite it is a programming interface to
create and execute text test cases it is
obviously the successor of the selenium
rc which we talked about because of
certain drawbacks which rc had so what
webdriver does is it interacts with the
browsers directly unlike rc where the rc
required a server to interact with the
browser and the last component is the
selenium grid so selenium grid is used
to run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
it's selenium version comprised of it
had an ide rc and grid and as i said
earlier there were some disadvantages of
using rc so rc was on its path of
deprecation and web driver was taking
its path so if you look at selenium 2
version it had an earlier version of
webdriver and also the rc so they
coexisted from tree dot onwards rc was
completely remote and web driver took
its place there is also a four dot
version around the corner and it has
more features and enhancements some some
of the features which are talked about
are w3c webdriver standardization
improved id and improved grid now let's
look at each of the components in the
selenium suite selenium ide is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and is a very
simple and easy to use tool it is
available as a firefox plugin and a
chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called selenis commands and
they can be exported to the supported
programming language and hence this code
can be reused however this is mainly
used for prototyping and not used for
creating automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitation which any other record and
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium id so earlier selenium id was
only a firefox extension so we saw that
ide was available since the selenium
version one selenium ide died with the
firefox version 55 that was id was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium id has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on chrome as well as as an
add-on on firefox browser so they
completely revamped this ide code and
now they have made it available on the
github under the apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new id now with this new idea also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using
idec on chrome or firefox but through
command prompt using your site runner
you can execute this test cases on any
browser thus by achieving your cross
browser testing control flow statement
so initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your effects conditions the
while loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this id looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the firefox browser so on
this browser i already have the id
installed so when you already have an id
installed you will see an icon here that
says selenium id and how do you install
this you simply need to go to your
firefox add-ons here where it says find
more extension so just type in
selenium id and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see the selenium id just click on that
and now since i've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ide icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this id so when i
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so i already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so i'll go ahead and open that
so i'll say open existing project and i
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
facebook using a dummy user mail your
sorry username and password that's all
it's very simple script with few lines
and this is what it is going to do so
what we will simply do is we'll just run
the script and see how it works for that
i am just going to reduce the test
execution speed so that you should be
able to see every step of execution here
all right so what i'll do now here is
i'll just adjust this window and i'll
just simply say run current test all
right so i'll just get this side by side
so that you should be able to see what
exactly the script is doing okay so now
you are able to see both the windows
okay so now it's going to type in your
user email here there you go and now it
will enter the password and it has
clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy ids it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the id if you look here after i
execute the test case every statement or
every command which i have used here is
colored coded in green so that means
this particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result is
it says fb login which is my test case
name completed successful let's look at
few components of this id the first one
is the menu bar so let's go to our id
all right so the menu bar is right here
on the top so here is your project name
so either you can add a new project here
or rename your project so since we
already have this project which is named
as facebook and then on the right you
have options to create a new project
open an existing project or save the
current project and then comes on
toolbar so using the options in this
toolbar you can control the execution of
your test cases so first one here is the
recording button so this is what you use
when you start recording your script and
then on the left you have two options
here to run your test cases the first
one is run all tests so in case you have
multiple test cases written here you can
execute them one by one sequentially by
using this run all test else what you
can do is if you just want to run your
current test this is what you would use
then id has this debugger option which
you can use to do a step execution so
say for example now whenever i run the
script it's going to execute each and
every command here sequentially so
instead if i just select the first
command and say do step execution all
right so what it does is the moment it
finishes the first command which is
opening of facebook right i think which
is already done here yeah all right so
once this is done it is going to wait
immediately on the second command and it
says pause debugger so from here you can
do whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is just going to simply go ahead
and complete the com complete the test
case now there is another option here
which is you see the timer there it says
test execution speed so to execute your
test cases in the speed you want say
whenever you're developing an automation
script right and say you want to give a
demo so you need to control the speed
sometimes so that the viewer is able to
exactly see all the steps which is being
performed and this gives you an option
to control that complete execution right
so do you see the grading here so we
have somewhere from fast to completely
slow execution so the previous demo
which i showed was i control the speed
and then i executed it so that we could
see every command how it is being
executed all right so what's the next
this is called as an address bar so
whichever wherever whenever you enter an
url here that is where you want to
conduct your test and another thing what
it does is it keeps a history of all the
urls which you have used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded so each and every
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or failed so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if i click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is a details of this
command which i have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this id so
with this you'll get an ideas how do we
actually record scripts in id so for
that i have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon dot in then we'll
search simply search for say product
iphone and once we get that search page
where all your iphones are displayed we
will just do an asset on the title of
the page simple all right so let's do
that so first thing what i need is an
url okay so first let me go to my
firefox browser here and say amazon.com
so why i'm doing this just to simply get
the right url absolute url path here and
so that i don't make any mistakes while
typing in the url okay so i got this so
let me close all this windows i don't
need any of this let's minimize this all
right so here what i'll do in the tests
tab i'll say add a new test and name
this test as
amazon search
done i'll say add now i'll enter this
url which i just copied it from my
browser and then i'll just say start
recording so what it
did was since i've entered the url in
this address box it just opened the
amazon dot in url now let's do our test
case so in my test case what i said was
i want to search for iphone once i have
this i'm just going to click on my
search button so now this gives me a
list of all iphones and then i said i
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is i have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium id options here
so in this i will select assert title
and then i will close this browser so
that kind of completes my test case so
now take a look at all the steps which
is created for me so it says open slash
because i've already provided the url
here so either you can replace it with
your regular url or you can just leave
it as it is so what i will do since this
is going to be proper script and i might
be using this to run it from a command
prompt also so i'll just replace this
target with the actual url and then what
it is doing it is setting a window size
then there are whatever i did on that
particular url on that website it has
recorded all the steps for me so this is
where it says type into this particular
text box which is my search box and what
did it type iphone this was the value
which i entered now there was one more
feature which i told you in this new id
which had which i said it has a failover
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this id is equal to tab search
textbook this is nothing but that search
box where we entered the text iphone and
it has certain identification through
which this ide identifies that web
element and that has multiple options to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is id is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
css and the xpath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if amazon dot
in website changes the id of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular id fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the id it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of these becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
assert title here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all very simple test case
so what we will do now is we will stop
the recording and then i have also given
a closed browser so right now what i
will do is i'll just comment this out
why because if i just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now i'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now i'll just say run the
current test date so your amazon in is
launched
okay it is typed in the iphone it's also
clicked on the search so it is done so
now if you look here since we are in the
reference tab it is not able to show so
let's go to the log and now let's see
the log so it's going to be a running
lock so if you notice here the previous
examples which we have run for facebook
is also in the same lock so we will have
to see the log from running amazon
search because that's our test case so
if you see here every command line right
was executed successfully assert title
was also done and your test case was
executed successfully so it passed now
what we will do is on this assert title
i'll just modify this
and let's say just add some text i'll
just add double s here now this by
intentionally i am going to fail this
discus just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the id behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so i'll just
run the disk test case again so before
that let's close the previous
window all right done and now
here i'll also uncomment the close
because anyway it's a failure which i'm
going to see which i should be able to
see it in the logs so i will close the
browser after the execution of test case
okay so let's simply go and run the test
case okay amazon.com is launched it
should search for iphone now yeah there
you go all right
now it should also close the browser
yes it has closed the browser and it has
failed now see here now this is the line
where our command filled why because the
expected title was not there and if you
look in the logs it says your assert
title on amazon.in failed actual result
was something different and it did not
match with what we had asked it for so
this is how simple it is to use your id
to create your automation scripts so we
saw all the components of id we saw the
record button then i showed you the
toolbar i showed you the editor box and
also the test execution log so now let's
come to what are the limitations of this
id with ide you cannot export your
scripts your test scripts to web driver
scripts this support is not yet added
but it is in the works data driven
testing like using your excel files or
reading data from the csv files and
passing it to the script this capability
is still not available also you cannot
connect to database for reading your
test data or perform any kind of
database testing with selenium webdriver
yes you can also unlike selenium
webdriver you do not have a good
reporting mechanism with the ide like
say for example test ng or repotential
so that brings us to the next component
of the suite which is selenium rc
selenium remote control so selenium rc
was developed by paul hammond he
refactored the code which was developed
by jason and was credited with jason as
a co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in java it is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
java c perl python and ruby it interacts
with the browser with the help of an rc
server so this rfc server uses a simple
http get and post request for
communication and as i said earlier also
selenium rc was called as selenium 1.0
version but it got deprecated in
selenium 2.0 and was completely removed
in 3.0 and it got replaced by what
webdriver and we'll see why this
happened and what was that issue which
we had with the rc server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when jason
huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as javascript program
and then that was also called as a
selenium core so every html has a
javascript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a javascript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this rca had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say
test.javascript here which you are
trying to access elements from anywhere
from the google.com domain so what used
to happen is every element which is
accessible e are the elements which can
belong only to google.com domain like
say for example mail the search or the
drive so any elements from this can be
accessible through your test scripts
however nothing outside the domain of
say google.com in this case was
accessible say for example if your test
scripts wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says it
prohibits a javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from a domain different from where it is
launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
scripts which can access your google.com
or anything related to google.com these
scripts cannot access any elements
outside the domain like as we said in
the example yahoo.com this was the same
origin policy now to overcome this what
this gentleman did was he created
something called a selenium remote
control server to trick the browser in
believing that your core your selenium
core and your web application under test
are from the same domain and this is
what was the selenium remote control so
if you look at again a high level
architecture or how did this actually
work first you write your test scripts
which is here right in any of the
supported language like your php or your
java or python and before we start
testing we need to launch this rc server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the cellini's commands and
these salinis commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your rc server the browser interaction
which happens through rc server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple http and post
and get request and that is how your rc
server and your browser communicate and
how exactly this communication happens
this rc server it acts like a proxy so
say your test scripts ask to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your rc
server launches the browser it injects
the javascript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your test script right from your
test scripts to your browser goes
through your rc and now upon upon
receiving these instruction your
selenium core executes this actual
commands as javascript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
rc to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
javascript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the rc server to the browser
collecting the results again from the rc
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so rc had definitely lot of
shortcomings and what are those so rc
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your selenius command
and your browser the architecture of rc
is complicated why because of its
intermediate rc server which is required
to communicate with the browser the
execution of commands takes very long it
is lower we know why because every
command in this takes a full trip from
the test script to your rc server to the
core engine to the browser and then back
to the same route which makes your
overall test execution very slow lastly
the apis supported by rc are very
redundant and confusing so rc does have
a good number of aps however it is less
object oriented so they are redundant
and confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commands
using a click or a mouse dot both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is the kind of
confusion which developers used to
create hence
selenium rc got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls webdriver was
introduced so while rc was introduced in
2004 webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. it's a class platform
testing platform so webdriver can run on
any platform like say linux windows mac
or even if you have a ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ide and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the webdriver method so when
i do a demo you will understand what
this webdriver methods are and how do we
locate the web elements on the webpage
it does not require a core engine like
rc so it is pretty fast why because
webdriver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate
server like the rc hat so each browser
in this case what happens is each
browser has its own driver on which the
application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the commands
which you will be passing from the
script like say for example click of a
button or you want to enter some text so
through your script you tell which
browser you want to work with say chrome
and then the chrome driver is
responsible for interpreting your
instructions and to execute it on the
web application launched on the chrome
browser so like rc webdriver also
supports multiple programming languages
in which you can write your test scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various frameworks like test ng
junit n unit and report engine so when
we talk about the limitations of
webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various frameworks and tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
webdriver at a high level
what is in web drivers a web driver
consists of four major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries
right or what we also call it as
language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if i go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all these
tabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that i'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you are
working with java here what you need to
do is you need to download your java
language binding so let us go back to
the presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo i'll be showing
you some of this aps right and these are
nothing but the rest apis
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a json wire protocol
what is json javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as i said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation
so does selenium
so let's look at what these limitations
are and if there are any workarounds for
them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like apm
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this apm tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool
and using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium i said that with webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of webdriver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about
also if you want to know more details as
how do we work with the grid how do you
want to install that grid so do check
out our video
on simply learn website on selenium grid
third limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test ng report ng and even extent
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it
also there are other challenges
with selenium like selenium is not very
good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like auto it
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium rc and the web driver
so rc has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
rc server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple
execution speed
it is lower in rc and much faster in web
driver why because in web driver we have
eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that the rc server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers
it requires an rca server to interact
with the browsers we just talked about
it and whereas webdriver can directly
interact with the browser
so rc again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant abs which kept developers
guessing as which api to use for what
functionality
however webdriver offers pretty clean
apis to work with
rc did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in web driver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website
then type the selenium in search bar and
click on it and click on the selenium
3.0 training so we are basically
searching for selenium 3.0 training on
the simply learn website first let's do
the steps manually and then we will go
ahead and write the automation script so
let's go to my browser
on my browser what i'll do is let me
first launch the simplylearn website
okay and here what my use case step says
is i need to search for
selenium and click on the search button
so once i do that it is going to give me
a complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with
simplylearn and what i'm interested in
is the selenium 3.0 training here once i
find this on the webpage i need to go
and click on that all right so this is
all the steps which we are going to
perform in this use case okay now so for
writing the test cases i'll be using an
id which is eclipse i've already
installed my eclipse and also i have
installed selenium in this instance of
my eclipse all right so if you can see
the reference library folder here you
will see all the jars which are required
for the selenium to work next another
prereq which is required for selenium
and that is your driver files now every
browser which you want to work with has
its own driver file to execute your
selenium scripts and since for this demo
i'll be working with the firefox browser
i will need a driver file for firefox
now driver file for firefox is the
geckodriver which i have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers
now where did i download this from let's
go ahead and see that so if i go back to
my browser and if you go to your
selenium hq dot website you have to go
to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this you
will see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you are working on you need to
download that particular file now since
i am working on mac this is the file
which i am using if you are a windows
user you need to download this zip file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
firefox or a chrome driver for your
chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class i already have a
package created in this project so i'll
use this project and create a new class
so i'll say create new java class and
let's call this as
search training i'll be using a public
static void main and i'll click on
finish
so let's remove this auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your code is what you need
to do is you need to define or declare
your driver variable using your class
webdriver so what i would do is i'll say
web driver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this id is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from org dot open sq dot selenium this
is the package which we will need all
right so you have a driver created which
is of the class web driver and now after
this i'm going to create three methods
all right so first method i will have
for
launching the firefox browser okay and
then i will write a simple method for
searching
selenium training
and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method i'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which i am going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
i'll be creating and from the public
static void main i will just call these
methods one after the other okay so let
us go ahead and write the first method
now my first method is launching the
firefox browser so i'll say public void
since my return type is null or there is
no return type for this let's call it as
launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser i need to mention two steps
now the first step is where i need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then i'll explain what this
does i'll just say system dot set
property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is webdriver dot
gecko dot driver and i need to provide a
value so value is nothing but the path
to the gecko driver and we know that
this gecko driver which i'm going to use
here is right here in the same project
path under the drivers folder correct
and that is what the path which i'm
going to provide here so here simply i
need to say
drivers slash gecko driver
g-e-c-k-o all right done and let me
close this sentence all right now since
i'm a mac user my gecko driver
installable is just the name gecko
driver if you're a windows user and if
you are running your selenium scripts on
the windows machine you need to provide
a complete path to this including dot
exe because driver executable on your
machines is going to be geckodriver.exe
so just make sure that your path which
you mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is i
need to just say driver is equal to new
firefox driver okay so this command new
firefox driver creates an instance of
the firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the firefox driver classes present
okay we did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the firefox
browser firm so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now i need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called
driver.get
driver.get what it does is whatever url
you're going to give it here in this
double quotes as an argument it is going
to launch that particular website and
for us it's a simply learn website so
what i do as a best practices instead of
typing out the url i go to my browser
launch that url which i want to test and
i simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that i do not make any mistakes
in the url okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method i need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so
let me relaunch this let's close this
okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when i did a manual
testing of this i entered the text here
so now since i have to write a script
for this first i need to identify what
this element is for that what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to say right
click here and i'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which i can use
for finding this element so i i see that
there is an id present so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to simply use
this id and then i'll just copy this id
from here go back to eclipse let's write
a method first so i'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training
or just search all right now in this i
need to use a command called driver dot
find element
by id is what i'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the id which i copied from the website
is what i'm going to paste here okay and
then what i'm going to do on this
element is i need to send that text the
text which i'm going to search for which
is selenium so i'll just say send keys
and whatever text i want to send i need
to give it in double quotes so for that
selenium so this is done so now i've
entered the text here and after entering
the text i need to click on this button
so for that i need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name i do
not have anything here all right so what
i can do is i can either use the class
name or i can write an x path since this
is a demo which we have already used id
locating technique i would go ahead and
use the x path here so for me to
construct an x path uh i will copy this
class first okay
and then i already have a crow path
installed on my firefox so i'll use the
crow path and first test my xbox so i'll
just say double slash let's see what was
that element it has a span tag okay so
i'll have to use span and at class equal
to and i'll just copy the class name
here and let's see if it can identify
that element yeah so it is able to
identify so i'll just use this x path in
my code so i'll go back to eclipse and
i'll say driver dot find element
by dot x path and the x path which i
just copied from crow path is what i'm
going to paste here and what is the
action i need to do here i need to say
click
done so i have reached a stage where i
have entered this selenium okay and then
i have clicked on the search button once
i do this i know that expected result is
i should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
i should be able to click on that so for
that again i need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag h2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so i would again would like
to use a x path here now this time while
using the x path i'm going to make use
of a text functionality so that i can
search for this particular text so i'll
simply copy this i'll go to my crow path
the tag is h2 so i'll say simply h2
okay and here i'll say text equal to and
this is the text which i copied i missed
out that yes there so i'm just going to
add an s okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see a blue dotted line it is
able to show us which element it is
identified so i'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ide eclipse so now
here what i need to do is i'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot x path
and paste the x path which we just did
and then again i have to do a click
operation
all right so technically we have taken
all the steps of the use case and we
have written the commands for that
now let's add an additional thing here
say after coming to this page after
finding this we want to uh say print the
title of this page now what is the title
of this page if you just hover your
mouse on this it says online and
classroom training for professional
certification courses simply so what i
will do is after doing all these
operations i will just print out this
page title on our console so for that i
have to just do this driver dot ah so
let's do a sysop so i'll say sys out
system.out.println okay and here i would
say
let's add a text here the page title is
and then let's append it with
driver dot
get title so this is the command which
we'll be using to fetch the page title
done now what is the last method i need
to add just to close the browser all
right so let me add a method here i'll
say public void close browser
and this is one single command which i
need to call i will say driver dot quit
okay and then i need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so i let me use my class name which is
this so i'm going to create an object
obj is equal to
new class name and then using this
object first is i need to call the
method launch browser and then i'll call
the method search
right and then i'll call the method
close process done so technically our
script is ready with all the
functionality which we wanted to cover
from our use case now there are few
other tweaks which i need to do this and
i'll tell you why i need to do this now
for example after we click here right
after we click on the search if you
observed on your website it took a
little while before it listed out all
the selenium trainings for us and
visually when you're actually doing it
you wait for the selenium 3.0 training
to be available and then you click on
that now same thing you also need to
tell your scripts to do that you need to
tell your scripts to wait for a while
until you start seeing the selenium 3.0
training or it appears on your web page
there are multiple ways to do that in
your script and it is a part of overall
synchronization what we call where we
use kind of implicit and explicit kind
of ways now since this is a demo for
demo purpose what i'm going to do is i'm
going to use a command called
thread.sleep and i'm just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this mainly for the demo
purposes you can use a thread dot sleep
command now this thread dot sleep
command needs us to handle some
exceptions so i'm just going to click on
add throws declaration and say
interrupted exception now same thing
i'll have to do it in my main function
also okay so let's do that and complete
it
all right so this is done so by doing
this what am i doing i'm ensuring that
before i click on the selenium three dot
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the
page shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing i'm doing all
right and also now since you're going to
be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly i'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what i'll do is i'll just give a
simple thread.sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds wait should be good enough okay
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this okay now our
complete script is ready so what i'll do
is i'll just save the script and then we
will simply run the script so to run the
script i just say right click run as
java application okay it says ask me to
select and save i have saved the script
now so let's observe how it runs okay
the simplylearn.com
the website is launched so the selenium
text has been entered in the search box
it has clicked on the search okay all
right so now it did everything whatever
we wanted it to do all right so since we
are closing the browser you are unable
to see whether the selenium three dot
training was selected or not however
what i have given here is to fetch the
title after all these operations were
complete and if you see here the
complete operations was done and we were
able to see the page title here okay so
now what i'll do since we are unable to
see whether it clicked on the selenium
3.0 training or not i'll just comment
our the close browser the command okay
so we will not call the close browser so
that the browser remains open and we get
to see whether did it really find the
training link or not ok so let me close
this window we don't need this firefox
window close all tabs and then i'll just
actually execute this script so i'll say
run as java application so save the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we've got the search results it
should click on selenium theoretical
training and yes it is successfully able
to click on that all right so now it's
not going to close the browser because
we have commented on that line however
it did print us the title here all right
so this is a simple way of using the
selenium scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallelly so design
is in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run test and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a windows
machine one of them is a mac machine and
another one is say a linux machine so
your requirement is to run the test on
all supported browsers and operating
system like the one which is depicted in
this picture so what you have to do is
first thing is you configure a master
machine or what you also call it as a
hub by running something called a
selenium standalone server and this
talent standalone server can be
downloaded from the selenium hq website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so i'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our selenium hq website so you
can see here right on the top it says
selenium standalone server and this is
the latest version available so you just
need to download
once you download this keep a version of
this one on your master machine that is
your hub and this should also be present
on your node machines and there is a
certain command which you can use to
install the server as a node and as a
master depending on your configuration
so once that is done you have your
master and your master of the hub and
the nodes created your master can
control on which nodes you want to
execute test now say if this is a mac
machine this is a windows machine
through your master or your hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what is then also you could have
a multiple combination of tests like say
for example
smoke test to be run on all these nodes
that's the kind of configuration you can
create or a certain component test to be
run on say only windows 10 with an edge
browser or say regression test on mac
machine so any such things whatever
configurations you have for your node
what happens is the hub picks the right
node which confirms to your requirements
or the configurations which you have set
up and then sends a command to the node
to execute those test cases on the node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does this grid have now
the first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications
it is pretty static each server is
configured in advance with a subset of
required browser instances available
so if you want to vary this you will
need to reconfigure so any configuration
tomorrow on any machines you want to
change it cannot be done automatically
you need to completely reconfigure that
node and then add it back to the grid
thirdly although it is available to run
on virtual servers it is actually not
designed as a cloud native application
and because of as a result of this it
isn't optimized to take advantage of
things like say distributed storage or
dynamic scaling or even automatic
failover so these are some of the
limitations of the grid advantages of
selenium speed and accuracy of course
since there is no manual execution your
test can run faster and with grid it
helps in parallel execution and you can
run or execute large volumes of test
within a very short time frame let's
take an example say before just before
the release of your product say during
the last lap of your testing you find a
bug and of course it has to be fixed so
the developer fixes the bug and you want
to run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time
and it will also help you release your
product in time with very minimal or
absolutely no human errors the second
advantage it's an open source so it's
available free of cost so anyone can
download it and start using it it
supports wide spectrum of programming
languages we have been seeing throughout
this presentation it is not restricted
to any particular programming language
so whatever language you are comfortable
with you have an option to use that and
write your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support so this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping and achieving a
very broad test coverage
and we also saw that pretty easy to use
tool right so you can check out all our
videos and you can it's just a matte
matter of time that you can master the
skill of writing your automation scripts
reusability of course like any
programming language it provides you a
mechanism to reuse your code and avoid
redundancy well again let's see an
overall what are the limitations of
selenium itself now since selenium is
open source that is one of the biggest
advantage now there is a little
disadvantage which comes with that and
what is it you do not have much
technical support because it's an open
source code however there are loads and
loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like apm for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like auto it and securi which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
webdriver has limited limited reporting
capability but again it does provide us
support for integrating tools like test
ng report ng and extent report it does
not have test management capabilities it
need not right not one tool need not
have each and everything what is
required but there is always a way to
integrate it so selenium does provide a
way to integrate any of the test
management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation today we'll see
how to install a very popular continuous
integration tool called jenkins on
windows to download and install jtk
simply type install jdk on google and
click on the first link which is java s8
development kit 8.
as you can see we get a list of
downloads for jdk since i'm on a windows
64-bit system i've already installed jdk
version for windows 64. before you
install jdk you also need to accept the
license agreement
let me show you where my jdk has been
installed
first i go to my c drive program files
under the java folder you'll find two
more folders that's jdk and gre now
let's set up the path in the environment
variable go to system properties
under the advanced tab select
environment variables
under system variables there are two
more variables called java home and jre
home java home contains the path for jdk
i'll show you where it is
go to jtk folder
copy the path and paste it in the value
section gre home contains the path for
gre
similarly go to the gre folder copy the
path and paste it in the corresponding
value
one more thing you need to do is set up
the bin folder location for jdk in path
variables
let's see where the bin folder location
is
here it is
after setting up the location
click ok to finish the setup
now shall we check if java has been
successfully installed for that go to
the command prompt and type java hyphen
version
you can see our java is successfully
installed and it's up and running the
version we've installed is shown here
now let's download jenkins on windows
simply type download jenkins on google
and click on the first link
here we can see that jenkins provides
two types of releases
long term support release and weekly
release
as i'm interested in a more stable
release so i will go for lts
now when i scroll down i'll get an
option for windows
once i select that
a stable installer starts to download
you can see it says thank you for
downloading windows table installer
so now our jenkins has started
downloading this might take a few
seconds
till then maybe you can catch up if
you're left behind
okay so the download is complete
now let's go ahead and unzip downloaded
jenkins file
after the unzipping has been done we'll
start the installation click on this
folder
click run
next this is the default path where
jenkins will be installed we don't need
to change it so we can just go ahead
with next install
after this your jenkins installation is
successfully completed
select finish
yes that's all
now that installation is complete let's
go and explore jenkins
go to your web browser and search
localhost colon 8080.
you can see that it says welcome to
jenkins
so i have already created a username and
password for jenkins
i'll enter my credentials
and that's all this is how the jenkins
homepage and interface looks like
and that's all
signing in
yes so that's the dashboard and this is
how the jenkins homepage and interface
looks like
so if you're installing jenkins for the
very first time it will ask you to
install some recommended plugins i have
already installed mine so i don't need
to install them once again now there are
a lot of things you can do in jenkins
let me run you through a few of them
there's some jobs that i've already
created and run
this is new item it allows you to create
a new project so you can create a
freestyle project a maven project
a build pipeline etc then
going back to the dashboard there is
build history so this section shows you
the status of your build here you can
see what's the built name the time since
the build is running and what's the
status of your build
there is another very important section
called manage jenkins
here you can configure your system
you can configure global security
credentials then there's some global
tool configuration you can also download
and manage your plugins
here you can see the four tabs where you
have some updates you have some
available plugins
you have the plugins that you've already
installed
and then there is advanced plugin as
well
now let me show you how to create and
run a job in jenkins so coming back to
the dashboard let me select new item we
can name our job here let me name the
job as jenkins demo
i will create a freestyle project so
select that and click ok
this might take a few seconds
so when we have created that
here we have a number of options that we
can go ahead with you have your source
code management building triggers
building environment and then of course
some post-build actions
so that's about creating and running a
job in jenkins let's give some
description to our job
so we have create the job we give
description something like this is my
first jenkins job
so we will not use any source code
management tool in the build section as
you can see there is an option to
execute windows batch command
click on that
and here you can give your command
let's use the echo command
i will write something like hello this
is my first jenkins demo
and then i'll also give the date and
time parameters so that i can track on
what date and time this job was built
that's it so click apply and then save
okay so this job is created now let's
build it go to build now
once you click it you can see a built
history has been created click on that
in the console output you can see the
output of your very first jenkins job it
says hello this is my first jenkins demo
what you gave in the command box you can
see that and you can also see the date
date and time when this job was created
so we've successfully created our first
jenkins job
hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using jenkins my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today let's get
started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either build going bad or
build being good or build being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
will have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to back
up your jenkins so jenkins has got a lot
of useful information set up on it in
terms of the build environments in terms
of workspace all this can be very very
easily backed up using a plugin so this
is what i'm going to be covering as a
part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or linux based services so if at all you
have windows like the way i have and i'm
going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever i install it as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warp file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt
referral around linux box specifying
java hyphen jar and the name of this war
file it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that's written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this sequel and program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i have
set it up here in my environment
variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java
iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if i told i do this
the environment variable specific to my
java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container
wherein you know you can launch jenkins
as a container but i'll not get into
details of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into sql and program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to back up your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
jenkins msi installer i would just i
don't want to make any changes into the
jenkins configuration c colon program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if i told you running as a war file you
would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so
if that is not great it will crib about
it but this looks good
so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your your network is not so good
few of these plugins would kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or or mirrored sites and sometimes some
of them may be down so do not worry in
case some of these plugins kind of fail
to install you'll get an option to kind
of retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 1995 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write ui in java you will kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the ui bottom line you are
a little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed jenkins
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and is possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration
this just lets jenkin know at any point
in time how many jobs or how many
threads can be run you can kind of
visualize it like a thread that can be
run on this particular instance
as a thumb rule if at all you're on a
single core system number of executors
two should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
at the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you gotta kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary uh
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured the smtp details of my
personal email id
in case you're in an organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for jenkins server so you can
specify the smtp server details of your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail for sending out
notifications so the smtp server would
be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
ken's
okay one other thing that i want to kind
of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you will have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command
bash or the command prompt for for
running git and connecting to any other
git server so you would need git to be
you know installed on that particular
system and set the path accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it will crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say ok
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you'll see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
would let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time
stamp pertaining to the job i mean the
date and time in which this job was run
all right very very simple command that
says you know this is my first job it
just puts out something along with the
date and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some buildings tray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you would see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you would see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running would you know there will be
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what i'm going to do
i will just keep everything else the
same i'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that
gets
triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and he's asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have my jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my jenkins instance i would need
a way of controlling access to my
jenkins server this is wherein i would
use a plug-in called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global rule and a
project rule project specific growth i
can have different roles and i can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
jenkins instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there is updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it will take some
time for it to get refreshed all right
now these are the available plugins
these are the install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security and uh i would see this
role-based strategy showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to
enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy uh plugin and i'm
going to enable that strategy all right
i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the cia instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qa guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if you hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
or check you know have read-only access
to the job run
no i don't want him to give him any any
particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want read yes definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here how sick configure
managements manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer1 is a user that
i have configured so still have not set
any rules for this particular user yet
so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular global
rule and i would go ahead and save my
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer1
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who
is tagged as a part of this developer
role would get the same kind of
permissions and these permissions can be
you know fine grain it can be a project
specific permissions as well but for now
i just demonstrated the high level
permission that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you would need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonarcube is one of the
popular static code analyzers so you can
connect a jenkins build you can build a
job on jenkins and push it to sonar cube
and get sonar cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our jenkins instance to github i already
have very very simple java repository up
on my github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello java and this is
what is there in the repo there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
sleepers url so what i would do is i
would connect my jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so i
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me i would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
kit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay get job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf
went over all the way to github pulled
this repository from there and then you
know it brought it down to my local
system on my jenkins instance it
compiled it and it ran this particular
application
okay now that i have integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based uh
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it'll compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and you can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index.jsp it just contains an html file
that is there as a part of this web
application so from a perspective of
requirements now since i'm going to
connect jenkins with this particular
repository get we already have that set
we only need two other things one is
maven because jenkins will use maven so
in order to use maven jenkins would have
to have a maven installation that is
there on the jenkins box and in this
case the jenkins box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven
there is zip files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2 home variable to the directory where
you unzip your mi1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat
server 8.5 is what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a
server.xml let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is uploading that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i'll call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository is
this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that i
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm going to just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package
directive let me use this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
the what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential i
would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is same
in web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you've got
to go and change is the url of the
server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what you'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some other machines or some other
slaves you know that's a wonderful thing
to have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dot net
kind of a projects
know mac based system as well so how are
you going to support all these needs so
that's where in a beautiful concept of
master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i'll set up
a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive my
jenkins is on my c drive so what i do is
i would just use my e drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there i'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guy so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or i made a
setting for the master so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and
you know create an agent
so i'll go to managed nodes so if you
see here there's only one master here so
let me provision a new node here so this
is the way you know in which you bring
up a new node you have to configure it
on the server jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular agent so that he can
connect to our jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i'll just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay so if you see the name let me
just copy this name here with the
description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or not 86. c column program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether
so i create a folder here called jenkins
node and this is where i'm going to
place my or i'm going to provision my
slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they'll have to specify this particular
label
so imagine this way if i have a bunch of
windows system i name it as windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
and this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
agent.jar
i would say yes
and this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this
sorry for launching this agent is found
this agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or
whether i cut this i come back to my
folder my jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provisionagen.jar
and i need to use this whole command
ctrl a control c and then launch this
particular agent so let me
bring up a command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen jar
jnlp this is the url of my server in
case the server and client are on
different locations or different ips you
have to specify the ipad address all
this any way would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
connected very well so let me come back
to my
jenkins instance
and see you know if you told me you see
earlier this was not connected now let
me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision are jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials of the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it'll create a workspace right here all
right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here i will say
that you know delegate job is good i say
freestyle project i'm going to create a
very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegated to the
slave negative i don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that i
have configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it ran successfully
and where is the workspace the workspace
is right inside our jenkins node it
created a new workspace delegated job it
put in here so my old or my primary
master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed built in jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up so one quick way to do
that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of us colon program
files colon jenkins directory because
that's where our whole jenkins
configuration is present but we would
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
stop this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you install this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say backup this particular i'll
give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jkins to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server it can kind of slow down
your jenkins instance because it's it's
in the process of copying a few of those
things and the files are being changed
at that moment it's little bit
problematic for jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically try to you
know bring it to a shutdown kind of a
state and then take a backup
all right so i'm going to backup all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations so how do i do that i
just come back to
my manager cans
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
that's an or
jenkins configuration
installation process for docker so
before we begin let me give you an intro
to docker so what is docker docker is a
tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so when i say
containers i mean a software package
that consists of all the dependencies
required to run the particular
application and when you deploy
containers you're basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in any kind of environment so
dockers have multiple features some of
which are that multiple containers can
run on the same hardware it has very
high productivity when compared to
virtual machines it maintains isolated
applications and has a very quick and
easy configuration process so now let's
begin with the demo we'll be installing
docker on an ubuntu system so this is my
system i just opened the terminal so the
first thing you can start with is
removing any docker installation that
you probably already have present in
your system if you want to start from
scratch so this is the command to do so
sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker io
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version 17.12
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a docker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now
the command to check this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a this displays all
the containers that you have pulled so
far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so i did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
sudo
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state
and with that we come to an end of our
docker installation what docker is and
how you could be using it within your
own devops environment so let's get
started in this presentation we're going
to go through a number of key things
we're going to compare docker versus
traditional virtual machines and what
are the differences and why you want to
choose docker over a virtual environment
we'll go through the advantages of
working with docker and the structure
and how you would build out a docker
environment and during that structure
we'll dig through the components and the
advanced components within docker at the
end of the presentation we'll go through
some basic commands and then show you
how those basic commands can be used in
a live demo so with all that said let's
get started so let's first of all
compare docker with a traditional
virtual machine so here we have the
architecture on the left and right of a
traditional virtual machine versus a
darker environment and there are some
things that you'll probably see
immediately that are big differences one
is that the virtual environment has
hypervisor layer whereas the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
now the bit up time for a virtual
machine is fairly slow in comparison to
the boot up time for a docker
environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment that
can lead to instability and performance
issues whereas docker is designed to run
multiple containers
in the same environment and actually
gets better the more containers you run
in that hosted single docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that vm
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
the systems and again the actual boot up
time for a vm it just takes a long time
you took about minutes in contrast to
the milliseconds that it takes for a
docker environment to boot up so let's
dig into what docker actually is and
what allows for these great performance
improvements over a traditional vm
environment so docker itself is an os
virtualized software platform and it
allows it organizations to really easily
create deploy and run applications as
what are called docker containers that
have all the dependencies within that
container very easily
and the container itself is really just
a very lightweight package that has all
the instructions and dependencies such
as frameworks libraries bins etc all
within that container and that container
itself can then be moved from
environment to environment very easily
if we to look in our devops life cycle
the place where docker really shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're actually building the code and
you're actually testing the code having
a container running the solution at
those stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so really
you can use docker in multiple stages
within your devops cycle but it becomes
really valuable in the deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do
rapid deployment and you can do it
really fast the environment itself is
highly portable and was designed for
that in mind the efficiencies that
you'll see will allow you to run
multiple docker containers in a single
environment as compared to more
traditional vm environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create this in turn allows you
to be able to scale your environment
very very quickly but with all of these
advantages probably the one that is most
critical to the type of work that we're
doing today is security you have to
ensure that the environment you are
running is a highly secure but highly
scalable environment and i'm very
pleased to say that docker takes
security very seriously so you'll see it
as one of the key talents for the actual
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how docker
actually works within your environment
so docker works there is a what's called
a docker engine the docker engine is
really comprised of two key elements
that you have a server and a client and
the communication via the two is via a
rest api the server as you can imagine
has the instructions that are
communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do the
connection between the client and the
server the communication is via a rest
api
on older systems you can take advantage
of the docker toolbox which allows you
to go ahead and control the docker
engine the docker machine docker compose
and kitematic so let's now go into what
the actual root components though of
docker are so let's have a look at those
key components there are four components
that we're going to go through we have
the docker clients and server we have
docker images we have the docker
registry and the docker container we're
going to step through each of these one
by one so let's look at the docker
clients and server first so the docker
client and server is a command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your mac or command line on
your pc or linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest api
so you can do some communication such as
a docker pull command which would send
an instruction to the daemon which would
then form the interaction of pulling in
the correct components
such as an image or container or
registry to the docker client the docker
demon itself is actually a service which
actually performs all sorts of operating
and performance services and as you'd
imagine the docker daemon is constantly
listening across the rest api to see if
it needs to perform any specific
requests if you want to trigger and
start the whole process you what you
want to do is use the command dockered
within your docker daemon and that will
start all of your performances and then
you have a docker host which actually
runs the docker daemon and registry
itself so now let's look into the actual
structure of a docker image so a docker
image itself is a template which
contains instructions for the docker
container and that template is written
with a language called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
it's very easy to learn the docker image
itself is built within that yaml file
and then hosted as a file in the docket
registry the image is really comprised
of several key layers and you start with
your base layer which will typically
have your base image in this instance
it's your base operating system such as
ubuntu and then you then have layer of
dependencies above that this would then
comprise the instructions in a read-only
file that would become your docker file
so let's let you go through and look at
what one of those in sets of
instructions would look like so here we
have four layers of instructions we have
a from pull run and then command so what
does that actually look like in our
layers so to break this down the from
creates a layer which is based on ubuntu
and then what we're doing is we're
adding in files from the docker
repository onto that base command that
base layer and then what we want to be
able to do is then say okay what are the
wrong commands so we can actually then
build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of the
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the decor image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a docket image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on write the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker container the
docker environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to keep improving the
efficiency within the actual system
itself all right so let's go on to item
number three which is the docker
registry so the docker registry itself
is the place where you would host and
distribute the different types of images
that you have created or you want to be
used within your environment the actual
repository itself is just a collection
of docker images and those docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml and a very easily stored
and shared and what you can actually do
is you can actually associate specific
name tags to the actual docker images
themselves so it's easy for people to be
able to find and share that image within
the docker registry itself one of the
things you actually see as we go through
the demos you actually see us actually
using the the tag name and you'll see
how it is an alphanumeric identifier and
how we actually use it to actually
create the actual container itself one
of things you can do to as start off how
you would manage a registry is you can
actually use the publicly accessible
docker hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect to the registry of both push and
pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and is being shared so again
full command and it pulls and retrieves
a docket image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you created
and push it to the registry whether it's
docker hub or whether it's your own
private registry and allow it to be
shared across your teams some key did
you know in docker registry deleting a
repository is not a reversible action so
if you delete a repository it's gone so
let's go into the final stage here which
is the actual docker container itself so
the docker container itself um is an
executable package of applications and
its dependencies bundled together so
gives all the instructions that you
would have for the solution that you're
looking to run it's actually really
lightweight and again this is because of
the redundancy that's built into how you
structure the container and the
container itself is then inherently also
extremely portable what's really good
about running a container though is that
it does run completely in isolation so
you're able to share it very easily from
grouped group and you are guaranteed
that even if you are running a container
it's not going to be impacted by any
host os peculiarities or unique setups
as you would have in a vm or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a docker
environment they can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vm you
would have a defined amount of memory
for each vm environment the challenge
you start running into though is that
you can't share that memory whereas with
docker you can easily share the memory
um for a single environment across
multiple containers
the actual container is built using
docket images and the command to
actually run those images is a run
command all right so let's actually go
through a basic structure of how you
would run a docket image so you go into
terminal window and you would write a
docker run redis and then it would run a
container called redis so we're going to
go in and if you don't have the redis
image locally installed it will then
pull it from the registry then the new
docker container redis will be then
available within your environment so you
can actually start using it so let's
look at why containers are so
lightweight they're so lightweight
because they really have been able to
get away from some of the additional
layers that you have in virtualization
within vms and the biggest one is the
hypervisor and the need to run on a host
operating system those are two big big
elements so if you can get rid of those
then you're doing great so let's look at
some of the more advanced concepts
within the docker environment and we're
going to look at two advanced components
one is docker compose and the second is
docker swamp so let's look at docker
compose docker compose is really
designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
apache server with my sql database and
you need to create additional containers
to run additional services without the
need to start each one separately and
this is where you would write a set of
files using docker compose to be able to
help balance out that demand
so let's now look at docker swarm so
docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
docker environments within a single
platform so what you actually are
looking at doing is within your docker
swamp is we're treating each node as a
docker daemon and we're actually having
an api that's interacting with each of
those nodes there are two types of node
that you're going to be getting
comfortable working with one is the
manager node and the second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node is the one sending out the
instructions to all of the worker nodes
but there is a two-way communication
that is happening the communication
allows for the imagine node to be able
to manage the instructions and then
listen to receive updates from the
working node so if anything happens
within this environment the maginot can
react and adjust the architecture of the
worker node so it's always in sync it
was really great for
large scaled environments so finally
let's go through what are some of the
basic commands you would use within
docker and once we've gone through all
these basic commands we'll actually show
you a demo of how you'd actually use
them as well so if we're going to go in
probably the first command is to install
docker and so if you have yum installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto your computer
to start the docker daemon as you want
to do a system ctl start docker the
command to remove a docker image as
docker rmi and then the image id itself
and that's not the image name that's the
actual alphanumeric id number that you
want to uh grab the command line to
download a new image is docker pull and
then the name of the image you'd want to
pull and by default you're going to be
pulling from the docker default registry
that will then connect to your docker
daemon and download the images from that
registry client the command line to run
an image is docker run and then the
image id
and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from docker hub then
we would have a docker pull and then the
image name and colon its tag to pull
build an image from a docker file you
would do docker build
t and then the image name and colon tag
to shut down the container you do docker
stop container id the access for running
a container is docker exec it container
id bash
so we've gone through all the different
commands but let's actually see how they
would actually look and we're going to
go ahead and do a demo so welcome to
this demo where we're going to go ahead
and put together all of the different
commands that we have outlined in the
presentation for docker uh first is just
to list all of the docker images that we
have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull
and then the name of the image that we
want to pull which is going to be my
sequel
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest my sequel
command my sql image that we have so
it's now go ahead and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download almost there
once that's done we're going to go ahead
and do is we'll actually
run the docking container and create the
new container using the image that we
just downloaded but we have to wait for
this to download first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run
dash d
dash
p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon
colon 80
and then put in my sequel
call on
latest so we have the latest version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do
sudo docker
ps
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do
ps-a
and yes there we are we can see that we
do have our new container my sql latest
and it was created 36 seconds ago
but it's in the exit mode so what we
have to do is we have to change that
status so it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run
dash
t
dash dash
name
and we can name it
sl
sql
uh mysql
slash spin slash
dash
and that's now gonna be in the root and
we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the docking containers we
should see it is now
an active container
sudo docker
start
and then we'll start the scene
and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
state excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're going to do is check the list
of images that we have
and to sudo docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sql is listed and what we want
to do is delete my sql and to do that
we're going to type in
sudo docker rm-f
image
mysql
run that command and what we'll find is
the image there's no such image oh okay
so what we actually have to do is we
have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
it's exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image id as well
however if an image is running
and active we have to kill that image
first so we'll go ahead and we're going
to select the image id we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to do
so we do sudo darker kill
and just kill sl and that will kill the
container and now
we'll see that the container has gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image going
with image id boom
easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
well so here we are we've listed all of
the uh
containers and they're all gone so let's
go into the next exercise final exercise
which is to actually
create a batch image
and we do a batch http image so let's go
ahead and write that out so it's going
to be docker
run
dash
did
dash dash
name
white is that's going to be the name of
this http service dash p
8080 colon 80
v
open quotes
dollar sign pwd
close quotes
colon
slash usr
slash local
slash
apache2
slash htdocs
slash
httpd
semicolon 2.4
we'll run that
put in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or see what ports are
running so let's do
sudo images
and see which ports are being used
because it's either the the port or the
name
hasn't been put in correctly so sudo
docker images
ps
pseudo docker
ps-a
and
yep
let's port 80 there
so we clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because i think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila
here we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser
and we'll type in
as soon as firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running
and today i'll be showing you how you
can install the configuration management
tool ansible so let's have a brief about
why one would use ansible and what
exactly is ansible so if you consider
the case of an organization it has a
very large infrastructure which means it
has more than probably hundreds of
systems and giving one or even a small
team of people the responsibility to
configure all these systems makes their
work really tough repetitive and as you
know manual work is always prone to
errors so ansible is a tool which can
automate the configuration of all these
systems with ansible a small team of
system administrators can write simple
codes in guyamal and these codes are
deployed onto the hundreds and thousands
of servers which configures them to the
desired states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's the server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
creates our ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible hosts
file and there we'll specify the details
of our node or client machine
so this is a ansible host file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses or
certain hostname so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system takes place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the root's password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write our
playbook so playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook
so name
and i'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest date of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our note system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
ok because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to our note system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running state and the web
page that we created should be hosted so
let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible a very warm welcome to all our
viewers i'm anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be taking you through a
tutorial on ansible so ansible is
currently the most trending and popular
configuration management tool and it's
used mostly under the devops approach so
what will you be learning today you
learn why you should use ansible what
exactly is ansible the ansible
architecture how ansible works the
various benefits of ansible and finally
we'll have a demo on the installation of
apache or the http package on our client
systems we'll also be hosting a very
simple web page and during this demo
i'll also show you how you can write a
very simple playbook in yemen and your
inventory file
so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where sam is a system
administrator sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure
a company's infrastructure basically
consists of all its systems this could
include your web servers your database
servers the various repositories and so
on so as a system administrator sam
needs to ensure that all the systems are
running the updated versions of the
software now when you consider a handful
of systems this seems like a pretty
simple task sam can simply go from
system to system and perform the
configurations required but that is not
the case with an organization is it an
organization has a very large
infrastructure it could have hundreds
and thousands of systems so here is
where sam's work gets really difficult
not only does it get tougher sam has to
move from system to system performing
the same task over and over again this
makes sam bored not just that repeating
the same task leaves no space for
innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and chef
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits here she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks
playbooks are written in yaml yaml
stands for yaml ain't a markup language
and it is honestly the easiest language
to understand and learn since it's so
close to english we also have the
inventory the inventory is a file where
you have all your nodes that require
configuration mentioned and based on the
kind of configuration they require they
are also grouped together so later in
the demo we'll have a look at how the
playbook and the inventory is written
and that will probably make it clearer
so of course the local machine needs to
communicate with the client and how is
this done this is done through ssh ssh
is your secure shell which basically
provides a protected communication in an
unprotected environment
okay so we saw the various components of
ansible now how does ansible exactly
work you have your local machine on one
end this is where you install ansible if
you have gone through any previous
material on ansible you would have come
across the term agentless often being
associated with the stool so this is
what agentless means you're installing
ansible only on your local machine and
there's no supporting software or plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have no agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks
onto the notes and thus it's called a
push configuration tool now the
playbooks and the inventory are written
at the local machine and the local
machine connects with the nodes through
the ssh client this step here is
optional but it's always recommended to
do so it's where the facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node now all this is collected
from the node and sent to the local
machine so when the playbook is executed
the tasks mentioned in the playbook is
compared against the current status of
the note and only the changes that are
required to be made further are made and
once the playbooks are executed your
notes are configured to the desired
states so as i mentioned before ansible
is currently the most trending tool in
the market under the configuration
management umbrella so let's have a look
at the various benefits of ansible which
gives it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client and node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick ansible is
also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to english as you can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run n number of systems it would have
the same effect on all of these systems
without any side effect and finally we
have automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these stars are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks run successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the actual
hands-on let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so i'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both centos 7
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
i'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminals open right
now so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our host file so a host
file here is basically the inventory
it's where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2.127
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaml
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned clients group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we are doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation and when it comes to
yaml although it's very simple to write
and very easy to read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under task
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name
so yeah that's pretty much it so when
you write your yaml file the language is
pretty simple very readable indentation
is absolutely necessary make sure all
your spaces are correctly placed we can
now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook
is ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbook is executed as you can
see here gathering facts that's where
all the facts of the note that the
present state of the note is collected
and sent to the local machine so it's
basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make is already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
so that was very simple wasn't it
if you have any doubts about the
procedure or any other part of the
tutorial please post your doubts in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as we see them as you
probably already know chef is a
configuration management tool so that
basically means that chef is a tool
which can automate the entire process of
configuring multiple systems it also
comes with a variety of other
functionalities which you can check out
in our video on what a chef and the chef
tutorial so before we move on to the
installation process let me just explain
to you in brief the architecture of chef
so chef has three components there's the
workstation which is where the system
admin sits and he or she writes the
configuration files here your second
system is the server the server is where
all these configuration files are stored
and finally you have the client or the
node systems so these are the systems
that require the configuration you can
have any number of clients but for a
demo to keep it simple we'll just have
one client now i'm using my oracle vm
virtualbox manager as you can see here
i'll have two machines the master and
the node both of these are sent to s7
machines as of the server we'll be using
this as a service on the cloud so let's
begin let's have a look at our master
system first this is my master system
the terminals open over here and the
terminal color here it's black
background with green text
and this is my note system so the
terminal here has a black background
with white text so you can differentiate
between the both so we start at our
master system the first thing we need to
do is we need to download the chef dk so
you can write w get which is the command
for downloading and then go to your
browser and just type chef dk here
the first link
so here you have different versions of
chef dk depending on the operating
system that you're using you need to
select the appropriate one i'm using the
red hat enterprise version and that's
number seven so i'm using centos 7 so
this is my link for downloading chef dk
just copy this link and go back to your
terminal
and paste it here
so your chef dk is being downloaded this
will take a while right after we
download the chef dk our next step is to
install it on our system
so our chef dk is downloaded now let's
install it
so guys this is the version of chef dk
that you have downloaded so make sure
this is exactly what you type down here
too
so great our chef dk is installed so
basically our installation for the
workstation is done right now but just
so you understand how the flow is we'll
also write a sample recipe on our
workstation so before we do that let's
first create a folder
my folder name chef repo basically the
chef repository
and let's move into this folder
okay so we're in next what we need to do
is as i mentioned earlier all your
recipes will be within a cookbook so
let's create a folder which will hold
all our cookbooks
and let's move into this too
okay so our next stage is to create the
actual cookbook within which we'll have
our recipe so the command for creating
the cookbook is chef generate
cookbook
sample because so samples the name of my
cookbook so guys please notice here cook
books is the directory that i created
which will hold all our cookbooks and
here cookbook is the key word so sample
is that one cookbook that we are
creating under our folder cookbooks
and our cookbook is being created great
so that's done moving into a kobo
okay so when our cookbook sample was
created automatically there's this
hierarchical structure associated with
it so let's have a look at this
hierarchical structure to understand
what our cookbook sample exactly is
before we move on so the command for
looking at a hierarchical structure is
tree so as you see here within our
cookbook we have a folder recipes and
under this this the default.rb recipe
this is where we'll be creating our
recipe so we'll just alter the content
of default.rb so let's move on to
finally writing our recipes so we'll
move into this recipes folder first
so now we'll open our recipe defaulted
rb in g edit
so the recipe for this particular demo
is to install the httpd package on our
client node that is basically your
apache server and we'll also be hosting
a very simple web page so let's begin
so the recipes in chef is written in
ruby
so i'll explain you the recipe in a
while
okay so the first line is where you
install httpd the second line for
service is where you start or enable the
http service on the client node that's
our first task the second part is where
we need to create our web page
so this is the part where your web page
will be stored
if you have written any html file
previously you know that this is
probably like a default path where our
web pages are created
yep that's it so this is the content
that will be displayed on your web page
if everything works right and i'm pretty
sure it will so now we can save our
recipe and that's done close here gerry
so now that we have created the recipe
all our work at the workstation is
completed the next thing we do is we
move on to the server so as i mentioned
earlier we'll be using the server as a
service on the cloud
so go to your browser and here just type
manage dot chef dot io
so this is the home page of your chef
server
click here to get started we need to
first create an account for using the
chef server this completely free we just
need to give our email id and a few
other details it's in fact a lot like
creating an account on facebook or
instagram
fill in all the details
check the terms of service box
so the next thing you need to do is go
back to your inbox and verify your email
id so i have my inbox opened here on my
windows machine so this is my inbox you
would have received a mail from chef
software just click on this link to
verify it and create your password
and that's done so let's continue this
on our workstation machine
so type in your username and password
so the first time you log into your chef
server you'll have this pop-up appear
where you need to create a new
organization so create your organization
so this organization is basically the
name that will be associated with the
collection of the client machines first
thing you do go to your administration
tab and download the starter kit so guys
when you're doing this part make sure
that you're on your workstation that is
your opening your shep server on the
workstation because you need this folder
to be installed here
you save the file so this gets
downloaded so the shift starter kit is
the key to connecting your workstation
with the server and the server with the
node so basically it has a tool called
knife which we'll come across later in
our demo this knife is what takes care
of all the communication and the
transferring of cookbooks between the
three machines in our case the two
machines the workstation and the node
and the one server so let's go back to
our root directory
so our chef starter zip file is within
our downloads folder what we do first is
we'll move the sip folder into our
cookbooks folder and then we'll unzip it
there because our cookbooks folder is
the one that contains the recipe and
that is where we require knife tool
command to be present so we can send
this recipes over to the server
so we'll just check the contents of our
cookbooks right now to ensure that our
chef starter.zip file is within the
cookbooks
yep so it's here so next thing we do is
we need to unzip this folder
great so that's unzipped
and this means that our workstation and
our server are now linked
so we just need to use the knife command
tool to transfer or to upload our
recipes which we created on the
workstation onto the server so before we
execute this command we need to move
into our cookbooks directory as you know
that is where we unzipped our chef's
starter kit so that is where our knife
command is present to
and now let's execute the knife command
so it's knife
cookbook
upload and sample so as you probably
recall sample is the name of the
cookbook that we created and within
sample we created our recipe which is
default.rb so we're uploading the entire
cookbook onto the server execute the
command
great so our cookbooks uploaded now
let's check this on our server so move
to your browser where you opened your
chef server and go to policy so here you
go this is the cookbook we uploaded
sample and it's the first time we
uploaded it so the version
0.1.0 the first version now what you
would notice is if you go to the notes
tab there are no notes present so if you
have no nodes you basically have no
machine to execute your cookbooks and
the nodes are not seen right now because
we have not configured them yet so
that's the next thing we need to do all
this so far was done on your master
machine now we'll move on to the node
machine
so before moving on let's just check the
ip of our node machine
so that's our ip note this down
somewhere and now we move back to our
workstation
as we already saw that we uploaded a
sample workbook next thing we need to
make sure that our server and node are
able to communicate with each other so
again we use the knife tool for this
tool
the command here is knife bootstrap and
enter the ip address of your node which
we just checked
we'll be logging in there so we'll be
using the node as the root user
and then we also need to specify our
root password for the node
and we give a name to this node so this
is the name by which we'll be
identifying our node at the server
so as you have probably noticed here
we're using the term ssh which is a
secure shell so it basically provides a
channel of secure communication between
two machines in an unsafe environment
okay so it's done so if your command has
executed right which in our case as we
can see has our chef's server and our
chef node must be able to communicate
with each other so if this is so we
should be able to send the cookbook that
we previously uploaded from our
workstation onto the server now from a
server to our node so to do that before
we move on to the node machine we need
to go back to our chef's server let's
refresh this page
and as you see here previously under the
notes tab we did not have any node
mentioned now we do chef node which is
the node we wanted to identify our node
by which is a centos platform and that's
our ip so it's active for two hours
that's the uptime last check-in the last
time we checked into our node was a
minute back and yeah that's pretty much
it so now we'll create a run list and
we'll add a sample to this run list
so just click on your node and you'll
see the small arrow here in the end
click on that
edit run list and under available
recipes we have a cookbook sample
present so drag and drop this to the
current run list and accept it okay so
now that we updated our run list our
recipe is sent to our node what we next
need to do is that we need to execute
this at our node so now we'll move on to
our node machine
shift client is the command to execute
your
so while this recipe is executing you
can see what exactly is happening our
recipe was to install http package first
which is your apache server so the first
line that's done and it's up to date the
second line it's enabled third line the
service is started and the fourth line
is where your contents created for the
web page at this very location so by the
look of this everything should work fine
so how do we check this we can just go
to our browser
and the search bar just type localhost
and there you go so our httpd package
which is the patchy server is installed
and our sample webpage is also hosted
congratulations on completing the chef
demo so if you look at the devops
approach or the devops life cycle you
will see that chef falls under
operations and deployment so before we
begin let's have a brief look at all
that you'll learn today first we'll get
to know why should we use chef and what
exactly is the chef two of the most
common terms used with chef
configuration management and
infrastructure as code we'll have a
brief look at these we'll also have a
look at the components of chef and the
chef architecture quickly go through the
various flavors of chef and finally
we'll wrap it up with the demo a demo on
the installation of apache on our notes
so let's begin guys why should we use
chef well consider a large company now
this company caters to a large number of
clients and provides n number of
services or solutions of course to get
all of this done they need a huge number
of servers and a huge number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure now this infrastructure
needs to be continuously configured and
maintained in fact when you're dealing
with an infrastructure that size there's
a good chance systems may be failing and
in the long run as your company expands
new systems may even get added so what
do you do well you could say the company
has the best system administrator out
there but all by himself could he
possibly take care of an infrastructure
that size no he can't and that's where
chef comes in because chef automates
this entire process so what does chef
provide chef provides continuous
deployment so when you look at the
market space today you see how products
and their updates are coming out in a
matter of days so it's very important
that a company is able to deploy the
product the minute it's ready so that
once it's out it's not already obsolete
chef also provides increased system
robustness as we saw chef can automate
the infrastructure but in spite of this
automation there's a good possibility
that errors do creep in
chef can detect all these bugs and
remove them before deploying them into
the real environment not only this chef
also adapts to the cloud we all know how
today the services tools solutions
everything is revolving around the cloud
so chef does really play along by making
itself easily integratable with the
cloud platform so now that you know why
to use chef let's look at what exactly
is chef chef is an open source tool
developed by ops code
of course there are paid versions of
chef such as chef enterprise but other
than that most of it is freely
accessible chef is written in ruby and
airline if you would have gone through
any previous material on chef i'm sure
you would have come across ruby being
related to chef but not erlang so this
is why because ruby and erlang are both
used to bill chef but when it comes to
actually writing the codes in chef it's
just ruby and these are the codes that's
deployed onto your multiple servers and
does the automatic configuration and
maintenance and this is why chef is a
configuration management tool so i've
used this term configuration management
a couple of times what exactly does this
mean let's start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and what
are these practices for these practices
are for managing your entities the
entities which are required for
efficient deployment so what are these
entities that you need for efficient
deployment they are code infrastructure
and people code is basically the code
the system administrators write for
configuring your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers and then
finally you have the teams that take
care of this infrastructure so codes
need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructure's
configuration needs to change and
finally of course the people need
coordination so if you have a team of
system administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person b c
d and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes pushes these files onto the
node so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pull against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files shelf follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's tim tim's a system
administrator at a large company now he
receives a task he has to set up a
server and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins he
sets up the server but then it hits him
it would take him the entire night to
install 20 software applications
wouldn't things have been much simpler
if he just had a code to do so well of
course codes do make things much simpler
codes have a number of advantages
they're easily modifiable so if today
tim is told we need mysql installed on
20 systems tim simply writes a code to
do so and the very next day tim is told
we changed our mind we don't need maya
skill i think we'll just use oracle this
does not bother him because now he just
opens the file he makes a few
corrections in his code and that should
work just fine code is also testable so
if tim had to write ten commands to do
something and at his tenth command he
realized the very first command he wrote
there was something not right there well
that would be quite tiresome wouldn't it
with codes however you can test it even
before running it and all the bugs can
be caught and corrected codes are also
deployable so they're easily deployable
and they're deployable multiple times so
now that we saw the various advantages
of having codes let's say what
infrastructure as code exactly is here's
the definition infrastructure as code is
a type of it infrastructure where the
operation team manages the code rather
than a manual procedure so
infrastructure as a code allows the
operations team to take care of a code
which automatically performs various
procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of chef are written in
ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes oh hi is
a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the chef client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
source you have simply learn 3.erb erb
is the extension for your ruby files so
the cookbooks are only created at the
workstation they now need to be sent
over to the server where they are stored
and this is the task of the knife knife
is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
db where simply db is the name of the
cookbook we then move on to our node
machines at our nodes we run the ohi
service the ohi service will collect all
information regarding the current state
of your notes and send it over to the
chef client when you run the chef client
these informations are sent over to the
server and they are tested against the
cookbooks so if there is any discrepancy
between the current state of your notes
and the cookbook that is if one of the
notes does not match the configurations
required the cookbook is then fetched
from the server and executed at the node
this sets the note to the right state
there are various flavors of chef we'll
quickly go through these first we have
chef solo with chef solo there's no
separate server so your cookbooks are
located on the node itself now this kind
of configuration is used only when you
have just a single node to take care of
the next flavor is the hosted chef with
hosted chef you still have your
workstation and your node but your
server is now used as a service on the
cloud this really makes things simple
because you don't have to set up a
server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
chef line server with chef client server
you have a workstation you have server
and you have n number of nodes now this
is the traditional chef architecture
this is the one we have used for all the
explanations previously and finally we
have private chef private chef is also
known as enterprise chef in this case
your workstation server and node all are
located within the enterprise
infrastructure this is the main
difference between chef client server
and private chef in case of shep client
server all these three machines could be
dispersed the enterprise version of chef
also provides the liberty to add extra
layers of security and other features
and we reach the final part of our video
where we'll have the hands-on so before
we dive into our demo let me just
quickly give you an introduction to it
we'll be using two virtual boxes both
sent to s7 one will be used as
workstation while the other will be a
node so we are just using one node to
make things simple the server will be
used as a service on the cloud now these
are the steps we'll be performing during
our demo we'll first download and
install the chef dk on our workstation
we then make an empty cookbook file and
we'll write a recipe into it we need to
then set up the server so as i mentioned
earlier server will be a service on the
cloud so you'll have to create a profile
but this will be completely free we then
link the workstation to the server and
will upload the recipe to the server the
notes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo we begin our demo
here's my oracle vm virtualbox manager i
have two machines here i've already
created my workstation and node both of
these are sent to s7 machines just for
you to differentiate this is my terminal
and for my workstation it's a black
background with white text and as of my
note it's a black background with green
text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for chef dk installation
go to the first link which is your
chef's official page and under red hat
enterprise because our system's a red
hat system
select the link of the version that
you're using so i'm using centos 7 so my
operating system version is 7 so i'll
take this link now this is the link for
downloading your chef dk you copy this
link and go to your terminal guys notice
i'm in the home directory of my root
user so let's install our chef dk
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and chevy case download downloaded next
step we need to install it
and this is the version of the chef dk
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks so first let's
make a chef repository so within that
we'll have a folder for holding all our
cookbooks and within our cookbook we'll
write our recipe so we start with the
directory for chef repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called
cookbooks within which we'll store each
of our cookbooks
move into this
folder
[Music]
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our chef dk we
have a chef repo folder here and let's
check the contents of the chef repo
and this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that we'll be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create our
first cookbook so the instruction for
creating your first cookbook is chef
generate
cookbook
and the name of your cookbook so i'm
just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of our cookbook
let's move into sample
and three is the command for checking
the hierarchy so here as you can see we
have recipes and under recipes we have
default dot rb so we'll be editing this
default.rb to create our recipe okay so
let's begin with that let's move into
our recipes folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for our recipe is
for installing the httpd package
on our node and then we'll also create a
small index file where we'll just have a
simple content such as welcome or
something like that just to check if our
http is working fine so let's begin
typing the code here package httpd
service
httpd
do and what must be done with this
package is that once it's installed it
needs to be enabled
and it needs to be started
and so that's our first task our next
task
is creating our html file
so as you know all your html files will
follow this path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured
your node
and that's it that's our simple code
so our recipe is now ready save it and
exit back to your terminal now what we
need to do is that we need to configure
our server so go to your browser
on the search engine type manage dot
chef dot io
so as i mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your
login page
for the chef server most of you may not
have a profile already so you go to
click here to get started and fill in
the details
it's just like creating an account on
facebook so i already have my account
i've put in the credentials here i'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there is another box for entering a
short form of your organization now my
organization name was simply learn and
the short form was slp123 so when you
come to the administration tab under
organization you can see this
organization name next step click on
this arrow and you gotta download your
starter kit okay so once you click on
down starter kit you'll come to this
page where there's a button for download
starter kit
so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal
so you come back to your terminal and
next what you need to do is you need to
unzip your shiftstarter.zip so for that
first we'll move our chef starter to the
root so it's currently present under the
downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chefstarter.zip now
let's unzip it
first let's just check the contents of
our root directory right now
so we have a chef repository
chef repo fi uh folder that we created
the chef starter zip
that we just moved and of course the
chef dk so now we can unzip our
chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we got
to move the chef
starters.zip file into our cookbooks
which lies inside the chef repository
this is done because we'll be executing
our further commands to connect our
workstation with the server from the
cookbooks because that is where our
sample cookbook is
and that's moved
so now we'll run a knife command so what
knife does is that it uploads your
recipes or your cookbooks onto the
server so here's the command for running
your knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
0.1.0
and uploading sample yeah so our
cookbook is uploaded now let's just
check this at our server how we do that
is
go back to your browser where you have
open your server
so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured our node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server
and you see here our cookbooks uploaded
sample so our workstation and our server
are connected so now we need to connect
our node with the server so first we
move on to our node machine
we need to take the ip address of our
node machine
so for the ip address
we'll just type ifconfig
[Music]
right so this is your ip address
192.168.2.190
[Music]
note this down somewhere guys
now that's done
go back to your workstation
i'll just keep it this way so i can see
both okay go back to your workstations
terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node so we have taken the ip of our
node and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.2 point the username which is
root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node on our server i'm
just giving it chef node you can give it
whatever you like we'll just check the
command knife bootstrap the ip address
ssh user our user which is root
ssh password the password for the root
and finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to our browser open
our server service on the cloud and
we'll check the node tab so ideally your
node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here our chef client service on
the node has started running so let's
just check this with the server
go to your nodes
and here we go so chef node a centos 7
platform
this is our ip so it's all done so now
we need to add a cookbook to the run
list of this node so come here click on
this arrow
edit run list here's sample this is the
cookbook that we want to run on our node
put on the current run list and here we
have the run button just click on that
so this should have transferred our
cookbook onto the node let's check that
go to your node machine
clear this
we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we are running it once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list the changes in
the run list is updated
so in 1 minute 56 seconds
our cookbook has
run
on our note so the configuration changes
should have been made
let's check that it's pretty simple just
go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our html page that we created
on our workstation congrats you
configured your first note and i really
hope you did so that is the end of our
demo we have successfully installed the
httpd package
on our node and we have also executed a
html file anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be showing you the
installation procedure for the
configuration management tool puppet so
what exactly is the use of puppet if you
consider the scenario of an organization
which has a very large infrastructure
it's required that all the systems and
servers in this infrastructure is
continuously maintained at a desired
state this is where puppet comes in
puppet automates this entire procedure
thus reducing the manual work so before
we move on to the demo let me tell you
what the architecture of puppet looks
like so puppet has two main components
you have the puppet master and the
puppet client the puppet master is where
you write the configuration files and
store them and the puppet client are
basically those client machines which
require the configuration in case of
puppet these configuration files that
you write are called manifests so let's
move on to the demo so here are my two
machines the first is the server system
which is basically a master where you'll
write your configuration files and the
others the node or the client system so
let's have a look at both of these
machines this my node system the
terminals open here and the terminal has
a black background with white text
and as of my server or the master
machine it has a black background with
green text
so we started our server machine the
first thing that we need to do is we
need to remove the firewall so in a lot
of cases there are chances that the
firewall stops the connection between
your server and your note now since i'm
doing a demo and i'm just showing you
how puppet works between two virtual
boxes i can safely remove the firewall
without any worries but when you're
implementing puppet in an organization
or a number of systems on a local
network be careful about the
consequences of doing so
so our firewall is disabled next thing
that we do is we'll change the hostname
of our server system now while using the
puppet tool it's always advisable that
you name your server's host as puppet
this because the puppet tool identifies
the hostname puppet by default as the
host name for the master or the server
system
let's just check if the host name has
changed successfully
yup so that's done so as you see still
localhost is appearing as the hostname
so just close your terminal and start it
again
and you see here the hostname has been
changed to puppet okay so the next thing
that we have to do is we install our
puppet labs make sure your system is
connected to the net
right so puppet labs is installed next
we need to install the puppet server
service on our server system
now that our puppet server service is
installed we need to move into the
system configurations for our puppet
server so the path for that is atc
sysconfig puppet server
so this is a configuration file for the
puppet server now if you come down to
this line now this line here this is the
line which allocates memory for your
puppet server now you must remember that
puppet is a very resource extensive tool
so just in case to ensure that we do not
encounter any errors because of out of
memory we will reduce these sizes so as
of now we have 2 gb allocated by default
we'll change this to 512 mb
now in a lot of cases it may work
without doing so but just to be on the
safer side we make this change
save it
and go back to your terminal we are now
ready to start our puppet server service
the first time you start your puppet
server service it may take a while next
we need to enable this
and if your puppet server service is
started and enabled successfully this is
the output that you would get in case
you're still not sure you can always
check the status at any point of time
and as you see here it's active so
everything's fine as of now next thing
we do is we'll move on to our agent
system or our client or node system
so here too we'll have to install puppet
labs but before we do so we need to make
a small change in our hosts file so
let's open the host file
yeah so this is a host file we need to
add a single line here which specifies
our puppet master so first we put our
puppet masters ip address followed by
the host name and then we'll add a dns
for our puppet server so let's just go
back
to our server system and find out its
ip address
and that's my ip address for the server
system
now the host name of our puppet server
and a dns for it
save this file
and return to your terminal
so now we can download our puppet labs
on the node system is the exact same
procedure that you followed for
downloading puppet labs on your server
system too
so in my note system the puppet labs is
already downloaded so the next thing is
we need to install a puppet agent
service
so puppet is a pull type of
configuration tool what this means is
that all your configuration files that
you'll be writing on your server is
pulled by the node system as and when it
requires it so this is the
co-functionality of the agent service
which is installed on your client node
or agent system so my puppet agent
service is installed so next i'll just
check if my puppet server is reachable
from this node system
so 8140 is a port number that the puppet
server must be listening on and it's
connected to puppet so that guarantees
that your server is reachable from the
node system
so now that everything is configured
right we can start our agent service
so guys you would have noticed that the
command for starting the agent service
is a little more complex in the command
for starting your server service this is
because when you start your agent
service you're not just starting a
service but you're also creating a
certificate this is the certificate that
will be sent over to your master system
now at the master system there's
something called the certificate
authority this gives the master the
rights to sign a certificate if it
agrees to share information with that
particular node so let's execute this
command which does both the function of
sending the certificate and starting
your agent service so as you can see
here our services started successfully
it's in a running state now we'll move
to our master system or this server
system
so first we'll have a look at the
certificates that we received
the certificate should be in this
location
so as you can see here this is the
certificate that we just received from
our agent service so this here within
quotes is the name of our certificate so
next when we are signing the certificate
this is the name we'll provide to
specify that this is the particular
certificate that we want to sign so the
minute we sign a certificate the note
that send the certificate gets a
notification that the master has
accepted your request so after this we
can begin sharing our manifest files now
here's the command for signing the
certificate
okay so our certificate is signed
which means that the notes request is
approved and the minute the certificate
is signed the request is removed from
this list so now if we execute the same
command as we did to check the list of
all the certificates we will not find
the certificate anymore let's just check
that so as you see now there are no more
requests pending because we have
accepted all the requests if you want to
have a look at all the certificates that
is signed or unsigned you can use the
same command with the addition of all
and all the certificates received so far
will be listed as you can see here the
plus sign indicates that the certificate
request has already been accepted so now
that our certificate is signed the next
thing we do is we'll create a sample
manifest file
so this is the path that you create your
manifest files in
our file name is sample.pp and our files
created so right now we have no content
in this file we'll just check if the
agent is receiving it and once that's
confirmed we'll add some content to the
file so let's move to our agent system
now this is the command to execute at
the agent system to pull your
configuration files
so a catalog is applied in 0.02 seconds
so now that the communication between
our agent system and our master system
is working perfectly fine let's add some
content to the previous placeholder file
that we created on our master
system so now we open the same file
in an editor
okay so we are going to write a code for
installing the httpd package on our node
system which is basically a apache
service node and then within quotes
insert the host name of your node system
so my node systems hostname is client
the package you wish to install which in
our case is httpd
and the action to be performed
and that's it a very small and simple
code save this file
now let's go back to our node system
and let's pull the second version of the
same configuration file so every time
you execute this command as we did
previously to what happens is the agent
service so the agent service basically
checks on your master system if there's
any new configuration file added or if
there's any change to the previous
configuration file made if so then the
catalog is applied once again so now our
catalog's applied in 1.55 seconds so now
to check if our catalog served its
purpose let's just open a browser
just type localhost here
and as you can see if your httpd package
has been successfully installed the
apache testing page will appear here
today we look into the tutorial on the
configuration management tool puppet so
before we start one thing i'd like to
mention is that puppet falls on the op
side of the devops approach so let's
begin so what will we learn today today
you'll learn about why we should use
puppet what exactly is puppet the puppet
architecture how puppet works and
finally we'll have a demo on the
installation of apache on our known so
let's begin why puppet so consider the
scenario of an mnc the m c puts together
the small team of system administrators
they are responsible for taking care of
the infrastructure of this organization
now this infrastructure could consist of
data centers server centers and many
such components fortunately for the mnc
they were doing extremely well so the
number of clients kept growing
consistently and with this came a boom
in the infrastructure size now here is
where the problem came in with such a
large infrastructure the small team that
they put together in no way could manage
this so what do we do the solution seems
pretty simple right just increase the
size of the team sure we'll increase the
size of team but when do you think we
can put an upper limit on the size when
do we get to stabilize this team so here
is where puppet comes in with puppet a
small team is enough to take care of
this large infrastructure this is
because the data center server centers
all of them can be updated in a matter
of seconds with puppet entire load of
doing so has now shifted from the team
onto the tool not only this with puppet
if servers do fail and there's a very
high chance of servers failing when
you're considering an organization the
scale of an mnc puppet can instantly
roll them back to their previous working
states and if that wasn't enough puppet
also provides the capability to deploy
servers on demand and enforce security
on them now all of this is done through
simple coding which is written in ruby
we look at how puppet works more so now
that we know why we should use puppet
let's have a look at what exactly is
puppet so first and foremost puppet is a
configuration management tool as i
already mentioned in the beginning of
this video so this simply means that
puppet ensures that all your systems are
maintained at a consistent state so
consider that you want to deploy a
number of servers now you require these
servers to be identical if this task is
given to a human there's a very good
chance that those systems will not be
identical or some of them may even fail
humans are prone to errors you cannot
blame them so puppet ensures that all
these servers are deployed on time and
they are identical secondly puppet is
also a deployment tool this simply means
that puppet has the capability to deploy
your applications your services
softwares all of this on your notes
automatically and finally puppet
implements infrastructure as code now
this term infrastructure as code is a
very important one when it comes to the
devops approach you would have noticed
this term being used in our previous
video on chef 2. if not you can always
click the top right corner to know more
so what does this term infrastructure as
code mean infrastructure's code simply
means that all your policies
your tasks your instructions everything
is written in coded format so in case of
puppet specifically all of this is
written in the ruby language so now that
we know what puppet is let's look into
the puppet architecture
so puppet has a master slave
architecture as you can see here on the
top we have the puppet master and below
we have the puppet clients so the puppet
master is the system where your system
administrator sits the clients are those
systems which require configuration you
can have n number of clients connected
to the puppet master so don't worry we
look into each of these components in
detail firstly we have the puppet master
so the puppet master is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it
so manifest is the first subcomponent of
the puppet master these are the actual
files where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority now as we will see
later in this video the puppet master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of ssl certificates
so when the client sends over the
certificate to the master ca provides
the master the authority to sign these
certificates the minute the master signs
a certificate the master is basically
saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our clients
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we have a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with master slave
architecture so the client so far is not
a client it is just a system and we will
refer to the system as system a so
system a sends over a client certificate
to the master associated with this
client certificate is the host name of
system a now master goes through the
certificate it sees the host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
the signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
i am willing to exchange information
with this system and i do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master signs a certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
these software now all this information
is collected it's called the fact and
it's sent over to the master at the
master this information that is the
facts is compared against the manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against manifest to know if what the
manifest is about to perform is already
performed on these systems so if the
manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured and we reach
the final and the most exciting part of
our video which is the hands-on so today
i'll be showing you how you can use
puppet to install apache on one of your
client machines so we'll be using two
machines here we'll have a server and
we'll have a node machine the server is
essentially your master the node is your
client i'm just using the term server
and node instead because i want to keep
it very close to as they are used in the
commands now both these machines are
going to be sent to a seven machines and
i have oracle vm virtualbox installed on
my machine so on that i've simply
created two virtual boxes both centos 7
of course so before we move on to the
actual demo i'll just take you through
the various steps so first we'll install
the puppet server on our server or
master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start this service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize the certificate and then it
will sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifest
so the manifesto is just the code for
configuration and once that tool is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your catalogs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course is the client so
let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the
hostname the last word you see there
that's the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our
hostname is set so just type hostname
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the ip of this
machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's a command to download the
puppet lag
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2gb
so we are going to reduce the size
mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just change this to xms
m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it open this in the vi
terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
dash
master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running
state and while we executed this command
not only did the service start running
but an ssl certificate was also created
so this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so our certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate the name of the certificate
itself is usually the host name of the
machine so our certificate's name should
be localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
yeah as you can see here the certificate
is signed
sign certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file
we won't be writing anything in this
file as of now so we are just checking
here we are just creating this file and
then we'll go to our client machine and
just check the if we can access this
file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on our client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the httpd
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is a client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just cleared the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache
so as you can see we have successfully
used puppet to install the apache
service on our puppet client
and this is the end of our demo
thanks guys that was a great session now
matthew will help you understand how
chef puppet and ansible are different
from one another we're going to decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it chef puppet antipole
or salt stank all four are gonna go head
to head so let's go through the scenario
of why you'd want to use these tools so
let's meet tim he's our system
administrator and tim is a happy camper
putting and working on all of the
systems in his network but what happens
if a system fails if there's a fire a
server goes down well tim knows exactly
what to do he can fix that fire really
easily the problems become really
difficult for tim however if multiple
servers start failing particularly when
you have large and expanding networks so
this is why tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool and we
need to now decide what would be the
best tool for him because configuration
management tools can help make tim look
like a superstar all he has to do is
configure the right code that allows him
to push out the instructions on how to
set up each of the servers quickly
effectively and at scale all right let's
go through the tools and see which ones
we can use the tools that we're going to
go through are chef puppet and support
and salt stacks and we have videos on
most of these software and services that
you can go and view to get an overview
or a deep dive in how those products
work so let's go and get to know our
contestants so our first contestant is
chef and chef is a tool that allows you
to configure very large environments it
allows you to scale very effectively
across the entire ecosystem and
infrastructure chef is by default an
open source code and one of the things
that you find is a consistent metaphor
for the tools that we recommend on
simplylearn is to use open source code
the code itself is actually written in
language of ruby and erlang and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have apache linux
servers running or you may have a my sql
server running or you may have a python
server running and chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to make a
significant update or a minor update so
there's great communication going back
and forth if we look at the pros and
cons the pros for chef is that there is
a significant following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection of recipes that allow you to
be able to quickly stand up environments
there's no need for you to have to learn
complex recipes the first thing you
should do is go out and find the recipes
that are available it integrates with
git really well and provides for really
good strong version control some of the
consoles are really around the learning
speed it takes to go from beginner user
with chef to being an expert there is a
considerable amount of learning that has
to take place and it's compounded by
having to learn ruby as the programming
language and the main server itself
doesn't really have a whole lot of
control it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network all right let's look at our
second contender puppet and puppet is
actually in many ways very similar to
chef there are some differences but
again puppet is designed to be able to
support very large heterogeneous
organization it is also built with ruby
and uses dsl for writing manifests so
there are some strong similarities here
to chef as with a chef there is a master
slave infrastructure with puppet and you
have a master server that has the
manifests that you put together in a
single catalog and those catalogs are
then pushed out to the clients of an ssl
connection some of the pros with uh
puppet is that as with chef there is a
really strong community around puppies
and there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very well
developed reporting mechanism that makes
it easier for you as an administrator to
be able to understand your
infrastructure one of the cons is that
you have to really be good at learning
ruby again as with chef you know the
more advanced tasks really need to have
those ruby skills and as with chef the
server also doesn't have much control so
let's look at our third contender here
ansible and so ansible is slightly
different it is the way the ansible
works is that it actually just pushes
out the instructions to the server
environment there isn't a client server
or master slave environment where
ansible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yawl stands for yaml a markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know xml and xml is pretty easy if
you know xml you're going to get yammo
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focus is
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a playbook and an inventory or
you have a playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
playbook in the playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote nodes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with yamo
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure up and
running is less than other tools that we
have on our list now i do have to add a
proviso this is a relative less it's
still very fast it's going to be a lot
faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and gamma itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as ruby ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
contender here salt stack so sort stack
is a cli based tool it means that you
will have to get your command line tools
out or your terminal window out so you
can actually manage the entire
environment via a salt sac the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yammer or dsl which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient now
the way that salt snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with saltstag so
sourcetech is very easy to use once it's
up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that
saltstack is fairly late in the game
when it comes to actually having a
graphical user interface for being able
to create and manage your environment
other tools such as ansible have
actually had a ui environment for quite
some time all right so we've gone
through all four tools let's see how
they all stack up next to each other so
let the race begin let's start with the
first stage architecture so the
architecture for most of our
environments is a server client
environment so for chef puppet and salt
snack so very similar architecture there
the one exception is ansible which is a
client only solution so you're pushing
out the instructions from a server and
pushing them out into your network and
there isn't a client environment that
there isn't a two-way communication back
to that main client for what's actually
happening in your network so let's talk
about the next stage ease of setup so we
look at the four tools there is one tool
that really stands out for ease of setup
and that is ansible it is going to be
the easiest tool for you to set up and
if you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration before looking
at other tools now and so with that said
chef puppet and sourcetag aren't that
hard to set up either and you'll find
there's actually some great instructions
on how to do that setup in the online
community let's talk about the languages
that you can use in your configuration
so we have two different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural in that they actually
specify at how you actually supposed to
do the task in your instructions with
puppet and stack it's decorative where
you specify only what to do in the
instructions let's talk about
scalability which tools scale the most
effectively and as you can imagine all
of these tools are designed for
scalability that is the driver for these
kind of tools you want them to be able
to scale to massive organizations what
do the management tools look like for
our four contenders so again we have a
two-way split with ansible and sort
stack the management tools are really
easy to use you're going to love using
them they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl or the ruby dsl to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and soft stack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular cloud environments and
puppet and chef are actually available
in both amazon and azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our chef link here but chef is
now available on azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses ssl to secure
sockets layer and ansible and saltstack
use secure socket hashing and ssh as
their communication tool bottom line all
four tools are very secure in their
communication so who wins well here's
the reality all four tools are very good
and it's really dependent on your
capabilities and the type of environment
that you're looking to manage that will
determine which of these four tools you
should use the tools themselves are open
source so go out and experiment with
them there's a lot of videos our team
has done a ton of videos on these tools
and so feel free to find out other tools
that we have then covered so you can
learn very quickly how to use them but
consider the requirements that you have
and consider the capabilities of your
team if you have ruby developers or you
have someone on your team that knows
ruby your ability to choose a broader
set of tools becomes much more
interesting if however you're new to
coding then you may want to consider
yaml-based tools again the final answer
is going to be up to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is please post in the comments below
which tool you have decided to go with
and what are the challenges that you're
i'm coming up with because we'll help
answer those challenges for you thanks
matthew now we have anjali to tell us
how you can become a devops engineer
devops is a collaborative approach just
taken up by most companies these days it
focuses on scaling up and making the
entire process of scaling up much
smoother so no doubt companies are
actively looking out for devops
engineers welcome to another tutorial
with simply learn i'm anjali and today
we'll be looking into how you can become
a devops engineer so let's begin so by
definition devops is a collaboration
between the development and the
operations team which enables continuous
delivery of application and services to
the end users so let's expand on this
definition first the development team is
the one that actually produces the
products the operation team is related
with the management or the maintenance
of these products now there's a link
that devops forms between these two
teams which makes this entire process
much smoother and this approach this
collaborative approach is what's called
devops so devops focuses on continuous
delivery of application which means that
when the development team is ready with
the product it immediately goes into the
maintenance or the management phase and
it's then pushed on to the end users
with minimum delay just in case you
doubt the stand of devops today or its
growth in the near future you must know
that according to the information week
devops will be in high demand for
upcoming years and has no chance of
slowing down also according to linkedin
over the past few years devops has
increased in demand by 50 percent now
that's quite a lot of growth so clearly
devops is a field that will be great to
dive into and grow in so before we begin
how you can actually become a devops
engineer let's look at what we'll be
going through in this video first we
look at who is a devops engineer
followed by the devops career roadmap
we'll then look into a devops
certification and then finally the
salary trends for a devops engineer so
who is a devops engineer now a devops
engineer is an i.t professional who
understands the software development
lifecycle and when i say software
development lifecycle i do not just mean
the devops approach but right from a
waterfall model which is a traditional
software development life cycle and then
as you know we moved on to the agile and
finally we reached the devops life cycle
so a devops engineer needs to understand
the whole purpose of this life cycle why
we had to move from one model to the
other what are the shortcomings that the
previous models had and what all does
devops make up for also other than
understanding this entire process they
also need to know how to use the various
automation tools for developing the
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipelines so of course your
next question must be what is the
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipeline as you can see on
your right we have an image of this
pipeline so there are various stages so
first you have your planning stage where
you plan things out and write an
algorithm for your product then it's the
building stage where the algorithm
actually transforms into a code and is a
product which could be used then you
have the testing stage in the testing
stage your product is tested all the
bugs are caught and all of this is
corrected and once all of that's done
it's then sent to the deployment stage
which means now your product is ready to
be deployed once it's deployed of course
a product needs continuous monitoring
this is now something new which has been
introduced in the devops lifecycle that
although your product is out in d now
the monitoring stage is something that
the devops approach focuses on much more
than our previous models and for very
good reason which is that once your
product is deployed into the real world
to ensure customer satisfaction it's
important that you continuously monitor
the product this way you're able to
catch the bugs fix them and push it back
to the clients and ensure that they are
happy with your product and would go for
it again now in simple words a devops
engineer is expected to collaborate with
the developers and the operations team
to deliver high quality products within
a minimum amount of time now devops
engineer as such is not a profile that
you might come across very often but of
course there are a number of career
paths that you can take under the devops
engineer but of course there are a
number of career paths under a devops
engineer some of these are the devops
architect automation engineer software
tester integration specialist security
engineer and release manager now let's
look at the devops career roadmap so
basically if you're looking forward to
bagging that devops engineer job where
should you start and how should you go
about it first thing first there are a
few programming languages which go hand
in hand with the devops tools you need
to pick up these and also know the linux
fundamentals devops uses these
programming languages for developing and
automating software now three most
common languages used with the devops
tools are ruby python and javascript it
is always advised that you know at least
one of these of course we must consider
the fact that these three languages are
used with completely different tools so
knowing just one of these languages does
not mean that you can now work with any
tool under the devops approach but it
does give you a good hang of at least
one of them which is more than most can
say it's also important to know the
fundamentals of the linux command line
interface of course this is not very
unique to devops whichever career path
you are choosing linux fundamentals is
one of the most important things let's
now discuss some of the mandatory linux
skills that devops engineers should be
aware of the first is of course the
linux shell now you must either know
bash or the kernel shell then it's the
linux commands now there are a huge
number of linux commands but the basic
ones you must know no matter what are
the find grep awk and the set command
and finally we have the networking
commands ns lookup which is for querying
the dns and netstat for monitoring your
connections our next milestone would be
learning the source code management now
source code management is especially
important when you're dealing with huge
projects so that all your codes
irrespective of the number of files you
have or the number of versions of a
particular code you have everything is
organized and can be easily accessible
so it's important that you're
comfortable with at least one of these
source code management tools here the
most common ones we see are git cvs and
mercurial i would personally recommend
you to choose git and why git because
git is used to track changes in the
source code it can manage large projects
efficiently and it allows multiple
developers to work together with great
ease now our next stage is to learn to
build applications so a devops engineer
must know how to build an application
and commit to the source code management
tool such as kit now popular tool used
to build applications which makes things
much simpler is maven why maven well it
supports parallel builds instant access
to new features without any additional
configuration and has an easy built
process now maven is actually an
automation tool which helps to build and
manage software projects within a short
period of time so here you have the bom
file which is required to build an
application under which you have set of
jars you have the commands which are to
be executed the builds plugins and the
builds profile but in order to automate
the entire process you require a
continuous integration or a continuous
development tool and this brings us to
our fourth stage which is learning to
automate the process using ci and cd
tools one of the most extensively used
tools in this field is jenkins jenkins
is an open source continuous integration
tool it helps to automate continuous
development testing and deployment of
newly created codes well why jenkins
because it has multiple plugins it is
easily distributed across multiple
machines and has an easy installation
and configuration process our next stage
is to learn to test the applications
once you have completed the build
process learn how to automate the
testing process of web applications one
of the best testing tools for qa teams
is selenium and why selenium above all
the other tools that provide the same
functionality well because it provides
fast execution allows scripting in
several languages and also supports
parallel test execution the next thing
is to learn to deploy applications in
production servers so you should learn
how to deploy and run the applications
in the production servers and in order
to deploy an application you should have
the knowledge of containers such as
docker and configuration management
tools like ansible so docker helps with
the containerization while configuration
management tools such as ansible so
docker helps with containerization while
tools such as ansible helps you to
provide you the capability of pushing
configurations onto multiple servers and
maintaining them in the required state
so why choose docker high scalability
and efficiency reusable data volumes
isolated applications and why ansible
because unlike other tools in this field
it has a push based configuration it is
agentless and uses ssh for secure
connections the next stage is to learn
to monitor the applications so
monitoring your applications is another
important aspect of a devops engineer in
this stage we identify the issue and
implement the changes as quickly as
possible the most popular tool which
provides for monitoring applications is
ngos
it has a comprehensive monitoring system
high availability and immediate
remediation and finally a devops
engineer must know the working of cloud
providers for a devops engineer it's
important to know about the cloud
service providers and their basics cloud
computing is an important skill to learn
irrespective of which field you're in
today as a lot of companies have the
infrastructure on the cloud amazon web
services is the most popular cloud
provider whereas microsoft azure and
google cloud platform are slowly
catching up to amazon amazon web
services provides high scalability and
flexibility is cost effective and
provides better security let's now look
at some of the devops certifications you
can opt for the first one is the aws
certified devops engineer program which
is offered by amazon web services and
then of course we have the devops
certification training offered by our
very own simply learn simply loan also
provides programs which are more
specific to tools such as chef puppet
ansible and selenium certification and
we also provide a devops architect
masters program so now these are some of
the most popular certifications
available in the market let's get a
better idea of what these certifications
provide so we'll move on to the simply
learn web page so here we are on the
landing page for devops certification
training course as you can see here this
course provides 56 hours of in-depth
learning you will be working on more
than 10 real industry projects which are
integrated with the labs there are 24
live demos of the most popular devops
tools you have a 24x7 support dedicated
to mentor you throughout your project
and we also provide self-paced learning
so there are videos which are always
available in case you have a very
stringent timetable let's now look at
some of the tools which are covered
under this course so under build
automation we cover maven among other
tools configuration management this
ansible chef puppet continuous
integration and monitoring tools
includes jenkins steam city docker and
testing frameworks we have eggplant
junit version control bitbucket git so
we are going through a number of tools
but as you can see all the popular ones
are definitely covered other than this
let's also have a quick look at all the
topics that is covered under this course
so we have the course introduction
followed by introduction to devops and
then we focus on the various processes
under devops version control continuous
integration deployment and the build
tools software automation testing
frameworks configuration management
containerization all of this is followed
up by need of cloud in devops and of
course you have practice projects we
also are provided with two free courses
one covering the linux basics and one
with the fundamentals of javascript
since as we have already mentioned these
are two very important skills that a
devops engineer must possess and now
this is the devops architect masters
program offered by simply learn this is
the go to program if you take becoming a
devops engineer seriously as you can see
here guys it covers more than 40 in
demand skills and 15 plus tools you have
access to 120 life instructor-led online
classes you'll also be working on more
than seven real-life projects and at the
end of your entire course you receive
your master's certification there's a
well thought out timeline to proceed
with your course which covers
instructor-led and self-paced classes
your projects and your lab sessions also
some of the tools that we'll be covering
under this program include maven chef
puppet ansible solstack team city
jenkins nagios junaid jit and many more
so guys why procrastinate anymore get on
to simply learns webpage register
yourself to a course and get certified
get ahead of course if you're taking up
a career you must know what kind of
salary to expect an average salary of a
devops engineer in the united states is
dollars per year so this is the average
salary as you can see here guys there's
a graph which shows how there's been a
growth this graph here will give you a
good idea of the salary trend an average
salary of a devops engineer in india on
the other hand is 6 lakh 12 000 per year
so again here we have a graph on the
right which demonstrates the pattern in
growth in the salary now here's some
additional material to prepare yourself
and help you in the journey to becoming
a devops engineer so this is simply
learnt's youtube playlist on devops as
you can see here are a number of videos
to be precise they have 82 videos or 82
tutorials on devops you can start off
with this fun short video on what is
devops it introduces devops to you in
the most basic and fun way possible and
then you have devops tutorial for
beginners what is devops another
tutorial introduction to devops and then
you can follow this up with the
tutorials on the various tools under
devops for example there's get there's
jenkins docker docker swarm ansible chef
puppet a comparison between the various
configuration management tools there are
also devops interview questions part one
and part two which will help you prepare
for your interviews why devops is better
than agile or if it's the other way
around watch this video to find out how
to create your resume for the post of a
devops engineer and so on so there are a
lot of videos here guys you can
definitely go through them provides you
with a lot of information not only that
before you actually take up the simply
learn course to get a better
understanding of the kind of content and
the quality of content that they offer
you can come here and check out their
free courses or their free tutorial
videos i hope this helps we have now
come to the final part of our video
matthew will take you through 80 of the
most important interview questions that
you might face in a devops interview and
today we're going to go through part one
of a two-part series on interview
questions that you are likely to be
asked if you are interviewing for a job
that focuses on devops so there are
approximately seven sections that we
cover in devops we go from general
devops questions source code management
with tools such as git continuous
integration and here we'll focus on
jenkins continuous testing with tools
such as selenium and then you also have
the operation side of devops which is
your configuration management with tools
such as chef puppet and ansible
containerization with docker and then
continuous marching with tools such as
nagios the first video is going to zero
in on the left hand side of the screen
we're going to zero in on those general
devops questions source code management
continuous integration then continuous
testing our second video is gonna get
into the operations tools and we'll get
into that and the next time you come
back above me there's probably a link
that will take you straight to that
video so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
over the last five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
agile delivery which is on sprint to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around devops
the whole concept of devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and op team
another area in which i see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chat bot or any digital solution that
you have and has an expectation when
you're going through and actually doing
a devops paradigm the old model would be
that you would capture requirements from
the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there would be these barriers between
each of those as we move faster through
from waterfall to agile what we saw is
that with agile we were able to respond
much faster to customer demands so
instead of it being weeks or months
sometimes in some cases years between
releases of software what we saw it
would was a transition to weeks and
months for releases on software now we
see with devops is that the release
cycle has shrunk even further with the
goal of continuously delighting the
customer how further has that release
cycle shrunk to there are companies that
have gone from having releases of once a
week or once every two weeks or once a
month to now having multiple releases a
day indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out smaller chunks
of code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects
you're going through just very small
micro services or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic from a
customer that's coming to your website
and or to your mobile app they're going
to see responses happening continuously
so that the customer is always aware
that you as a company are listening to
their demands and responding
appropriately you're able to provide a
more stable environment and you're able
to scale that environment to the demands
of the number of customers that are
using your services so how you approach
a project that needs to implement devops
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in so there are effectively
three stages when it comes to actually
working in a dev ops the first stage is
an assessment stage and think of this as
the back of the napkin ideation stage
this is where you are sitting with a
business leader and they're giving you
ideas of what they would like to see
from feedback that they've had from
their customers this is blue sky
opportunity this is thinking of big
ideas that second stage and this often
comes as a fast follow to stage one is
actually proving out that concept so
developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the poc to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the poc so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your dev ops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with devops what
you're also looking at is putting in
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that being delivered
so that once you actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that back into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to backfill the demand of work
that gets completed in the bank log so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production and
ensures that your businesses and
functions are running as you would
expect them to be so it's going through
and completing the code that you'd
actually see continuous deployment in
contrast is all about ensuring that
you're automating the deployment of a
production environment so you're able to
go through and scale up your environment
to meet the demands of both the solution
and the customer this makes software
development and release processes much
more faster and more robust so if we
look here we can actually see where
continuous integration and continuous
deployment come hand in hand so when you
actually start out with the initial
pushes of your code that's where you're
doing your continuous integration and
your continuous delivery and then at
some point you want to get very
comfortable with deploying the code that
you're creating so it's been pushed out
to your production environment one of
the things that's great about working
with the tools that you use in a devops
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment and
what this means is that when you
actually come to deploying solutions to
production there are no surprises
because your development team have been
working against that exact same
environment all the way through so a
question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of the
configuration management in devops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas and the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability to manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before the second area
is that you want to also demonstrate the
business reasons for having
configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
it and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help and maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that with being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24 7 for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify and report those
thoughts or threats immediately and
respond immediately for your entire
network instead of having to wait as it
happens sometimes for a customer to
email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self-audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for devops is amazon's
web services aws and they have really
five distinct areas them that you can
zero in on board services so when the
question comes up what is the role of
aws in devops you want to really hold
out your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that aws and
other cloud providers but aws is
certainly the leader in this space are
great for being able to provide support
for the role of devops so one of the
things that we want to be able to do
effectively when we're releasing any
kind of solution is to be able to
measure that solution and so kpis are
very important so you will be asked for
three important dev of kpis and so three
that really come to mind that are very
effective the first one is mean time to
failure recovery and what this talks
about is what is the average time does
it take to recover from a failure and if
you have experience doing this then look
at the experience you have and use a
specific example where you are able to
demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy solutions and
what actually happens when you're
actually doing those deployments and
what does the impacts to your network
look like when you're doing those
deployments and then the third one is
really tied to that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so and how
many times did you deploy to a server
and something happened where the server
itself failed what we're looking for
when you're going through and being
asked for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're pushing out your
infrastructure and then the second is
being able to validate that
self-auditing ability and one word of
caution is don't go in there and say
that you have a hundred percent success
the reality is that servers do degrade
over time and you maybe want to talk
about a time when a server did degrade
in your environment and use that as a
story for how you're able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so
one of the terms that is very popular at
the moment is infrastructure as code and
so you're going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your devops environment and
infrastructure's code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that xml or ruby or yaml are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
that software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental to
the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as yammer to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
uh source code management with git is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to git is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
version control and if we look at the
way that the two are set up older
technologies such as older versions of
team foundation server though the
current version does actually have git
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in
and check out of code the developer in
the centralized system does not have all
the files uh for the application and if
the centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly onto your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows
for scalability when it comes to
building out your team so if you have a
team that may be in europe you can
actually then scale that team with
people from asia from north america or
south america very easily and not have
to worry about whether or not they have
the right code or the wrong code and in
addition to that if the actual main
server where you're checking in your
code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands you use for working with
git so if you were to be asked the
question is what is the git command that
downloads any repository from github to
your computer on the screen we have four
options we have git push git fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be git clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to a github repository
using git then first of all you want to
be able to do is connect the local
repository to a remote repository and in
the example you may want to talk about
using the command get remote add origin
and then the actual path to a github
repository you could if you want to
actually at this point also talk about
other repositories such as git lab that
you can also work with or a private git
repository that would be used just for
the development team once you've
actually then added the local repository
into your local computer then the second
action you want to use is a push which
is to actually push your local files out
to the master environment so you use the
command git push origin master so one
question you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bare repository and
a standard way of initializing a git
repository so let's look through what is
the standard way so the standard way
using git init allows you to create a
working directory using the command git
in it and then the folder that creates
is the folder that creates all the
revision history related to the work
that you're doing in contrast using the
bear way you have a different commands
for setting that up so it would be git
init dash dash bear and it does not
contain any working or checked out
source files locally on your machine in
addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you'd have with
the normal get in it initialization so
which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv get rm-r or none the
above well in this instance it would be
gate mv a question that you'll be asked
around commit is going to be what is the
process to revert a commit that has
already been pushed and made public and
there are two ways you can address this
the first is to actually address the bad
file in the new commit and you can use
the command git commit dash m and then
put in a comment for why that file is
being removed the second is to actually
create a new commit that actually undoes
all the changes that were made with the
bad commit and then to do that you would
use git revert and then the commit id
and the commit id and it could be
something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the the commit that you had made but
that would allow you to revert any bad
files that you had submitted so the two
ways of being able to get files from a
get repository and you're going to be
asked to explain the difference between
git fetch and get paul so get fetch
allows you to fetch and download only
new data from a root new repository it
does not integrate any of the new data
into your working files and it can be
undone at any time if you wanted to
break out the remote tracking branches
in contrast git pull updates the current
head branch with the latest changes from
the remote server so you get all of the
files and downloaded it downloads new
data and integrates it with the current
working files you have on your system
and it tries to merge remote changes
with your local ones so one of the
questions you'll get asked about git is
what is a gate stash so as a developer
you will be working on the current
branch within a solution but what
happens if you come up with an idea
where it's something that will take a
different amount of time for you to be
able to complete but you don't want to
interrupt the mainline branch so what
you can actually do is you can actually
create a branch that allows you to start
working on your own work outside of the
mainline branch and this is called get
stash allows you to be able to modify
your files without interrupting the
mainline branch so you once you start
talking about branching and get be
prepared to answer and explain the
concept of branching so essentially what
it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the mainline branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called get rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command get diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you would use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two or
more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a highlight of conflict markers and
you'll be able to select which conflicts
you want to keep on which you want to
merge and which ones you want to change
so it's a step through how you would
actually resolve a merge conflict and
the first step would be under github you
want to be able to pull the repository
name and then the pull request around
that repository in the pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve they'll pull up a file that
will list out all of the conflicts for
you near the bottom of that file will be
a list of the requests that need to be
resolved and then if you need to make a
decision on which branches you want to
keep or which ones you want to change
that will have to be something you have
to put in instructions inside of the
file you'll actually see that there are
conflict markers within the instructions
which are going to ask you which files
you want to change which ones you want
to keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in github so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then onto the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all of
the conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use get bash and so when you want to as
a first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local get repository and
command line by using the cd change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide.md
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with github you actually go
through and use a text address and then
use any text editor but as you go
through and edit out what you want to
keep and what you want to
manage in your conflict so you actually
have a resolution that's been created so
that you'll be able to then once you're
using the conflict markers you can
actually merge your files together so
that the solution itself will allow you
to incorporate your commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and applied your changes you're
able to then merge the conflicted
commits into a single commit and able to
push that up to your remote repository
all right let's talk about the next
section which is continuous integration
with jenkins so the first question
you'll be asked about with jenkins is
explain a master slave architecture of
jenkins
so the way that jenkins is set up is
that the jenkins master will pull code
from your remote git repository such as
github and will check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins dot
war java dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins.jar java dash war
jenkins.war
and the answer is a java dash jar
jenkins.war so when working with jenkins
you're going to be asked what are the
key concepts and aspects of working with
a jenkins pipeline and you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the user-defined model of a cd
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to define
dependency in maven and do we have a
build.xml
b
palm.xml c dependency.xml
or d
version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovyscript as
their domain specific language for
jenkins and there are one or more note
blocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side shows what the actual
declaration for each section of that
script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to find the work
completed in a decorative pipeline so
how do you create a copy and backup of
jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
there essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or see you
can actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
hpi plugin file into the jenkins home
plugins subdirectory you want to remove
the plugins development directory if
there is one you want to create an empty
file called
plugin.hpi.pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disable allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running builds to complete before
restart are required in which case you
would use the command of the url for
your jenkins environment slash safe
restart so let's go into the fourth and
final section of this first video which
talks about continuous testing with
selenium so the first question you will
be asked most likely around selenium are
what are the four different selenium
components and again you will want to
hold open your fingers because there are
four distinct environments you have
selenium integrated development
environment or selenium ide you have
selenium remote control or selenium rc
you have selenium web driver and then
selenium grid you'll be asked to explain
each of those areas in more detail but
let's start off with by looking at
selenium driver what are the different
exceptions in selenium webdriver so it's
useful to remember that an exception is
an event that occurs during the
execution of a program that disrupts the
normal flow of that program's
instructions and so we have four we have
a timeout exception an element not
visible exception no such element
exception and a session not found
exception and each of those if we step
through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium web driver so
as we evolve in our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
solutions onto multiple platforms you're
going to be asked can selenium and other
devops tools run
in other environments and so a good
question around this is cancelling them
test an application in an android web
browser and the short answer is
absolutely yes it can we have to use the
android driver for it to be able to work
so you want to be able to talk about the
three different types of supported tests
within selenium so when the question
comes up what are the different test
types supported by silent you can answer
that and there are three different types
of tests first is a functional test
second is a regression test and third is
a load testing test the functional test
is a kind of black box testing in which
test cases are based on a specific area
of feature within the software a
regression test helps you find any
specific areas that functional tests or
non-functional areas of the code
wouldn't be able to detect the load
testing test allows you to monitor the
response
of a solution as you increase the volume
of hits in how you're using the code are
put onto it an additional question
you'll be asked is how can you get a
text of a web element using selenium but
the get command is due to achieve text
of a specific web element it's important
to remember however that the command
does not return any parameters but just
returns a string value so you want to be
able to capture that stream value and
discuss about it a question you'll be
asked around selenium is can you handle
keyboard and mouse actions using
selenium and the answer is yes you can
but you have to make sure that you're
using the advanced user interaction api
and the advanced user interaction api is
something that can be scripted into your
tests and it allows you for
capturing methods such as a click and
hold and drag and drop mass events and
then keyboard down or keyboard up key
release events so that if you want to to
capture say the use of control shift or
a specific function button off the
keyboard you'd be able to capture those
of the following four elements which of
these elements is not a web element
method a get text b
size
c get tag name d send keys and it's b
size you're going to be asked to explain
what is the difference for when we use
find element or find elements and so if
we look at find element find element
finds the first element in the current
web page that matches the specified
located value in contrast
find element finds all of the elements
on the web page that matches the
specified value when using webdriver
what are the driver close and driver
quit commands and these are two
different methods used to close a web
browser session in selenium so driver
close will close the current web browser
which your focus is set and driver quick
closes all the browser windows and ends
the web driver session completely the
final question that you are likely to be
asked in using selenium is how can you
submit a form using selenium well in
this instance that's relatively easy the
following lines of code will let you
submit a form in selenium which would be
web element el equals driver dot find
element and then you put in the id and
the element id and then l submit open
close parentheses semicolon second round
of interview questions following on from
the previous video that we did last week
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go through and cover the following
areas so we've already covered some
areas but as a reminder what devops
really allows us to cover are a number
of areas for interview questions so
there's going to be a general interview
questions source code management
questions continuous integration and
testing questions and then configuration
management containerization and
continuous monitoring we've already
covered part one in the video and there
should be a link at the top of the
screen that'll take you to part one what
we're gonna do in this video is go
through part two where we're gonna deep
dive on configuration management
containerization and continuous
monitoring specifically focusing on
tools such as chef puppet ansible docker
and nagios so let's just get into the
first section which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is why do
you have ssl certificates used for chef
really fundamentally your immediate
answer should be security ssl provides
for a very high level of private
security and private and public key
pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using ssl and you're using the
private public key model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network that chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked um some questions
such as the following which is the
following commands would you use to stop
or disable the http service when the
system boots and you'll typically get
four responses and there'll be
system ctl disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http dot service system disable httpd or
the final option which is system ctl
disable httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag system ctl disable http
dot service so chef comes with a series
of tools that allow it to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is test kitchen and test kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy it
to a real node so some of the commands
that you would use are for instance if
you want to create an instance of test
kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around chef is how does chef apply
differ from chef client so fundamentally
the difference between them is that chef
apply will validate the recipe that
you're working on whereas chef client
looks to apply and validate the entire
cookbook that's run in your server
environment so one is focused on the
recipe and the other is focused on the
entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppets and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version 3. now something to bear in mind
when you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is uh being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira gate and jenkins
so what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class and puppet and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppets of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to answer is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within and support and
really the answer comes down to two
things one is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to it it's a more complicated
but more sophisticated architecture
where you're able to have a complete
environment managed by the puppet
architecture so let's get on to our next
section which is containerization
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the docker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like um again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and certainly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a docker hub and
then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub
and you can use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read only file
system the docker container is a
collection of the runtime instances of a
docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with jason
and my that is something that you should
be uh get comfortable with is you want
to be able to use that to name your
files and as a frame of reference json
is a logical way of being able to do
value paired matching using a javascript
like syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have docker registry
is an open source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing docker
images whereas in contrast for
repository it's a collection of multiple
versions of a docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the registry docker also has
its own default retreat called docker
hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that uh support
docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here amazon web services
microsoft azure google cloud rackspace
but you could add in their ibm bluemix
could put in red hat really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in docker
so if we go through expose is an
instruction used in dockerfile whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p for when we're doing
our command line used in docker and
examples of these are expose 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish would do the example docker run
d dash p and then
0.0.0.80 a colon 80 as our command line
so let's look at continuous monitoring
so with continuous monitoring how does
nagios help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and servers and so
this is really just a high level
question of using nagios within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say
nagios allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they're being
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any task failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with web services and apis that
are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does negatives help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negative process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negatives web interface to be able
to run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagios
remote plug-in executor or the mpre of
nagios so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
cpu load etc what are the ports used by
nagios for monitoring purposes in this
example there are three and they're easy
to remember so i would memorize these
three but they're essentially ports five
six six six five six six seven and five
six six eight so there are two types of
checks within nine years so you will be
asked for what is an active and passive
check in nagios so an active check and
is initiated by the nagios process and
is run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks our results are submitted to
nigeria's for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios daemon negas will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plug-in will then
check the operational state of the host
oil service and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and i guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negotiate may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nagio so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how nagios
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
nagios processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the nagios network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagios
network analyzer are one provides an
in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats 2
allows system admins to gather high
level information on the health of your
network 3 provides a central view of
your network traffic and bandwidth data
and then 4 allows you to proactive in
resolving outages abnormal behavior and
threats before they affect critical
business processes
so what are the benefits of http and ssl
certificate monitorings with nagios so
with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the ssl
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how nagios itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including microsoft visual pc
vmware zen amazon ec2 etc etc so just
make sure you get that right off the bat
nuggets is able to provide capabilities
tomorrow an assortment of metrics on
different platforms it allows for ensure
for quick detection of service and
application failures and has the ability
to be able to monitor against many
metrics including cpu usage memory
networking and vm status so name the
three variables that affect recursion
inheritance in nagios and it is name use
and register so name is a template name
that can be referenced in other object
definitions use specifies the name of
the template object that you want to
inherit its properties and variables
from and register indicates whether or
not the object definition should be
registered to daggers and on the right
hand side of the screen we have an
example of what that script would look
like again you may want to be able to
memorize this as it's something that you
can actually write down and show someone
if you're going through a technical
interview so why is nagios said to be
object oriented and fundamentally comes
down to the object configuration format
that you can use in your object
definitions it allows you to inherit
properties from other object definitions
and this is typical of object oriented
development and is now applied for the
nagios environment so some of the
objects that you can inherit are
services hosts commands and time periods
so finally explain what is state talking
in nagios and so there are really four
options here when you're talking about
state stalking so state stalking is used
for logging purposes in nagios it allows
you to enable for a particular host or
service that nagios will watch over very
carefully it will log any changes it
sees in the output of the check results
and then finally helps the analysis of
log files i hope this will be helpful
for your interviews with that we've
reached the end of this complete devops
tutorial by simplylearn i hope you
enjoyed this video do like and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn
[Music]